Well, we're back.
We're... we're back.
We're...
Dude, I haven't played since...
Since 3 p.m.
But...
We're back.
We're here.
I've been playing since 3 p.m.
And we're gonna keep going until...
Oh my gosh, whoops, I realized.
Okay, the chat should not be here then.
I only put chat here because like...
Um...
Oh, maybe I should put chat here.
And then the alerts...
Oh, I get it.
The alerts on the other side.
So the reason why I'm moving them around is because I realized...
Um, this is where the kill feed is.
So like...
Oh, wait, Hela's free.
So the right side is where the kill feed is.
And I realized that's like hard to see and everything.
So I'm just like, oh, maybe I should put on the other side.
All right, we're gonna do triple support.
We have to do Adam.
Okay, guys.
Okay, so like the reason why I didn't stream until now is because I was like, I gotta get back.
GM1?
I lost GM1 and I've been trying to get GM1 for a while.
And now I got GM1 back.
So I was like, now I do the stream.
And now that I'm...
Oh my gosh, I'm sorry.
Now we can stream.
And then we're gonna do it so that we don't end until...
Until we're eternity.
We're locked in.
We're so locked in.
Come on, thank you for the five gifts.
Thank you, senor.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime system.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Five wins.
Bro, what the fuck?
What are you thinking, dude?
Yeah, oh my god.
Alright.
It's fine, we can do this.
Alright, we're locking in.
We actually have to try really hard.
I'm gonna be...
I can't be like super interactive, guys.
Like, I actually...
This is why I played...
Like, I didn't stream because like, I'm not locked in when I'm streaming.
So I was like, okay, I gotta focus up right now.
I gotta be so focused.
Guys.
Okay, that's nice.
That's fine, I'm so locked in.
Come on, we can...
We can just walk up, right?
That's fucking right, guys.
Just five games.
We can do it.
I get it now.
Okay, I might...
If I'm desperate enough, I might even start comming.
If I'm desperate enough.
We'll see.
We'll see how desperate I am.
I'll even talk and chat.
Yeah, no, fuck that guy in particular.
Oh, wait.
Not me.
There we go.
Okay, because there's like...
We need like...
We have three supports.
I am not getting the heal...
Getting my ult right.
Oh, no!
What the fuck is this, man?
If I'm desperate enough.
If like...
We're at a point where I'm like...
Okay.
All right, we need a win.
I will fucking communicate with my team.
I am that desperate.
I am so desperate.
I'm GM1.
I need my eternity and then I'll be happy.
And I'm gonna lose eternity tomorrow.
And then it's gonna be a cycle of abuse.
And I'll do it all over again.
Oh my god, I need Mac to like...
Let me heal.
Give me his like...
Head so I can like fucking give a snowflake.
Oh, there's no snowflake for you, I guess.
Give it to the Namor.
He's more important now.
All right.
All right, Namor.
Don't worry.
He has...
He's taking damage, so that's fine.
All right.
Come on, kill her!
Kill her!
Oh my god.
I guess we don't kill her.
Kill him though.
Kill him!
Oh my god, he's so low.
Thank god.
Okay, that's fine.
Triple support is actually so fucking scummy.
Nobody just dies.
There's still 12 more days.
All right.
The only way it will...
Okay.
Hey, any like...
I just gotta do this right away.
Get four pro players.
If only I was a millionaire with 30k people watching me.
And I could just get four fucking pro players to stack with me.
If only that I would.
But I also would get stream sniped to fucking hell.
Which I've already...
I'm getting stream sniped.
That'll be fine.
All right, there we go.
All right.
Dance, everybody.
Also, I'm not doing the scroll wheel because it's buggy as fuck.
Um, I know the scroll wheel tech.
But it's...
There's a...
There's a chance...
There's a chance if you do the scroll wheel tech that it's gonna stay on damage.
And like, that's happened to me for two games already.
And that's why I'm not doing it.
Because, um...
Come on!
Yeah, so like...
Yeah, it's bugged right now.
And that's why I'm not...
I'm not doing the scroll wheel.
I know, like...
I know the tech.
I have the tech on.
Um...
I have it binded.
Uh, but they actually...
Like, that has not happened to me yesterday.
Because I've been doing that a lot yesterday.
But today, I've actually...
Like, when I started doing it, like the last...
Uh...
The last, like...
Like, today.
Just starting today.
I would have it stuck on damage.
And it would, like...
It would be on heals.
Like, I would see it on heals.
And then, like, um...
But it would...
It'll be on damage.
Like, people will die in my ult.
And then, like, the thing is...
I manually...
I stop scroll wheeling.
And then, like...
You know, when I see people not being healed even though I'm on heal.
I try to reset it by being on...
By manually pressing Q instead of, like, using my scroll wheel.
And it would still be stuck on damage until the ult is over.
So, like, that's why I don't use the tech.
Um...
I was like, yeah, it's not worth it.
Like, like, but...
Because, like, this is, like, maker...
This... The ult is, like, actual make or break.
And if I fuck up the ult, like, once or some shit...
There you go.
I started the...
Oh, you forced it?
I got him one HP.
What the fuck do you mean you did that?
I did that.
Okay, we gotta kill that Hella though.
Oh, I guess you're not...
I'm so sorry.
I thought I could block it.
I guess you're not fucking living from that.
All right.
Oh, I need to reload my hands.
Gotta reload my hands.
I love reloading my hands.
Woo!
Okay.
I'm just going to put it on mack right now.
All right.
Bye.
I don't really want to use my ult yet.
I want to use it...
My ult as a defensive thing and Mantis ult as aggressive.
Because, like, we don't...
All right, I'll use it just in case.
All right.
Live, everybody!
Live!
And then I'll do damage manually.
That's right.
Live!
Okay.
Yeah, it lasted just a day.
And the people are still doing it.
I'm happy that it's not common knowledge because people are still doing it.
So that...
Because I'm playing Luna.
So, like, if people are still doing it, then, like, it's the enemy team that's doing it, you know?
It's the enemy Luna that's fucking up.
So I'm fine with that.
I'm fine with the enemy Luna fucking it up.
Like...
That's fine.
Hey, guys!
There's still that Captain America that I froze earlier.
Oh, whoops!
Accidentally woke him up.
I didn't think he was actually going to wake...
Okay.
There you go.
I'll kill him.
Yeah.
Also, Raccoon, thank you for the...
Thank you for the...
It's great.
Thank you.
Yeah, they're griefing themselves because I'd be the one playing Luna anyway on my own team.
Yeah, so, like, as long as other...
The enemy Luna is still doing the scroll wheel tech, I'm fine with it because there's a chance that...
There's a chance that...
They're gonna have the bug versus me.
So, I don't do it.
Yeah, I don't do the scroll wheel.
I don't know why they...
I mean, obviously, we all know why they patched it because it's so fucking broken.
Oh, my God.
Also, Neko, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Hello, everybody.
My name is DokiBrain and I usually stream on YouTube, but today I'm streaming on Twitch because I need eternity.
I need eternity, guys.
I need eternity.
So, like, my ego and my...
It's not for you, it's for me.
The scroll wheel tech is basically when you're ulting, you do...
It gives you damage and heal output at the same time.
So, instead of, like, swapping between heals and damage, if you use the scroll wheel to swap, it would be, like, super fast.
So, you get both heals and damage at the same time.
But it's bugged to the point where, like, it'll be stuck on damage.
So, like, you can't do anything.
You can't change it to heal until the ult is over.
And you have to do it yourself.
So, like, that's why, like, uh...
Put on Namor for now.
You know, the bad thing about 3 support is that support ult takes fucking forever to get for...
Because there's three of us.
Whoa, Namor!
Don't worry, I'm healing you from here.
All right.
Raccoon, no!
Rocket Raccoon!
Oh my god!
Okay, I got her.
At least.
Oh my god.
Where's Namor, anyway?
Oh, oh, look at me!
Look at me!
Look at me, please!
Okay, I don't need you!
Just go DPS, I guess.
Just... just DPS, I guess.
Just keep losing the DPS fight, too.
Like, you're not her.
Like, you're so lucky I was healing you.
You were so fucking dead.
You're actually not her.
If you were not getting pocketed by me, you would have lost.
All right.
Yeah, I'm on Twitch.
I streamed most ranked grinds on Twitch other than that one time yesterday.
People were so...
I don't know how, but apparently...
What is it?
BSP tweeted about me...
Like, the God of War Marble Rivals shit.
And then it turned into a fucking debate about VTubers spending too much time doing just chatting streams.
But then I'm just like...
I'm like, I wasn't even talking.
I wasn't even...
I was playing Marble Rivals!
They're like...
It turned into a debate about like...
Are VTubers spending too much time doing Zatsudans instead of playing the game?
And I was like, bro, I was...
I was not talking.
That's for sure.
Where am I gathering to?
There you go.
Okay.
Oh my god, you fucking cheated.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Guess we use this now.
They have Psylocke.
Alright.
Alright, I gotta run.
Because that insta kills me.
Alright, there we go.
Fuck a raccoon, I guess.
I am scared.
Alright, there was a reason why I was scared.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god!
Fuck!
Okay.
There we go, she's dead.
Alright.
Yeah, but I thought that was cool.
It turned into a debate about it.
And I was just like, I'm just playing.
And then like, people actually got mad at that.
And then like, I saw someone commented on YouTube be like, if you're just gonna play a different...
Like, if you're just gonna play a different game versus what's on the title, just go back to Twitch.
Like, and I was like...
I did it one time!
One time is all it takes.
One time is all it takes to turn them into a hater.
I was like, bro, and it was just because I wanted to get GM1 back.
It's all it takes.
Where the fuck is this Captain America?
He's fucking throwing his shield at me.
Did he die?
That tweet was a banger.
Where is that Captain America?
You betrayed our trust.
I still played God of War!
I fucking knew it.
I knew there was a...
Guys, guys, guys, guys.
Guys.
Come on, guys.
Just look at him.
Oh, shit.
If I stand under him...
There we go.
We'll never...
Yay!
Even though...
Okay, I was actually pretty locked in.
Like, I was...
I don't know how.
I'm fucking...
I don't know how I multitasked that.
Like, like...
I locked in.
I was fucking...
I felt like I was fucking around.
But I was also hitting, like, the nastiest freezes and, like, shots.
I don't know how I do it.
I'm just naturally gifted.
What can I say?
Azu and Mink, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
That's true.
I was looking at chat too.
I was definitely looking at chat while I was playing.
It's just that easy.
To be fair, I could play Luna on autopilot now.
Like, legitimately.
Like, I played her so...
I have way too many hours on Luna.
I have way too many fucking hours right now on Luna.
That can actually, like, autopilot on her.
How many hours?
50 plus, at least.
At least 50 plus hours.
On Luna herself.
I also...
I finally...
I learned how to play.
Atom now.
Because Atom's, like, so fucking broken.
Hello?
Okay, but I'm banning Hawkeye right after.
Because, like, Atom's meta now.
Everybody's playing, like...
Uh, Luna.
Uh, Luna, Mantis.
And if Luna's banned, it's Mantis, Atom.
Oh, what?
Oh, is this guy an Atom main?
All right, I hope he fucking plays.
Yeah, you're done for.
But...
I know, I saw the mod.
But, like, um...
I saw the mod.
But, like, I'm worried about it...
People banning, like, my account getting banned.
Because, uh, they see it as an anti...
Like, uh, because of anti-cheat.
That's what I'm worried about.
That's why I don't...
I'm not... I really want to use it.
But I'm really worried that, um...
I'm really worried, uh, that, like, installing mods would consider...
Like, bannable for rank.
Yeah, that's why I don't use any mods.
I don't use any, like, mods that replaces the models and stuff.
Because anti-cheat is, like, so...
Because, like, I feel like anti-cheat in general can get you, like, banned for, like, the craziest shit.
Like...
Yeah.
That's why I don't use any.
I wanted to, like...
Because I wanted...
There was a mod on Nexus Mods where you can change the cart...
To Thomas the Tank Engine.
And I thought that was the...
I thought that was the funniest shit.
I was like, oh man, I wish I could...
I wish I could change it to Thomas the Tank Engine.
Because it looks so funny.
I was like, oh my god, I want Thomas the Tank Engine in my game.
Like...
It looks so good.
If you go to Nexus Mods, you can find it.
Okay, I got locked in again.
Alright.
Also, I'm not in VC.
Because, like, I feel like I personally locked in more when I'm not in VC.
But that's just me.
I don't know.
I'll go in VC if I have to.
But I'm sorry, Mac.
I'm sorry, Mac.
You can talk to your own chat and I can talk to my chat too.
What the fuck?
That was so fast.
He's already here.
Oh my god!
Where's my heals?
Where is she?
She looked away from the Mantis!
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay.
The Mantis actually looked away.
Oh my god.
While I got fucking died.
Holy shit.
I'm sad now.
The Mantis wasn't even looking at me.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm worried about this game, guys.
I'm worried about this game, guys.
Ever since our Mantis, the first thing he does is not look at the support duo.
It doesn't make me feel...
Why did you run away?
I'm not feeling great about this game, guys.
I'm...
I'm not feeling great about this game.
Oh my god.
Like, I don't understand why she didn't look at me.
I was like, I'm right here.
I'm right beside you.
Okay, how close is she?
Okay, she has hers first.
I wonder why she has hers first.
Okay, I need to use this because I don't want to reload my hands.
It's way too risky to reload right now.
Alright, we won our very first fight.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
We won our first fight.
Let's fucking go.
Alright.
I'm just jealous of getting healed.
Oh my god.
I mean, wouldn't anybody?
We gotta take care of each other.
Supports gotta look after each other.
If we don't, like, what do we have?
I want to, like, position myself here, but I'm worried that...
I'm worried I'm gonna get...
I'm really...
There you go.
I swear, I SWEAR!
God, that freeze should have lasted a lot longer!
You fucking know it!
You know that freeze should have lasted fucking at least four seconds!
I...
Oh my god.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fight this one, too.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Alright.
I got worried.
I don't know if I should have used it.
I don't think I should have used it, actually.
Oh my god.
I got really worried we were gonna lose that fight there because he was, like...
Because our Mantis ult was gonna run out.
So, we'll see.
They have Psylocke ult now for it.
Ooh, they definitely have Psylocke ult.
I swear to god!
I swear!
Okay, I got solo ulted.
That's fine.
Thor was gonna fucking kill me anyway.
Thor was gonna fucking kill me.
There was no reason.
Let's start.
I'm gonna back out now.
Whoa!
I don't think we can tell that.
Okay, that's this.
I don't have ult.
Get off, Thor!
I can solo tank!
Damn.
What if he's a Thor player?
You don't know that.
Oh, he's dead.
You don't know.
Chicken soup could just be a Thor main.
I like how he's like, let me solo tank.
I can take them on.
Is he gonna- yeah, he's gonna stay on Thor.
I mean, I think it's fine.
If he's a Thor one trick, we just gotta play around him.
Like, what can we do?
Alright.
Goodbye.
Come on.
Thor it.
Okay.
Oh my god, alright.
I have to use this to stabilize.
Oh guys, guys!
Oh my god!
You could have helped him!
Okay.
Nope.
I froze somebody.
I don't know who.
Oh.
Alright, that's cool.
I'm gonna send this randomly out.
Maybe I'll hit something.
That's fine.
Alright, two minute and thirty- that's cool.
I don't know.
I'm not feeling that confident about this game.
We have no more support ults here.
I don't know.
I don't know, guys.
We're always- I feel like we're always lacking in the support ults here.
Which is making me a little- Oh my god, I can't heal you!
I can't heal you!
You're in the dog!
Okay.
That's okay, we got pick.
He went into the fog!
What am I supposed to do?
What am I supposed to do when you're in the fog?
When you're in the fog, I don't see anything.
I don't see anything!
She's coming over!
She actually fucking saw me!
Help!
No!
She moved so- I was so close to the spot!
I was literally one step away from the spot!
Oh my god.
The Lunatec is bugged.
The Lunatec is bugged to the point where like- Where if you do it, there is a chance- There is a chance that it will stick- They will stay to damage.
So like, I've had that happen to me twice within like- In like two- Yeah, I've had that happen to me twice like during the first five games that I played.
Um...
So like, that's why I don't do it anymore.
I have it binded, but like- It worked yesterday.
Yesterday, it was like working.
And then today, they might have like- Podfixed it.
Because it's in a- It's like a tech abuse.
Um...
It's not like act- Like...
It's like- What's it called?
Um...
Because it's not intentional.
It's not intentional.
It's too much of a risk.
I had like- I lost a game.
I lost one game for it because of it.
Because like, uh...
We could have won the push.
But then because they ulted me and I was doing scroll wheel tech.
And then we all died.
And we lost the game.
And they're like, why are you on damage?
And it like literally- Like on my screen, um...
Nobody was getting healed.
Like I could see no one getting healed.
So I was like, oh.
Oh, it's definitely bugged.
So they- You can see- You can see that it's on, uh...
Okay, our Neymar was actually doing shit though.
So like, I'm worried here.
OH MY GOD!
THIS ALWAYS HAPPENS TO ME!
I hate being there because I can't- I always like fucking accidentally walk off.
And this always happens to me.
And I need to like make sure I don't walk off.
Because I don't know how to not do that.
Okay, this is not the fight we're supposed to take, guys.
This is definitely not it.
I always fall off when I'm there.
Because I always feel like, uh...
Go back to Rocket.
When you mean go back to Rocket...
You mean Mantis?
We don't have Luna Mantis?
Okay.
Yeah, if Imod can make the command about Luna and just be like, she knows the tech but it's bugged out now.
It's bugged where it stays on damage if you do it sometimes.
Yeah, like, um...
I don't think this team is a good team.
I'm literally just getting ran down by- Me too.
Alright.
She dashed right into my right click and that's fine.
I'll take that.
I don't know why we have Black Panther.
Um...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Honestly, it was more useful on Mantis.
It was definitely a lot more useful.
He's fine, right?
You're so fine, Bong.
You're so healthy.
I have to do this.
I know I was gonna get, like, exploded.
I had a feeling.
I had a feeling they were gonna explode me.
I saw three people ran at me and I was like, yeah, I ain't dealing with that.
Uh oh.
This is it, Mac.
This is your time to learn.
Learn Wolverine.
I know how much you like learning.
Oh my- Why did you fly up there?!
I just did.
Starlord won.
Oh my god.
Captain one, two, player is everybody.
I- Oh, I don't know.
I killed the fucking Syla.
Like...
Where is everybody?
He stays as I 1v1 the Syla myself.
I did my job.
Holy shit!
Okay.
That's crazy.
Good luck, everybody.
Is he gonna follow me?
I need a fucking heal.
Oh my god.
Yeah, we all need heals.
Okay, so I didn't- It's Bud where it stays on damage sometimes.
You didn't right put that in.
Hello.
Yeah, that's right.
That didn't feel great, did it, Thor?
That's fucking right.
Do that again.
But don't, please.
I don't know if I'll hit it next time.
But don't do it again because I actually don't know if I'll hit it.
Sometimes I pop the fuck off when it comes to freezes.
And then sometimes I like watch the ice walk away.
Okay, I don't know if like- I don't know if that one- That like insta kills you if he lands on you.
Even on Luna ult.
Because there's some ults where- Oh my god, no.
This is longer.
This is so much longer.
Oh my god, that's fine.
Guys, that's not fine.
Please, he's assembling.
Please, just shoot him.
Okay, if you're too close- Okay, so it's basically like Magneto ult.
Because I couldn't tell.
I was like- I never got full killed by a Thor ult in Luna ult before.
But it's also because I've never tried to be like in the center, you know?
Because like I know like what it does.
Alright, somebody kill her.
No one?
Alright, that's fine.
So I never wanted- You know, I don't want to fucking risk it, you know?
If it does.
I never tried it yet.
And I don't think I want to.
Okay, so it's basically like Magneto ult.
Alright.
Oh my god, that's a hate crime!
He chose to kill me instead of the three other squishies in front of him.
That's fine.
Alright, here we go.
I don't know about this team.
I don't know.
I feel like their team is just- I mean, yeah.
I think their team is just- yeah.
I think their team is just better, honestly.
I think- I think- okay, Mac.
Oh,
that's huge!
But like, everybody's in the ult.
So like, I don't know.
That was very unlucky.
Alright.
You guys all want to be part of the show?
You know?
Like, would you guys like to be in my ult instead of like, in them?
Alright, not Dr. Strange though.
Nope.
Dr. Strange wants to stay deep.
Four people deep into the team.
Like, you know.
It is what it is.
It really is what it is.
I don't know why he was still like, by himself over there.
But that's alright.
That's cool.
I do so little damage when it comes to like, the sleep.
Like...
There we go.
I did that.
How?
What do I do?
I was at the very end!
What can I do?
I think I'm dying on point.
Wait, I need help on point.
I need- I need point.
I need help point.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Alright, I believe in you guys staying on point.
Do not get off point.
Alright.
Why are you healing the 1v1?
It's a good pick.
We should keep the pressure up.
Door one, door one, door main, door one, door one, door one, door fucking one.
Tracer's on ult, she's on it.
Do not C9!
Oh my god, they almost C9'd and I'm like...
Oh my god, they actually almost C9d.
They actually almost C9.
I was gonna fucking freak out.
I was gonna freak out.
They actually almost C9.
I was like, guys, I need to stand back so I can heal.
Oh my god.
I almost saw them all walk off.
I almost saw them all walk off the point.
I don't wanna stand on high ground.
I'm not standing on high ground.
I'm gonna stand next to the healer so I don't insta-fucking die.
Oh wait, okay, we're attacking first.
I don't know, I don't think we should TP.
TP never works, I feel like.
If we TP, like, send us back, like...
Like, back behind the high ground, you know what I'm saying?
Not inside that little place.
Oh my god.
Outside where the little fucking chairs and shit are.
Potatoes.
Alright.
If anybody asks me about the fucking scroll wheel tech, just give them the thing.
Just do !luna.
So we don't have to explain ourselves over and over again.
I'll put it on...
I don't know who I should put it on.
I guess a Black Panther for now.
Let's TP, let's TP, let's TP.
We're gonna TP, alright.
Let's hope I don't walk off again.
I'm gonna put it on tank then.
I don't know about playing slow, but okay.
I'll reload my hands.
All forwards, reloading.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Killed one.
I'm keeping pressure over here.
Alright.
Here we go.
Yo Panther, if you keep just going in and just, like, just...
You don't even have to kill anything, just stay alive.
I can just keep... I can just make it.
Yeah.
I swear to god, if you guys stepped off the point, I swear to fucking god.
I...
I swear to god, I'm gonna stand here and hope that you guys don't step off the point.
That's all I hope for.
That's... Oh my god, it's already a little bit gone already.
It's...
It's already...
I don't know how, but it's...
It's already a little bit gone.
Careful, careful, careful, careful.
Okay nice, get out, get out, get out if you can, get out.
Okay.
I'm back, I'm back.
Just wait it out.
We should walk on this, we should walk on this.
We should focus Mantis so she can stay alive.
Oh my god, big, big, big.
I'm teleporting, come on.
Stay on, stay on, stay on.
I'm trying to stay on.
I killed everyone.
Oh my god.
No!
And the Psylocke got me!
I was so close!
No!
That is crazy.
I was so close!
I mean, they just took more damage than they did though.
Oh my god.
Yes.
That's just all it is.
We just shit on them too hard in the first fight.
Are we good for this?
Yeah, we're not at all.
Should we run the double tank?
Oh my god.
They had two supports!
I was so lucky to even have 97!
Oh my god.
It was so hard to get support ult.
It was so hard.
I was so close.
I literally was 3%.
I did everything I could to build as much ult as I could.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I feel like I'm gonna get fucked up.
Maybe this Rocket Raccoon will heal me.
The Mantis definitely did not last time.
Alright, here we go.
I'm scared.
I'm a little scared, guys.
I want to believe, but I don't.
I won't.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Come on.
I'm coming over.
Get over here.
Kill the Thor.
Kill Thor.
Thor.
I'm trying.
Please kill me.
Please.
I'm trying so hard.
Oh my god.
I'm on you.
I'm dead.
Focus the healers, bro.
Please.
Why did we not?
That is fucking crazy.
Why did we not kill him?
Bro.
Like, strange.
You gotta like not fucking die there, man.
I mean, we could still hold this.
Okay.
I'm putting on Strange.
I'm so close to support.
I have heal over my ult.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
They have support ult.
But they have Psylocke ult.
Oh my god.
We have to kite.
Just kite.
Stay together.
Kite this one.
Please.
Oh, I can't.
Kill the Mantis.
Forward.
There's a lot of height.
One HP.
One behind.
Kill Strange.
Please.
Almost damage.
They have Mantis ult.
One HP.
Bro.
Right there.
The cop.
Heal your name.
Keep me up.
It's fat.
It's not fat at all.
I did not kill that.
Oh, Psylocke.
Please.
Oh my god.
We're gonna lose because I was alive for so long.
I was actually...
I was alive for so long.
What do you want from me?
I literally walked backwards and then he just kept chasing.
Oh my god.
I actually...
I did so much there.
Oh my god.
I was like...
We just didn't have a Mantis.
We didn't have a Mantis.
What am I supposed to do?
No Mantis.
Also, X1 and...
Alright, thank you for the Twitch five.
Thank you.
Alright, if we lose the next game...
Um...
We'll...
We'll start comming.
We'll start comming if we don't...
If we lose this game.
We'll actually talk.
Oh my god, we have a Mantis player.
Like, it's already an improvement.
Oh my god.
As in, I will talk in-game.
You know, our Namor is actually insane.
Like, he gets so much value.
Also, Cup, thank you for the tier one.
Also, Transi, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Uh...
Bruce Banner.
That's fine.
Where is he?
Nobody else does it, so I'll do it.
And the second one, I'll do Hawkeye.
I don't know if they'll do Hawkeye.
Sometimes they don't.
So I just don't.
We got a new estranged.
We do not have Hawkeye.
Yeah, that's good.
We will have Hawkeye then.
Uh...
But yeah, it was...
Also McSpanky, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Oh my god.
I still... I can't believe it.
I can't believe it.
We could've won that.
We could've...
Oh my god.
If...
If like...
Uh...
If they...
If they only like...
Oh my god.
If they like turn around and kill the cap.
That would've been so winnable.
Literally just needed to kill the cap.
Cause like...
No matter where I position, he's just gonna Mach 7 run at me.
I literally freeze him too.
And then like...
What am I supposed to do?
Just run...
Just...
Just run.
Run to my team that's getting hit.
Like no matter how far away I run back, he's just gonna chase me.
Alright.
You see it does...
Sometimes I do this, but sometimes people...
Uh...
Sometimes people just...
Don't look.
I got zero peel.
I literally froze all my divers.
That's literally what I did.
I just froze everybody that died at me.
Like I had zero peel.
I'm just lucky that I got the freezes.
Not luck.
It's sketchy knocks.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Everybody's taking so much damage though.
Oh...
Oh my...
Oh!
You're gone!
Okay, guys!
Let's just walk away from the healers.
All of you.
All of you guys.
Just walk away from us.
I'm just gonna help marry that.
We're on the right side?
Okay.
Alright.
I hope Starlord knows that we can't heal them like this.
Oh!
I'm just gonna do the clap.
I'm just gonna clap because they're all in the line.
And that's really useful for me.
Alright.
Oh!
Can't.
There we go.
That's fine.
I have my ult anyway.
We'll have Mantis ult next.
I just...
I just want you guys to be alive.
And then I walk away.
Okay.
I didn't think...
We should not Mantis ult that.
Now we have no defensive ult.
We're using that as an aggressing, but we don't have...
Oh!
There we go.
I messed up my freeze.
Hahaha!
Oh, nice!
Doesn't matter!
They still died.
Thank god.
They don't need support.
I killed him.
Oh, thank god.
Alright.
That's fine.
I didn't even pay attention to be fair.
Oh god.
Oh!
I'm freaking out.
When I start shaking, I'm freaking out right now.
I'm trying not to, but like...
Why am I staying like this?
Oh my god, please.
Oh!
He'll be fine.
He is not fine.
Goodbye.
I'm sorry.
I have to live.
I already have my ult.
I had no reason to heal you.
There's no reason for me to keep you alive.
I already have my ult.
It's all about survival at this point.
I have to reload my hands.
I have to reload.
I have to reload my hands, but it's okay.
We're all okay.
We're all healthy.
Alright, Mantis first.
Mantis is always first, but I accidentally used my...
My main ult earlier because I was scared.
I was so scared.
Yay!
I am...
Oh!
Shit!
Don't you...
No, he has a reset!
He has a reset!
Please!
No!
Mantis!
Our Mantis died.
I couldn't do anything after that.
It was over for me unless I froze him, but I couldn't freeze him.
Mantis, you could have...
Mantis, you could have slept him.
Root's out of position.
Did he fuck it up?
I don't know.
Nope.
Okay, I'm locked in.
Who used ult?
It's my bad.
Who is it?
I'm just getting melted now.
Yeah, that solo thing.
I'm just gonna...
Here we go.
Oh my god, he was one!
I'm sad.
It was actually one.
I'm so sad.
Alright, that's fine.
That's not fine.
Oh my god, I was gonna be like, where is my...
Okay.
Alright,
we still have...
We can still fight this with my ult.
Yeah, I didn't ult because I was thinking we have one last fight.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Somebody else has to touch.
That sucks.
Alright, I don't know who's gonna be touching it.
But it's not us for sure.
Oh wait, what?
Why didn't they touch?
The car was not even that far!
Including which side you're on.
I'm Luna Snow.
What?
It wasn't even that far and I kept touching it.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
Alright, I'm getting ready to communicate.
I'm so ready to communicate with people now.
Not now, but like...
Does anyone else play tank?
Um...
I'm ready to communicate in the next game.
I'm so ready.
Someone goes sub.
I guess I don't pick anyone else.
Oh, we don't have a Mantis player.
How do we not have a Mantis player?
It's lost anyway.
Alright.
Okay.
No, we have.
Oh yeah, no.
These hours are always mostly DPS players to be fair.
I'm not ready.
I'm not.
I'm ready to talk next game.
Not really.
I'm not ready to talk next game either.
They're portaling.
Oh, they portal.
I'm a little scared to be up there, so I'm not going to be up there.
Just drop down if you need.
That's me.
I need...
I need to drop down.
That's me.
I dropped down because I need...
Oh, oh, oh, please.
Oh my god.
Nice, girl.
On point, on point, on point.
Please peek me.
Please.
Watch the weapon.
Please, please, please, please.
Adam, please.
Oh my god.
He didn't even soulbonded.
Oh my god, Adam.
I just needed literally 1%.
Oh my god.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
If I had a soulbound, I'm so sad.
Alright.
Here we go.
You awesome houses.
Alright.
I don't know how.
We have one fight.
Let's defend for four minutes.
I kink.
I don't...
I have never opened...
I've only commed when I know it's a streamer game.
But like, at this point, I'm desperate.
I'm desperate.
Please soulbond us.
Please, you just need to soulbond us.
Just soulbond.
Just keep soulbonding.
God.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Final score.
One.
Two.
This is crying back to back.
Wow.
No, Mack.
Don't.
No, he's good.
He's an actual good player, Mack.
I don't want him to farm us.
Mack, I don't want him to farm us.
Mack.
Oh my god.
Alright.
It's time to...
It's time to bound.
I'm bounding it.
I'm gonna bound.
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, I couldn't do it.
I'll do it soon.
I'm sad that...
I'm sad...
Oh wait, he's there again.
He's there.
Why didn't you...
Oh my god.
Now they're gonna throw.
I'm banning Mantis then.
Oh my god.
Oh no, he's gonna throw because...
Why?
I'm gonna lose my GM, what?
He's not free though.
He's really good.
This guy's actually really good on DPS.
He's...
He's really good on Namor.
That's why I'm like, no, I can't avoid him.
Because you know he's gonna try his absolute fucking best when he's against us.
So like...
So I'm like...
Oh my god.
So I'm sad.
I'm sad.
I wish he did avoid us.
So like, he wouldn't throw.
He's...
A lot of good players are just egomaniac assholes though.
That's...
Oh my god, why didn't we ban Mantis?
Why didn't we ban Mantis?
Okay.
Oh my god.
I've won with this guy before.
Before like...
Before...
On my team.
I've won with him.
Because that's how...
I know he's good.
Because he like...
He's actually like...
Clutch it up as Namor.
As Ashley.
That's why I'm like...
I'm...
Oh my god.
Because he hates...
He hates Mac.
So he's gonna throw now.
I mean, if he's throwing, I'll report him I guess.
But like, we'll see how it goes.
We'll see.
That's usually how it goes.
If you fucking say shit that like...
Pisses the other person off.
They'll be like, alright, I'm gonna throw now.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Widow can be good.
But like...
I...
I don't know...
If he's like...
If he can do it without Mantis.
That's the thing.
Because like, Mantis is so...
All heroes.
Yes.
Wait, no.
I want all heroes.
Fuck!
Okay, I can't.
I was trying to figure out how to find my stuff.
Alright.
We'll see how this goes.
Yeah, but he usually picks Widow to troll.
That's what Triforce does.
He only does it to troll.
Isn't actually...
Mac.
Who?
Mac!
I wish I was able to bound my stuff in time.
We just have no front pressure right now.
Except for our Punisher.
Our Punishers are only frontline.
Oh, thank god.
Yeah, fuck off.
Oh, I missed the freeze though.
Oh no.
Go, Magneto!
Live for us!
Magneto, you have to live!
Magneto!
You have to live for us!
Magneto, I have to look away though.
I have to look away for now.
But Magneto, you gotta live.
Magneto, as the solo tank here.
I'm gonna make sure you're alive.
But that's really all I can do, honestly.
Oh my god.
I wish I could look at you guys.
Like...
Like, what do we do?
We're just...
We're stuck here.
Live.
Are we... are we alive?
Are we...
Oh my god, he's gonna be alive.
He's gonna be so alive.
Please.
The one time, I'm like on the point.
Alright, they got...
We have literally zero frontline.
We have no...
We have no frontline pressure.
Oh my god, the play close.
I'm scared for a Magneto.
I'm gonna play close because I'm actually scared for a Magneto here.
I don't know if, like, he's gonna actually live.
We'll just get away.
I...
I did everything I could.
Please.
Please get on the point while we live here.
We're gonna live here.
Okay?
Please.
Just...
Oh, okay.
You know what?
I'm still okay.
For now.
I'll just be here.
We got off point!
We had one job!
Just
kill me.
Just kill me.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
We're so fine.
Guys, I...
We can get back GM one, guys.
I believe.
We can get it back.
I believe in us.
You know, it's gonna be okay.
It's gonna be so okay.
I believe in us.
You know?
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna ask...
Dodge this Q because I'm pretty...
Dodge...
This Q...
Because I'm pretty sure...
He's gonna throw...
When he sees your name.
But try when he sees you...
Sees you against us.
I'm...
I'm not dealing with...
I know he's gonna fucking try so hard.
This is why I don't be toxic to people, like...
In game.
It's like I only...
I'm only toxic on stream.
Because I'm...
I don't know exactly why.
Because there's actions to your consequences.
And I'm unfortunately just a bystander.
It's like, yes, he might be getting picked.
But it's not the most ideal character to play.
In general.
It's not...
It's not really very ideal to play this character.
Because like...
I'm not...
I have to depend so much.
They'll be fine, right?
They are not.
They'll be fine.
They're so fucking fine.
Please.
I...
Just kill him.
I'll be fine.
It's not fine.
But like...
That's all I can do.
Be positive.
Alright.
It's like literally...
Literally...
You could play other characters and make more of an impact.
That's why like...
I'm worried.
Alright.
I'm just gonna...
Okay.
Slap.
Alright.
Stand on point, please.
There we go.
Stand on point, guys.
Alright.
That's fine.
Stand on point, everybody.
I...
I'll get the mines too, guys.
That's fine.
I'll stand on point for us.
Please.
That's fine.
He's one.
Alright.
I'm gonna fucking...
Woah!
Nice.
There we go.
That's fine.
At least like...
You know.
Alright.
At least our...
This is a good Widow map.
Thank God.
Thank God this is a good Widow map.
Alright.
That's fine.
I love Marvel Rebels.
Yippee!
I told you.
He's like an insane player.
He's so good.
Like...
Like he's actually insane.
Alright.
There we go.
Yes.
But it's like less reliable.
Widow is like not really that reliable as a character.
This is also a really good Widow map because there's so many angles.
Now on this map, there's not a lot of angles for them to play around.
So like...
Oh my God.
So it's a little scary.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know.
This is a scarier map now.
This is a scarier map because...
This is not...
Oh my God.
He swapped up.
He was like...
Maybe he actually wants to win.
Guys.
Maybe he...
Guys, you think he actually wants to win?
No.
Okay.
That's fine.
Thanks for giving me false hope for like five seconds.
I really appreciate it.
To feel like a little bit of happiness.
I really appreciate that.
You know.
Just...
I really appreciate that.
Guys.
I'm glad I got to feel it for a second.
You know?
Just a little bit.
Like, we could never cap.
Oh no!
I didn't know!
No!
I couldn't see him!
Goodbye!
I didn't see him.
He like was in the air.
You're alive!
Oh my God.
You're alive.
You're actually alive.
That's crazy.
Oh my God.
You're alive.
How are you alive, Magneto?
Alright, I'm going to play around here.
I don't want to play like fucking into them.
I don't know how our Magneto was alive there.
Oh, they have Bruton out.
They're going to wall us off.
They're going to wall the Widow.
Please.
No!
Please!
I'm trying!
How?
I'm dancing!
Please!
God, please!
Dance on point!
Aika, why am I the only one that understands the concept of the- He's just dying on my point.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I might be the only one that understands what point is, but that's okay.
That's okay.
Like, someone's got to understand.
I'm glad like one of us does.
Okay.
Okay, that's a little worrisome because...
Yeah, I don't think this Magneto understands that you don't look.
You don't peek.
You don't peek!
Don't peek him when he throws his rock!
Oh, it was GM1.
This is my demote game.
This is actually my demotion game.
And like, I'm...
I'm losing more and more confidence.
I'm losing more and more confidence as- Guys, please!
Why are you guys just up there?
What?
I don't understand my team.
Why are you just up there?
Just walk forward!
Please dodge his Q.
We've made enemies.
Goodbye.
It was nice being GM1 for a second.
It was nice being GM1 on stream.
Oh, fuck yeah.
Oh my god.
That's okay.
Oh, that's alright.
I'm okay, guys.
I'm okay, everybody.
I'm alright.
I'm so okay right now.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
At least he had fun.
He was fucking playing his heart out.
But, like, I said that he's really good.
But that was not a Widow map.
Like, the second one was a Widow map.
The first and third is not a Widow map.
So, like, and we had literally zero frontline.
Like, we had zero fucking frontline there.
Is he in-game or any?
Is he in-game?
I'm just gonna check just in case.
I swear to god if he's, like...
I don't remember.
His name was, like, Bog.
But he's not even...
Is he invisible?
Oh my god.
He's invisible.
No one was going forward.
Oh, yeah.
I gotta do the comms thing.
I can't wait for people to yell at me because I'm a female.
I'm so excited.
I swear to god if I am going to, like, have...
Okay, this is a new queue.
This is...
Oh my god.
This is a new queue.
Okay.
He's actually invisible so you can't, like, dodge him.
That's smart.
That's actually so smart.
Alright, let me...
I'm gonna push.
I can't wait for them to yell at me.
Guys, this is my favorite part.
I love it when they yell at me.
That's why I stopped using voice unless I'm a streamer lobby.
Because when you're in a streamer lobby, they don't yell at you.
Because they're like, I don't want to showcase that I'm misogynistic in front of, like, my favorite streamer.
Like, that's the only reason why I'm okay.
That's the only reason why I'm okay using mic when it's all...
Like, when I'm playing with other... when there's other streamers in my game.
Or hello, whatever.
Yeah, but then the streamers would protect me and be like, whoa!
And then, like, that embarrasses them.
But then, like, when I'm, you know, I'm like, oh, I gotta...
That's why I don't... I don't talk on voice comms unless I'm in a streamer lobby.
Because then they'll be like, whoa, I can't be...
Oh, we don't have Mantis ban.
If...
Can we have Mantis if...
Okay, I... fuck it, who cares at this point.
If he does bad, I'll just do, like, after we lose.
If we... if we don't do well.
And... I hope we're attack.
I hope we're attack.
Oh, okay, wait, no, I hope we have attack.
Yeah, that's what I mean, I hope we have attack.
Alright.
Can you remember this is...
This is gonna be harder to press B.
This is gonna be a little harder to press B.
Is there a control... Is there anything on control for Marvel Rivals?
Guys?
Is there anything on control for Marvel Rivals?
It's gonna be easier to put any healing on control than B.
I don't remember.
Alright.
Yeah, but...
The other team have...
But he has to fight... look at the other team's Mantis to be able to do it.
That's the thing.
I don't know if, like, he'll be able to look at the other Mantis in time.
Yeah, but, like, what about any supports?
I don't know.
Oh.
No, I'm wrong.
Alright.
Alright, that's cool.
Not gonna try and stand too close.
Oh.
Oh, you're gonna...
Whoop!
Alright.
Okay.
That's cool.
There's, like, nothing to talk about.
People just die.
Okay.
We got a pick.
Alright.
Oh, Psylocke behind me?
Oh my god, please!
I can't.
Comms don't matter.
Oh my god, I even said Psylocke behind me.
He just let me die.
How does her E work?
She gives people this, and then if I heal somebody else, she heals, and if I heal her, she gets stuck with the healing.
It's just that easy.
I don't know how to comm with this team.
Like, this team is so, like, everywhere.
Okay.
I don't...
What do you want me...
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, okay!
Um...
This team has to be the least team-five.
I don't even need to comm with them, like...
This...
This is not a team.
This is absolutely not a team.
Like, what do I even say to them?
Yes, it does.
What?
It stacks, does it not?
Oh, so did...
It heals more when you have it on them.
It feels like I'm healing more.
Oh!
Please.
Please, look at me.
Oh my god, I'll heal myself.
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, please!
Okay!
Okay, it's fine.
It does.
I'm pretty... I've done it.
I feel like I've healed, like, a shitload.
Unless I'm fucking placebo-affecting myself.
I don't know.
Maybe it doesn't.
And I was just a placebo effect.
Please just jump.
That's crazy.
Like...
I'm...
But yeah, I'm just... I think I have to use voice to just get heals.
If he doesn't respond to, like, me spamming that.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry.
Okay, he's alive.
Alright.
That's why I put on the tank.
For double the healing.
I'm just... Okay!
Oh!
I heard... I heard... I heard the growl.
I heard the growl.
I...
I heard...
What?
I hope we have Soulbond!
Oh!
It doesn't matter!
Oh my god.
That's okay.
I've accepted my fate on this game alone.
Oh, now we have three supports.
You know what?
Three supports works.
I don't trust this Loki at all.
After, like...
I hope...
Oh my god.
Please.
Oh my god!
I know the...
He's here.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please!
I guess I'll touch!
Oh my god.
Alright.
That's fine.
This...
This team is a team.
It really...
It's definitely a team.
It's...
Yeah.
I don't...
This...
Yeah.
It's...
It's a team.
I...
I can't cop with this team.
Nobody is, like...
Everybody is playing so split.
There's, like, no point in, like, actually being a team player.
To, like, communicate with them.
They're all, like...
They're all stupid.
Like, I can't...
I can't...
I actually can't do anything with this team.
Lord, thank you for tier one sub.
Thank you.
Violet, thank you for Twitch Prime.
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, like...
They're so...
I don't even think...
I don't...
I don't know what to do.
Okay.
I need to, like...
My keyboard is fucking in a weird area.
Alright.
Okay.
God, I'm, like, so sweaty right now.
So I need to, like...
Because, like, my fucking PC is, like, a goddamn heater.
That, like...
It's, like, sliding right now.
I feel, like, a little uncomfortable.
I need to get, like...
I need to get, like, a portable air con.
That's bullshit.
Alright, what's...
Is control on any, like, support found?
I don't remember.
That's the thing.
Like, is...
Is control on anything that's, like, important for support?
Because that's why I can't use, uh...
That's why I can't...
Oh, my God!
He's okay.
That's fine.
Okay, thank God.
No?
Okay, I'll use control for I need healing.
Because this is actually really difficult on, uh...
Is it really difficult on B?
I'm not used to it.
It's, like, too...
I have to move too much for that.
While control, I can easily...
Alright.
That's fine.
They're gonna push up.
That was a Hail Mary pass.
I don't wanna stay too close to my supports.
Other support.
Because of the fact that there's that.
Yeah.
No!
No, you're out!
I'm trying so hard to keep up.
Oh, my God.
I have to do this.
Oh, fucking...
Oh!
Please!
No!
Mac, I...
Oh, no!
Mac ran off!
I thought our Mantis would get ult first.
But she didn't.
She didn't get ult first.
So I had to...
Oh, and our...
And our Mantis couldn't use her ult.
That's very unfortunate.
That's...
I think he's dead.
He...
He go fought that.
He was like, I can win this 1v1.
He didn't win that 1v1.
I should've yelled at him to get back here.
I...
I should've yelled at him to be like, get back here!
That's why I should've used the comm.
Yeah, everybody literally...
They have the moon.
So I'm not standing close.
God, I'm so good at...
Ult prediction.
Like...
It's like I deserve to be in...
In this elo.
But like, please give me a high.
Please, I wanna be high.
Please, shoot the Ankh.
No!
I don't even know.
They were all bad.
I'm gonna avoid...
I'm gonna avoid these games.
They're not real.
Alright, guys.
I guess this solo queue hours.
Okay.
GG's.
Alright.
Mac's a fucking pussy.
He said...
You're weak, by the way.
He ain't quitting until eternity.
And he fucking quit.
Fucking weak as hell.
Fucking weak.
Oh wait, I gotta get rid of East Coast.
All the...
Eternity players told me to just never play East Coast.
Because...
All the...
I'm sorry if you're an East Coast ranked player in Eternity.
But like, I was literally told by like...
Everyone I know that's Eternity to never queue East Coast.
Because that's where all the bad players are.
Hideous.
Yup, and Violet.
Thank you for the Twitch...
Oh, I already said Violet.
But thank you for the Twitch friend.
Thank you.
So that's why I don't queue East Coast.
Alright.
I guess it's solo queue time.
Oh wait.
I can't even say why.
Like literally everybody's like, don't queue East Coast.
It's not even...
Stop now.
Because...
Because I promised that I would stream until Eternity.
Oh wait.
Sorry.
Wrong chat.
La mal.
Yes, I...
I promised that I would stream until Eternity.
I would stream until Eternity.
Well, now they know I'm a streamer.
Fuck.
Alright.
I'll ban Hawkeye.
Whoops.
That was awkward.
That's okay.
Nobody else is banning anything, so...
I'll ban Bruce Banner.
I guess I'm the Bruce Banner.
Oh my...
At least it's not all chat.
Yeah.
No, I'm banning Bruce Banner because I don't want to play...
Okay, so somebody...
Okay, let's hope that we have a hella player.
Oh my god, we have a Rocket.
Oh, I like how there are two people that insta-lock Mantis too.
That's looking crazy.
Maybe I'll meet somebody, guys.
Maybe I'll meet a player.
That's gonna be like...
Oh my god, you're pretty good at support.
You wanna like...
You wanna duo?
And then...
And then we get like a sick-ass win-streak.
Or we derank.
I don't know.
It could be one or the other.
One or the other.
Alright, let's see.
I need healing.
Where's I need healing?
Descend.
Oh, okay.
We're never gonna have to...
No hella players.
Wait.
Oh, I can...
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, we'll see.
We don't need to descend anyway.
My mental is already descended.
Maybe...
Maybe it'll be better.
See, this is so much easier.
Alright.
I don't know if I wanna talk to people anymore.
Like...
Now I definitely don't know if I wanna talk to people.
Oh no.
There's a Venom.
Oh my god, I reloaded my hands.
Please!
Oh my god.
I knew it.
Please.
You take way too much damage.
For me.
Please.
Please!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, focus.
Focus on him.
Focus.
Thank god he's kidnapping people.
I'm so happy.
Oh my god.
Bro, beat the shit out of him.
That's fine.
I think I'm okay.
This Wolverine is good.
Thank god.
Nevermind.
I mean, he is good.
But that's awkward, you know?
Oh.
That was very awkward.
Um.
Alright.
Okay, don't peek it, guys.
Don't peek it.
You can still die.
Alright.
That's fine.
Alright, we're okay.
He's gonna go kidnap somebody again.
He's gonna...
Oh shit!
Okay!
I don't know who he fucking...
Okay, hello!
I'm fucking scared.
I'm just gonna be here.
I'm just...
Alright, that's fine.
I'm...
We're so healthy.
Alright.
That's okay.
Helichurl left.
Hela behind us.
Please!
Hela's behind us!
Oh my god!
Oh,
thank god.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
That's okay.
I'm okay with that.
Our Wolverine's fucking crazy though.
He actually is crazy.
Holy shit.
He's fucking right now.
He's actually banging right now.
Not our Scarlet though.
Our Scarlet's a little special.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, please.
Oh, I'm here.
I'm here, everybody.
I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna stay on healing now.
Creepy.
And then I back up.
Alright.
That's fine.
They don't have any more support ults.
Oh, there we go.
There he's going for Zerker right now.
I don't know...
Okay.
I'll be safe here.
I'll be so safe here.
I'm not safe.
Oh my god, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, backing out fully.
Backing out fully.
And then I'm still healing.
I'm clapping.
I'm...
What?
Alright.
That's fine.
Please.
I'm just gonna...
leave.
I'm just gonna wait.
I'm gonna wait here.
I'm gonna...
Maybe it'll be different.
Maybe our Wolverine will kidnap somebody.
Not yet, but like maybe.
I believe.
I believe in the...
Oh...
That's fine.
Oh shit, we have Thor!
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, we have Thor then.
He's gonna...
Am I going with it?
We just run it down?
I'm already set up into Duke's team.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Woah, I'll body block this.
Yippee!
Maybe?
No.
Oh, maybe?
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh, and now there's Hela.
Alright.
I don't know now.
So...
Here you go.
You go do your thing.
Because I...
Yeah...
I thought like damage boost with the Raccoon will get double the damage.
Maybe I'll meet like...
A pro player that's smurfing.
And then...
And just be like Shroud.
Like, I'm a streamer, Mr. Pro Player.
Right now, it's smurfing.
You know, you just got the game.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so low.
Nice.
That's fine.
You're so healthy.
You're so fucking healthy.
Oh my god, where did I go?
Oh shit!
I'm just gonna stand back here.
You guys go till...
You guys go do your thing.
I'm positioning myself so I don't die.
Alright.
It'll be fine.
Not just a pro, but just anybody that's good.
So I can guarantee that they won't fuck it up.
That's really it.
Just to be sure they won't fuck it up for me.
So everybody else is gonna...
I'm surprised we're not running Mantis.
I'm surprised.
I have 200 ping spiking?
Who the fuck is it?
Oh, that's my team.
Where's he play?
Oh, he's playing.
Hello?
Wait, what was he on before?
What was he on before?
Oh, he was on Witch!
Oh!
How the fuck does he have 20?
I guess I...
I...
I didn't feel like the Witch.
Like...
It did not feel like the Witch did anything.
How the fuck?
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Although...
I don't think I'm...
You know, like...
Having a duo made me think that it was possible.
But now I don't...
I don't know anymore.
Now that I don't have a duo, I'm like...
Becoming...
Less...
I'm being less confident.
That's why I was so confident in my stream title.
And I thought...
I thought he was in it for the long haul, you know?
I thought Mack was in it for the long haul.
Now I'm a little less confident.
I mean, it's still possible.
I might get like the best RNG of teammates...
I could ever ask for.
But there's a reason why...
Everybody stacks now.
You know, just to lessen the RNG.
Where is he?
Oh, wait.
A hell of high ground?
Oh my god, no!
Oh wait, nice.
I'm back.
Jesus Christ.
I don't even know if my mic actually works, to be fair.
Nobody fucking talks here anyway.
I just assumed he looked back.
They looked back just because I died.
I'm back.
I'm almost close to up.
Hello.
Okay!
Oh, hey Penny!
Woah!
Alright, this...
Can we burn Hela?
Goodbye, Rocket.
Hela on cart!
Please, Hela's low!
Oh my god.
Everything is fine.
I need a health pack.
Guys, I'm scared of playing...
Where's the health pack on this side?
I thought there was a health pack on this side.
I'm scared of like playing against this Wolverine.
I'm really scared.
She seems...
He seems really, really good.
And knowing my luck, he's gonna take back the rank points that he gave me.
Knowing my luck, I can feel it.
I can feel he will... he take back what he gave it to me.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, Wolverine!
Don't worry!
You're so healthy!
Oh my god!
Oh, he's dead.
Yippee!
Oh my god.
Am I gonna play against this Wolverine?
I think I'm gonna play against this Wolverine, guys.
I think...
I feel like I'm gonna play against this Wolverine.
I feel like it.
Where is he?
Alright.
Alright, he's just gonna C9.
Oh my god, not again!
Who's on cart?
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
I'm ready to like...
I don't even know if my mic worked.
I don't even know.
That's the moon.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Yeah, but my... we both had a lot of healers.
Both of us had like a ton of healers.
Yeah, our healer was insane.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
I'm scared he's gonna take away the points he gave me.
I'm so scared.
I make a check.
Yeah, all of them did really well.
Oh shit, wait, why did Mendo...
Why is Mendo Diamond 1?!
Oh, and he...
Okay.
Let me check.
I'm sorry Mendo.
I just... I didn't know.
Why is he Diamond 1?!
Okay.
He D-ranked playing with Xkitsie.
Wow.
I was like, weren't you in GM?
I was like...
Ryan!
Alright, let me check if my mic is on.
It is!
It is on.
Okay.
I can check like...
I was like, why do I...
I was just like, wait, I have more people on here than usual.
No, it is on.
They just no put the...
Thank god.
Who's... okay.
Sorry, I don't know who you are.
I swear to god.
We're on...
D-ranked for the Cloud.
Okay, I need him...
I need him un-private.
I need to see this.
I need him to un-private so I can see it.
To see what the fuck happened.
When I wake up, I see Doki playing Viral Rivals.
Yeah.
It's a problem.
It's actually...
No, I'm not...
If you see me still streaming...
I am not...
I am...
Did he un-private it?
No, he still has it private.
I don't know if I should queue up.
You could be muted.
Just check it.
How do I check if I'm muted?
No, it works.
Cause like...
How do I check?
I mean, that's mic volume.
Yeah, voice chat's on.
Right here.
It should be fine.
It should be it.
They just don't acknowledge me as a person.
Which is fine.
Which...
I'm okay with that.
You know?
As long as they know...
As long as they know like...
I'm...
I'm trying.
That's all that matters to me.
You know?
As long as they know that I'm trying my best.
In this world.
That's all that matters.
Okay.
Well, I didn't talk in...
I didn't...
I didn't talk in...
On...
In the games.
Because I never feel like I had to.
So like...
It should be fine.
Alright, Ruben.
Let me see your history.
How do you rank from GM1 to Diamond?
Do I uninstall?
Le mal.
Unprivate.
So I can see.
No, I can't.
Show me.
You could be lying.
It could be just...
Just...
You getting diffed.
I need proof.
Then unprivate.
Why are you scared?
Why is he scared?
If it's true...
Then unprivate.
Unprivate it.
If it's true.
Then...
Unprivate.
He said it was because of XQC, right?
Then prove it.
I wanna see the last streak.
I just...
I wanna see the last streak with XQC.
Okay, no.
It's not because of XQC.
So it is...
Because of...
People add our teammates and offer them money to throw?
Why was I not...
He was on my team one time.
Shaked my head.
What the fuck?
Bro.
That cannot be real.
Holy fuck.
There's no way.
Bro, that's like insane.
That's just win trading.
Holy shit.
Alright, I take it.
I mean, it depends on how much money they offer, to be fair.
Depends on...
That's actually...
I take it once.
Just because I...
Just because I'm like...
But I take it.
But then like...
I wouldn't throw.
I just do it once.
Because I know that...
I know like...
They're so desperate.
So I take the money.
But I wouldn't throw.
Because there won't be a second time.
Because it would be weird.
They're like...
Wow, every time Dirt Keeper gets in the lobby...
You can see they lose.
Like...
I wouldn't do it.
I just take the money.
And then like...
Just take it.
And not throw.
Wait, he's also a group one trick?
Wait, is he actually?
I'm surprised he's not...
A Hulk main.
Because he's basically like Winston.
He's basically like Winston.
Alright.
I'm private.
I want to see...
Oh my god.
Why can't I see your profile?
Okay, let's see XQC's profile.
I don't understand why he wouldn't let me see his profile.
Let's see.
It's not even...
It's not even that bad.
I'm not gonna lie.
This is not even that bad.
Like, you're still...
Like, there's some wins in there.
How the fuck did you get from GM1...
To Diamond?
He only dropped one tier.
XQC only dropped one tier.
What the fuck happened in between?
Oh!
He was in Diamond lobbies.
Okay, that makes sense.
Okay, not really, but like...
Because you only lose four points more.
And now I am too.
Rest in peace.
I won't say it.
I'm gonna Q dodge you.
I don't know if it's still...
I don't know if the luck is still following you.
Alright, we got Q'd.
We can't.
We got Q dodged.
Mendo.
We gotta Q dodge him.
Tell him he's on the avoid list.
Yeah, but like...
I don't know who he's dueling with.
Whoever he's dueling with must be...
I don't know.
Could be good.
I mean, Mendo's good too.
But like, then it'll be two good players.
Because they're both...
Because he's an Overwatch player.
So like, he knows what he's doing.
He knows what he's doing.
So like...
Don't say I'll be dropping a...
Don't!
Stop!
Guys, stop.
I'll be...
Oh, true.
I won't get him anyway.
That's true.
I can just Q up.
Alright, Ruben.
Q a solo game.
And then win it.
And then we'll duo.
I believe in you.
Don't worry.
I might lose my solo game.
Because I'm a support player.
Don't worry.
You might be in my lobby, Ruben.
Ruben, we might be on the same team anyway.
JK.
We might be...
We might be on the same team.
No, Ra?
You guys know why cursor Ra isn't even in my chat right now?
Because I fucking blacklisted that word.
I blacklisted that phrase.
I'm fucking tired of your curses.
I literally did it in the middle of my stream.
When I de-ranked, I literally blacklisted cursor Ra.
I was like, no, I can't.
I can't deal with this anymore.
I don't fucking trust any of you guys.
I don't trust you guys anymore.
I'm fucking taking that out of your dictionary.
Of your fucking vocabulary.
Alright, guys.
Surely, things will be okay.
Right?
Maybe we'll bump into some stack or solo player that'll adopt me in.
And be like, pocket me.
And I'll be like, okay.
As long as I get eternity.
Keep the orb on me.
And I'll be like, as long as I get eternity.
The dream.
The pocket dream.
Surely.
Surely I can adopt somebody in.
It could be that easy, right?
Everything will be okay, guys.
Did you ban the hieroglyphics?
Alright.
We're just waiting.
Oh my god, this queue is so long.
I'm surprised.
Oh yeah, like the stream sniper shit reminds me of like, what was it?
The Kai and Speed's Fortnite marathon thing.
Where they're just getting stream sniped every single day.
And it was so funny.
The one game they actually won, a stream sniper helped them.
But their contract is like, they have to play Fortnite for three days.
So they just made up an excuse.
And being like, no, a stream sniper helped us win.
So we gotta keep going.
But they're like, they literally are getting paid to play for three days, apparently.
I could be lying.
I don't know.
I read that on Twitter.
But it was really funny seeing the amount of stream snipers that do fight them in Fortnite.
Because it's so easy to snipe.
It's so easy to queue snipe somebody in Fortnite.
Wait, Ruben got...
I dodged...
Oh, that must be an East Coast game.
Ruben must have got an East Coast game or some shit.
So like, he might be fucked.
Honestly.
East Coast servers just ain't it.
Why is Mendo not queuing up?
What is he waiting for?
Alright.
What...
What game did I get myself into?
What?
Excuse me?
What game is this?
What the fuck?
Okay.
No, it's 3-1 above all else on my team.
Oh my god.
Hawk then Scythe.
Sure.
Oh, okay.
Strange.
Okay.
I don't...
Fucking...
I don't know.
I'm a...
I'm a sheep.
I got a lock in.
I'm like slouched right now on my chair.
Like I'm lean...
Not slouched.
I'm lean back on my chair right now.
Because we had like a...
30...
Like a...
20 minute...
Intermission.
Alright.
Sure.
We don't...
We don't fuck with Dr. Strange.
Oh, but what if they go...
Oh, wait.
They banned Bruce Banner.
I get a lot of points if I do win this.
Because I'm just a little...
I'm just a little...
A little...
GM too.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh!
Allen and Wright, thank you for the...
Thank you.
Blessing of Khonshu.
Oh my god.
I hope so.
I mean, we have a...
That was a one above all, right?
Widow?
Claire?
We get these Pearl.
Oh my gosh.
I hope so.
I don't lose a lot, right?
Yeah, I don't lose a lot because I'm the lowest.
At least...
At least we have that going for me.
Okay, it's Ka.
He don't know you little bro.
Damn.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'm not a damn lobby.
I'm a GM.
Oh, Eternity.
One above all lobby.
Damn.
Oh, I should grab this.
Do we have Mantle?
Oh, we're running triple support.
Alright, let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Our only DPS is Widow.
I fucking believe in this team so hard.
I'm so...
I believe in this team.
I don't know if I wanna talk in this team.
Like, then I'm scared.
It'll be like...
Oh, she's fucking dog shit.
Three healers.
Let's go.
Triple support.
Alright, I'm Groot.
Oh, Sylak behind us?
Sylak still behind.
Hey, tanks.
I'm just gonna play with my tanks.
Oh, chucked out randomly.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Spiderman behind?
He's one.
He'll be fine, right?
Alright.
That's fine.
Spiderman still behind us?
Please.
I don't think...
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god, where am I?
Alright.
Alright, let's go!
Let's go!
Not dead yet!
Magneto's full HP.
Oh,
Spiderman behind us?
Alright.
Let's go!
That's fine.
Oh my god, let's fucking go, guys.
I'm starting to believe.
No, I shouldn't.
If I believe, we lose.
I need to go in with zero belief.
If I...
I can't stop.
I cannot start believing.
That's a jinx.
Torch your left.
I knew I have.
Oh, nevermind.
I can ult here.
I have to hide!
Sylak low.
Adam low.
Woo!
Sylak's right on me.
Sylak low.
Oh my god!
Point against her right.
Power left.
This is where I die!
Alright.
That's fine.
I'm fine with that.
I don't even know if they support...
They supported Adam and then...
I think they have...
Oh!
That's fine.
I need to stop believing.
When I don't believe, things look up for me.
I just got...
I just...
He's frozen.
Where am I?
Thorloak!
No!
Okay, guys.
Oh my god, I'm coming in with all...
Alright.
I...
Should I ult this?
Is it winnable?
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm ulting it.
Oh!
They're gonna Sylak ult after this.
Both tanks are on the support.
McNeil low!
McNeil one!
Sylak one.
Left side.
Oh, that's huge.
Luna low.
Thor, Thor!
Oh my god.
That was a crazy game.
Jesus Christ.
I'm like, do I ult this?
No response.
I don't think my mic is working.
I was like...
Alright.
I was like, alright, I'm trusting my instincts!
Or they're ignoring me.
I don't know.
No one said anything.
I just trusted my...
Oh my god.
Or they're ignoring me.
I don't know.
I can never tell.
Guys, I can never tell if people are ignoring me or like...
Or like it's working.
Who knows?
Who the fuck knows?
Sorry, I'm used to being ignored.
It's okay.
Oh my god.
I'm okay.
Ooh.
There's a Thor on the supports.
Thor half.
Thor low.
Thor half again.
I'll just talk just for the sake of talking.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Frozen?
Half?
He's low.
I'll ult this.
There's a Thor by himself on here.
He's half.
I'll stay here.
Alright.
I don't have...
I'm scared.
Thor half.
Thor low.
Okay.
That looks low to the left.
No one's talking anymore.
I'm by myself.
No one's...
No one's talking.
What do I do?
Just...
Lonely.
There was this one guy that comes.
But I don't know.
Thor is frozen.
If you keep me up, I can get ult.
Alright.
We fight this.
Yay.
Oh, tank, you're so far away from me.
Alright.
It's fine.
We got ults off of this, I think.
I don't think we did.
It was just mild, I think.
Hey!
There we go.
That's fine.
Oh, wait.
Whoa!
Nice.
Oh my god.
I don't know...
where to look.
Oh.
There's a Captain America in the supports.
We can't do anything.
Oh!
Can I live?
Let's find out!
Oh my...
That's crazy.
Oh, we got two picks.
Yeah, let's go.
Right side, Captain America's half.
Psylocke, Psylocke.
Psylocke's half.
Psylocke's one.
Captain America's one, too.
We can burst her.
She's low.
I can have all in 20.
Yay!
We did it!
I will never know if people could hear me or not.
Yay!
I'll never know.
I'll never know if my mic was working.
Oh my god.
Wait, 23.
That's a juicy.
That's actually a fucking juicy game.
Let's go.
Oh my god.
22k healing with three supports?
That's pretty fucking decent.
Oh.
I don't deserve the like, I guess.
Sorry.
You're right.
Our tank was pretty good, though.
That's alright.
I didn't need validation.
I didn't need it.
Alright, Reuben.
Did you win your game?
Oh shit, you did!
Okay.
Alright.
You get to be in here.
That had to...
I needed him to try.
It had to be like, the most try-hard thing he can do.
Just got full health.
Gonna uninstall.
Can you hear me?
Hello?
Oh.
So they didn't hear me.
I was calling so well.
All these callouts.
None of them heard me.
I was talking to myself the entire time.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Hello?
Alright, can you hear me now?
Oh my god.
Thank you for the five gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you.
At least I wasn't ignoring, you know?
At least I wasn't ignoring.
Hello?
Does it work now?
Okay, but he could be fucking with us.
Okay, let's see.
Is he fucking with us?
Is he?
Alright.
Oh, he is.
Oh, they were ignoring me.
Oh.
They were ignoring me.
I was getting ignored.
Oh.
No.
Uh oh.
Alright, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
Ruben, I know they ignored me.
I know they ignored me, Ruben.
I don't hear you on his stream.
Wait, are you guys...
I can't tell!
Oh, we don't hear...
Oh, wait, you don't hear me?
Okay, wait.
Let me rebind it then.
Cause sometimes it works last time.
Okay, let me rebind it.
Okay.
Hello?
Oh my god, are you serious?
Okay.
Let me...
How do I fix this?
Anyway.
Hello?
I thought he was doing his bit too.
Okay, I do open mic.
Can you hear me?
Oh my...
I have to do open mic.
Push to talk doesn't work.
Wait, okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me try this.
Okay.
It's push to talk that's fucked up.
Okay, let me do control then.
I need healing here.
At least I wasn't getting ignored.
Thank god.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
It's push to talk!
It was push to talk that's not working!
Oh my god, I don't want to do open mic cause I'm fucking...
I got five gifted subs and your mic aren't working.
They don't even have mute!
Oh my god.
No!
Wait, I'm gonna restart.
I'll restart.
Okay.
Restarting.
Game.
Okay.
I can't believe you thought I...
I thought he was fucking with me.
But thank god I wasn't getting ignored.
I thank god.
Restarting.
Game.
Alright.
Who do you think I am?
Alright, I'm restarting.
Oh my god.
I thought he was fucking with me, honestly.
I...
I legit thought he was fucking with me.
But thank god.
Thank god that's not the case.
No, it just...
No, Marvel Rivals...
Like, VC is so fucked up.
It's not like...
It's funny because everything else is so fucking well optimized.
Except for voice comms.
For some reason, voice comms is like the only thing...
That they have trouble with.
But it's like a multi...
That's why you don't hear people talk.
Because sometimes voice comms just doesn't work.
I'm not...
My mic isn't muted because open mic works.
Apparently.
Yeah, everything else is so great.
Except for voice comms for a multiplayer ranked game.
Where communication is very...
Is key.
So like...
I don't know.
Is it global?
I didn't check if it's global.
Yeah, it only works on open mic.
For some fucking reason.
Alright, let's check.
Maybe they think it's like League.
Where it's optional.
Could be, honestly.
I mean, someone said I should just check...
Oh wait, not competitive.
Practice range.
Let's check practice range real quick.
Sorry guys for the detour before the game starts.
Do I have ping?
Yeah.
I have voice comms here.
Oh thank god I wasn't being ignored then.
At least I'm not being ignored.
That's alright.
I mean, I feel a lot better now.
Knowing I'm not being ignored.
I actually feel a lot better.
Yeah.
I'm not crying.
I'm just happy I'm not being ignored.
Guys.
I swear.
I swear to god.
I'm just really happy that I'm not being ignored.
Guys.
That's really it.
Okay, need healing.
There you go.
Left control for need healing.
And then global should be the same.
Okay, here and then...
There we go.
It should work.
Alright.
Yeah!
I was trying so hard to communicate.
I actually, I worked so hard communicating with my team.
Hello?
Does it work?
Okay, okay.
So, it's just...
I had to restart my game.
Are you ready?
If we lose...
If we lose, Ruben...
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
So, like...
Yeah.
See, I'm not a coward like Mendo.
That's how rough it's been.
I'm not a coward.
Oh my god.
It's like, why did he say that?
We're like...
Why did you say that?
Ho, ho, ho.
How you guys doing?
Like, when I discorded Ruben, we're like...
A match without me.
Oh man, Hawkeye.
Fuck that guy.
And I'll do Hawkeye, then...
Bruce, if they haven't done Hella yet.
I say we ban Hulk, and then...
Hawkeye, maybe?
It's too late.
I already picked Hawkeye.
Oh shit, they died.
Haha!
We just wanna ban Hella then?
Yeah, I'm banning Hella.
I like how nobody's talking to him.
Now he gets to be ignored.
Haha.
Um, are you...
Perfect.
No.
Hahaha.
I just wanted him to talk to himself.
Brad, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Ryan, thank you for the tier 1 and the bitties.
Haha.
Now he knows how I felt.
Now he knows.
Oh, thank god.
I was like, do I ult, guys?
And then when they all, like, ignored me...
I really just thought that they ignored me.
But now I know.
It's cause I was just...
It was just cause, like, you know, nobody could hear me.
Thank god.
That made me feel a lot better, not gonna lie.
That made me feel so much...
All those comms for fucking nothing.
That's...
All those comms I did during the last two games we won...
For fucking nothing.
Let's fucking go.
Is East Coast...
No, this is Central and West Coast.
So, like...
Basically, like...
I don't queue East Coast cause all the Eternity and One Above All players tell me never to queue East Coast if you wanna climb.
So, like, I don't queue East Coast anymore.
Apparently, it's that bad.
Oh.
You put that on you, Lil Tink.
I'm gonna do this.
Oh.
Don't worry, I got you.
I totally got you.
Oh my god, where are you?
I don't got you.
Wait.
Wait, oh my god.
Wait, I was like...
Wait, what's that?
I was like, who the fuck was that?
Yo, they killed our Groot.
They killed our Groot.
Wait.
Okay.
Ruben's dead.
This is so healthy.
Wait, Black Panther's low.
Oh, nevermind.
Oh my god.
Black Panther behind.
Oh my god, he did it!
Kormi!
Mine's disabled.
I don't have it.
Oh.
Oh, please.
Please.
Please, Matop.
Thank god.
Alright.
I got...
Guys, they acknowledged me.
Wait, is this winnable?
I can ult.
Alright, I'll back up.
Oh, I need heals.
Luna needs heals.
Yeah, we played this map.
Okay.
Groot low, Groot low.
Breaking the Immortality.
Oh, Black Panther low.
Black Panther on me.
Nice.
Alright.
Tracer's just low too.
I'm playing behind them.
Yay!
I'm being acknowledged!
Oh my god!
Yay!
They acknowledged me!
We take space off that.
We should push it.
And since you get your ult first, you can ult first.
Alright.
Oh my god!
He's out.
Oh, Psylocke one.
Oh my god.
Black Panther and Psylocke behind us.
Black Panther one.
Oh my god.
That's fine!
There's a Dr. Street behind us.
Oh my god!
Don't worry!
I dance!
Nice.
Black Panther.
Okay.
Nice!
Shit.
Woo!
Fuck you, Loki!
My voice is being heard!
Let's go.
Wait, Wraith Strider's here.
There's two?
Nice.
I'm gonna ult early again here.
Dreamchase.
They have Panther ult.
Ulting?
Nice!
I'm missing everything!
But that's okay!
Oh, he used it!
Ha!
Yippee!
He doesn't know I missed all my shots.
He's not gonna look at the replay.
Ha ha ha ha!
He doesn't know!
Oh, I'm dead.
Ha ha ha ha!
I only- We should use nothing here.
Goodbye.
He has two ults.
We can just Mantis in.
That's fine, guys!
Oh my god, I sound so, like, nice.
Ha ha!
Like, as in, like, really a nice person.
What?
Ha ha ha!
And I'm comming!
And inside, I'm like, I hate you all.
Ha ha ha ha!
I just sound so, like, polite.
Ha ha ha!
We should Mantis in, I think.
Oh!
Oh, I guess not!
Fuck me!
Just don't listen to me, I guess.
Ha ha ha ha!
Who cares what I think, I guess?
Alright, let's go!
Who cares what I think?
That's fucking right!
That's right!
Who fucking cares?
There's a Psylocke behind us.
She has ult.
She's one.
Psylocke's one, Psylocke's one.
Okay, sounds strange.
Uh, Groot?
Yippee!
Who cares what I think?
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Is my mic bugged again?
Oh...
It's alright.
It's okay.
I guess...
My mic went out again?
Ha ha ha ha!
His works?
What is his work?
Ha ha ha ha!
Were you talking the entire round?
Cause I heard nothing.
Ha ha ha ha!
We'll see.
No?
Okay.
But did you hear me?
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright.
Alright, we'll see.
We'll figure it out.
You talked once.
Oh!
Alright.
It's just bugged.
Ha ha ha!
Oh my god!
No!
I hate the voice comms in this game.
I hate it so much.
Ha ha ha!
Alright.
Comms are just cooked.
No wonder the Mantis didn't fucking listen to me.
No wonder everything makes so much more sense now.
I was like, aw man.
That's fine.
You don't need to talk to me.
I don't need to be acknowledged.
Starlord behind me.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
Christ.
Oh my god.
Hey, at least they like, looked at it even though they can't hear me.
You know, that's fine.
I'm okay with that.
Ha ha ha!
That's like something.
Oh, goodbye.
He was not gonna live.
Let me get back up here.
If they could hear me.
Oh my god!
I'm ulting this.
Oh, sorry Mantis.
If you could hear me.
Ha ha ha ha!
We double- I didn't realize you.
Yep, brutal.
Okay.
I was not trusting him to- Oh my god.
That's fine.
That's so fine.
Comm's just dead in general.
Let's- That's fine.
Who cares?
We don't need to communicate.
Who needs to communicate in that fuck- If we can't communicate, the enemy team can't communicate.
Like- Ha ha ha ha!
Like- If- If like a gank is- If- You know what?
I'll take that.
I'll fucking take that, honestly.
Ha ha ha!
That means he-
Oh my god, he's so healthy!
You're so healthy!
I clapped and you lived!
That's how the world works!
Technology is beautiful!
I clapped and you're alive!
There we go.
Everything is okay.
No again for you.
Oh, I can ult first.
Oh my god, I build my ult so fast compared to Archmantis.
This is what I mean.
Like, everything is perfect except for the fact that, you know, communicating is not.
I'm not gonna be open micing this up, guys!
I don't need them to hear my fucking thought process when I'm playing.
Like, they're gonna be hearing me fucking breathe and everything.
Like, mouth breathing.
Oh my god, they went Iron Fist.
You're fucking mad.
Alright, alright, that's cool.
You know what?
Fuck it, let's go.
Let's go!
Let's- Yeah, let's- Yeah, let's go.
I knew- I was so confident.
We don't have any synergy.
I didn't realize our Mantis got ult already.
It's fine.
What are we gonna do?
Lose it with no support ult?
That's fine.
Double support ult?
We have two tank ults.
We just don't- We just don't get rooted.
See?
Just don't get rooted.
It's just that easy.
We got rooted, guys.
But we live.
We live those.
Oh my god!
We- Oh.
We definitely- Oh, please.
We- Oh!
Oh!
Just so you know.
It doesn't matter if I had support ult there.
It doesn't- It doesn't matter.
Like, you can't live- You can't live through, uh- Ha!
Whatever we just saw there.
Oh.
Oh, we're portaling?
It'll be fun, yeah.
I believe.
Groot low.
Let's go!
I don't think they can get back in time.
Ha ha ha!
We're back in.
In GM1.
We're back in it.
I'm sorry, Doki.
I'm feeling- I tried!
Ha ha ha!
No, I was trolling.
Mantis ult always first.
Ha ha ha!
But I knew- Ha ha ha!
I- But I knew we were better.
Ha ha ha!
Mantis ult is always first.
But, like, I- I was fucking her.
I was like, there's no way we lose this, right?
There's no- Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, was I heard?
Is my mic working?
Hello?
Ruben?
It's moving!
Guys, the mic is literally moving!
It's- Do you not see this move?
Do you not see this move?
I saw it move!
Oh my god.
The only time I actually like- I'm willing to play- One of the few times, I'm like, so down to communicate with my team and- Hello?
Is my mic working?
Hello?
Wait.
Is he ignoring me?
Oh, I'm- Okay.
Okay, no, he's not.
Okay.
It's not working?
Oh my god.
I'm mad.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Is my mic completely broken?
Are you se- Oh my god, bro, I never get to play- This is like the most detour of queuing because I never get to play because my microphone's broken.
I fucking- Life sucks.
Life is not bueno, guys.
Life is just not bueno.
We never get to actually play the game.
Oh my- I think it's mostly me.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it's mostly me because like, everybody- Okay, no, actually no.
Because like, sometimes it works and sometimes it just doesn't.
It's like- Yeah, voice chat keeps breaking.
Oh, whatever.
Fuck it.
I'll just keep comming.
If it works, it works.
If people hear me, then that's like the plus side.
No, it's the game.
The game literally bugs out when it comes to voice comms.
If they hear me, they hear me.
If they don't hear me, that's just life.
Alright, I need to get water real quick.
I'll be right back, guys.
Alright, I got water.
Alright, that's just life.
If they don't hear me, I guess I'll just...
die...
in game.
I might be the only GM one.
I'm gonna lose so much.
Alright, we have a rocket one trick.
Damn, banning Mantis.
How many sidelock one tricks are there anyway?
Unless you diff.
If not, I'm fucking banning this guy.
Alright.
Then...
I'm banning Mantis.
Okay.
If we have a rocket raccoon one trick, then I feel...
Oh my god.
How does his mic work?
That's not fair.
That's not...
He gets to say it all.
Oh, thank god Luna's banned.
Then I can play Mantis.
I'm okay with that.
I'm actually okay that they banned Luna.
Just so I can play Mantis.
Let's hope this guy diffs him.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Alright.
Luna Mantis is just way too good.
It's just way too good to like...
to like avoid it.
Alright, here we go.
Please switch if anything.
What does that even mean?
Yes, I'm GM one!
Yes!
I am.
I am GM one now.
No, Adam is.
Adam is definitely a lot better.
But like, what can you do?
We have a rocket one trick.
Like, what can you do?
Just gotta play around with one tricks.
The thing is, he gets to fucking enjoy being one trick because who the fuck bans Rocket Raccoon?
It's such a shitty support character that no one fucking bans him.
I actually have to flex.
I learn every other support except for Rocket because who fucking plays Rocket?
Who?
Who fucking bans Rocket Raccoon?
Like, I'm flexing because like I'm willing to learn other support because I'm no fucking one trick.
Alright.
Let me get a damage boost here.
Oh my god!
I like, I don't know what you want me to do.
You guys are all so low.
Like, oh my god.
Wouldn't it be funny if I got that?
Yeah, I did.
But it doesn't matter anyway.
Doesn't fucking matter.
Please.
Please let me heal you.
Oh my god.
Got a headshot though.
That's cool.
Oh, that's not cool anymore.
Guys, it's not fair.
They have double tank.
It's actually, oh wait, no, they have Magneto.
Wait, that's not fair.
They have a shield.
That's actually not fair.
Guys, I wish I had a shield.
I wish I had a shield tank.
I thought they were running double tank, but they were just running a shield, which is objectively a better...
Oh, I broke the Ankh.
I did my job.
I broke the Ankh.
Please.
Oh my god, please.
I can't even...
Alright, fuck it.
Let's go.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
Everybody...
Wait, why did you all...
Why did you all leave my ult?
I can't live!
Clearly...
Clearly, if they didn't leave my ult, I would have lived.
That's like the worst part.
Oh my god.
I had no more leaves.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I can't get headshot because they're all fucking double shielded up!
Oh my god.
What do you want me to do?
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
I'm not I'm not I'm not copying because...
I'm sorry, bro.
I'm sorry.
Like, I don't know what else to do for you.
Like...
Like, I'm...
I'm trying so hard to keep you up, bro.
I really am.
Here we go.
I can't even damage boost a rob because...
Oh, that's huge!
That's huge, but I can't do anything about it!
Because he's shielding everything!
There we go.
Please, no!
Oh my god.
I believe in this rocky raccoon.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
Please.
Anything.
Please, anything.
Oh my god.
Anything.
Alright.
Please.
Oh my god.
Please, anything.
I'm so proud of all you guys.
I'm so proud of you guys.
I didn't sedate because I was waiting for an ult to sedate it for it.
Because it's like...
It's scary to waste your sedate and then they ult at you.
So I was worried about that.
That's why I didn't sedate yet.
I used my sedate a lot because sedating is such a game clutch thing.
Game clutch mechanic.
I can't just sedate whenever I want.
Hahaha.
Ah!
Fucking Alarak, goodbye.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
There's like no reason to come, honestly, for this game.
Right now, there's like...
Like, I'm...
I'm not confident about this team, not gonna lie.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Where is she?
There we go.
See?
This is why I save my sedates.
This is exactly why.
Please.
Please peek me.
Leave!
Hahaha.
Goddamn, when I have no leaves, it's so scary.
Nice.
Alright.
I'll put three.
It's okay.
I have ult here.
And...
We're gonna have...
Moguito ult.
Reload.
Alright.
Let's go!
Oh, fuck.
I could've...
Alright.
That's a whale.
Yeah, I'm not fucking letting that happen.
I'm...
Alright.
Nice.
I'm alive.
That's fine.
I can let that happen, though.
I...
I'll be back.
I gotta fix my frame.
What?
Excuse me?
Oh, he's back.
Okay.
I was gonna be like excuse me.
But what do you mean by that?
Oh, it's you.
Alright.
That's fine.
Goodbye.
If you live, you live.
What?
That doesn't hit?
I'll just die.
It's fine.
That should've hit.
He was like, give me a sec.
I gotta text my friend.
And I was like, what?
Are we...
What do you mean?
Oh.
Alright.
Let's go.
I'm fucking okay!
I went left.
You guys alright?
Don't worry.
I'm fucking wow!
I made it!
I just made it.
Alright.
Oh my god.
That's fine.
I'm asleep.
Tyler behind.
Tyler one.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Yay!
I don't know if you can hear me, but like I calmed a little bit there.
Oh my god.
What a fucking...
Somehow we did it.
Oh my accuracy is so bad.
I'm like, I haven't played Mantis in a bit on stream.
My accuracy is so bad right now.
I was not hitting shit.
It's fine.
Everything's okay.
I hope I get to... I hope I get to play Adam today on stream.
I think my Adam was like pretty good.
Not a good female.
I'm not one of the good ones, guys.
34% accuracy is pretty fucking ass.
Yeah.
My mic is broken again, I think.
I've accepted it.
Yeah.
Sad.
It is what it is.
Would you ditch Luna for Mantis?
No.
Luna's so easy.
She's honestly so fucking easy.
You don't have to have aim to be able to play Luna well, but like if you have aim, then that's a bonus.
Because like her...
A good Luna is someone that can freeze almost every dive they get.
And like because I used to play Ana in Overwatch.
It's like... It's even easier.
It's even easier than Ana.
Her freezes.
Because like Ana's sleep is...
Oh no.
She got bubble.
Oh my god.
This is scary.
My aim is so bad right now.
I...
Oh shit.
Oh.
Okay.
I want to play back here if I can.
Please.
No!
You fucker!
Oh my god!
Bro!
I could have killed him!
I could have!
He did it!
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad that he woke him up.
You fucker.
I could have lived.
I could have fucking lived!
Actually fucked me.
He actually fucked me over with that.
I feel like the...
Project my ping must be... Oh wait.
No.
Thank god.
Nevermind.
That's West Coast.
No, I don't work for those people.
Oh.
I'm never on West Coast server even though.
Go damage!
I'm just bad I guess.
I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to.
He doesn't see me.
No, he sees me.
No!
He's so low!
Oh my god.
Nice.
Goodbye.
Punisher.
That's a good fucking defense though.
Should I fully back up?
Oh my god.
It went lower.
I swear to god!
You better kill him!
You better fucking kill him if you're gonna wake him up!
Oh my god.
You better fucking kill him.
I swear to god.
Oh my god.
I guess.
Okay.
I'm cool.
I'm gonna check.
I need to double check if I need to ult.
I don't think I do.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Come on.
Kill him!
He's so low!
Okay.
Nice.
I was like, I swear to fucking god, if you don't kill him...
I'm like, my aim is like...
I feel like I'm playing Luna.
I haven't played Mantis in a while.
So like, my aim is not good on Mantis right now.
I've been playing Luna way too much.
Her projectile is so different from...
Because Luna's hitscan...
So like, oh my god.
I'm fucking so bad on Mantis at the moment.
I usually get like 40% accuracy.
40% like, average accuracy.
But like, it's not doing so well right now.
I'm not doing so well right now.
Please.
I don't have leaves.
It's okay.
Too much Luna does makes me a bad player.
But I wanna.
Hide me.
Oh wait.
Everything is fine.
Damage boost.
Heal.
You're all so healthy.
Damage boost.
Heal.
You're so healthy.
Damage.
Oh!
Heal!
Damage!
Damage boost!
Oh my god, you're so healthy!
Heal!
Oh!
No!
I need two people in my ult to live through it.
The thing about like, Mantis' ult is that the more people in your ult, the more healing it does.
But I had no one near me.
I had no one next to me.
I'm not sure.
I don't think so.
That's so sad.
I'm so sad.
There were not enough people to fucking let me live.
If I had enough people on it, I could actually have lived that.
I mean, you all split up too.
That was my bad.
I should not have been split up there.
It's okay, I got you.
It's fine.
Who needs it?
Damage boost him.
Please.
I'm not hitting anything.
But you can.
You can hit for me, right?
Oh my god, he's so low.
Oh my god.
Nice.
Whip him!
That's fucking right!
Hahaha.
I'm not using this yet.
Oh fuck, nice.
Okay, not nice.
I need to wait for my Lee's.
Don't worry, I'm not using that yet.
I don't have to.
Oh my god, please.
I don't have to use it yet.
You can get healed for now.
That's right.
Oh my bad.
It's last fight.
Oh, yeah.
I thought this could be last fight and then we could kill people, but we didn't.
So that's fine.
I'm okay with that.
I'm okay with that, guys.
He didn't know where I was, thank god.
Oh.
Oh my god, he's getting healed.
He's getting healed.
No!
He got healed!
Yeah, they used Starlord ult, they used Psylocke ult, they used...
No!
Yeah, he did.
Their Starlord.
Oh my god, okay.
Alright.
Why?
Oh my god, why?
Wait, what?
Why did no one dodge that?
Why did our fucking...
Why did our fucking strange...
Our strange move in a portal...
I didn't know what went in.
I don't...
I'm so confused.
Why did no one go in?
I was like, surely one of them is gonna touch, right?
Surely we had fucking Psylocke ult and everything.
Surely one of you guys are gonna...
Bro, our strange opened a TP instead of fucking contesting point.
Why the fuck did he open portal?
I was like, opening a portal.
I'm like, excuse me?
Oh my god, that's crazy.
Just seeing our strange open a portal instead of contesting the payload.
Literally like, I'm so confused.
So fucking confused.
Alright.
No, he like, stayed in portal for...
That's the thing.
He actually stayed there.
I was like, okay.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Also, dad, thank you for the twitch prom.
Thank you.
I'll take this then.
Alright.
This portal won't be that bad.
One.
Two.
Three.
One.
Oh, somebody's sleeping.
Sleeping.
Alright, strange.
Strange.
Where?
Who's shooting me?
I'm sorry, I couldn't tell who the fuck was shooting me.
Here we go.
Bro, I- my mouse face.
I- I can't.
Alright.
Focus him.
Focus him!
Nice.
I'm gonna fucking- Oh, chaser!
Chaser!
Oh my god.
He's all over the- No, I'm fucking disoriented.
I might need like, a five minute break.
My eyes are like, crossing eyes.
Oh my god.
He jumped.
Our rocket raccoon is jumping.
I have to stay on the cart.
He's actually- He's jumping.
He's actually jumping.
No, I'm not good.
I'm not good.
I'm getting like, disoriented.
Oh,
nice.
That's right!
Now he knows how I felt!
Now they know how I felt when I had to deal with it.
Okay.
We're all staying together, right?
Wow!
Oh my
- That's fine.
That's fine.
I'm on it.
That's- Oh my god.
Oh my god.
My aim is not good on Mantis, right?
I'm sorry.
I swear.
I have 40% average accuracy on Mantis.
I swear to god.
Just today's not- This game is not it.
I've been playing Luna for like, nine hours straight.
I've been like, Luna and Adam, nine hours straight.
That's just-
Today's not it.
I swear to god.
My Mantis is a lot better than this.
I swear to god, chat.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm shot at it.
I swear.
I will pull up my fucking Mantis replays.
I have to prove to you guys that I can play Mantis.
I swear to god.
I will pull up my Mantis replays to prove to you guys.
Also, for all everyone new here who's watching for the very first time, my name is Doki.
I usually stream on YouTube, but since I'm doing the Marble Rivals grind, I'm on Twitch right now.
I'm mostly streaming the grind on Twitch.
Alright.
I think it's also because I'm like, just hyped up on Caffeine and stuff.
So, I usually play on high ground, but I want damage boost for my team, honestly.
They are definitely not TPing.
I don't know.
I feel like I should play here, but...
Because I need range to...
get five.
They're so five.
Oh, I'm not.
I'm backing up now.
I'm slowly backing up.
I'm slowly backing up here.
Wait.
Okay.
Whoa!
I swear!
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
I was gonna say, I swear to god of you.
Oh no.
Oh big, thank you.
Wait, what?
That didn't hit?
Still losable.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh, I don't have leaves!
I'm so sorry!
Oh shit, nice!
Yeah!
I swear!
Oh my god.
We did it.
We're good.
Don't look at my accuracy.
But we're good.
Give me five minutes.
I need to reset myself a little bit.
My aim was not, was not it for Mantis.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that was such a bad Mantis game for me.
That was actually Alright, I'm pulling up the vods.
I'm pulling it up.
I see.
Oh my god.
Alright, look at this shit.
Look at this.
Woah!
Alright, look at this guys.
Watch this.
Woah!
Okay, not this yet, but Oh shit, look at that!
And then, oh my god.
Oh ho ho!
And then Watch this guys.
Boom!
And then he's dead.
But this part is my favorite part.
This is my favorite part of this.
Oh my god.
I told you!
I brought receipts out.
I'm pulling out the receipts.
Told you.
When I'm not tired.
When I'm not like, when I'm not tired I admit, fuck you, we won that game.
Lucky shot.
Look, I cooked that game.
Exhibit A.
Guys, I'm tired right now.
My aim is not it for Mantis.
Cause like, Mantis's speed like, projectile is so different cause Luna's hitscan, Mantis's projectile, and my brain has not swapped over projectile today.
I'm too tired for that.
Like, my brain has not swapped yet.
So...
I kept the receipts just in case people judge me for my Mantis gameplay.
I keep receipts.
Everything will be okay.
Oh shit!
Wait.
Wait, but he's one above all.
You know what?
Get in my friends list.
I'll collect you all like the collector.
Yeah, that's the Widow.
That's the lucky Widow.
You know like the collector in Marvel Rivals?
Get in here.
Quick receipt.
Yeah, I think the games might take a bit to get in anyway.
So, I'll be fine.
It'll be fine.
Is Mendo still Diamond?
I don't know.
Yes, he is.
Poor guy.
Collecting the Infinity Stones.
That's rough buddy though.
That's rough.
GM1 to Diamond 1 sounds like...
That's like when you even get down to GM3, you'd stop by then.
I feel like.
Like, that's just...
Oh my god.
I'm just thinking like how much money did like the Wind Traders made from that to be like...
The fact that people like accepted the friend request to like...
They must have been like a lot of them were just queuing around that time.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Like how much money...
How much money would you get paid for it too?
I would never derank from GM because I'd stop.
If I have too much of a derank, I'd stop.
If I know it's like impossible to get it back.
Yeah.
I'm just curious how much money they made just from doing that.
So PB, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
After watching YouTube and your gameplay, all hail the somehow surviving unicorn.
What does that mean?
Also, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Next game.
My favorite skin?
I actually really like the skins for Marvel Rivals but like not enough to pay for any yet.
Because like uh...
Oh yeah, 100 bitties.
Sorry.
Oh my god!
Timmy, thank you for the... Holy shit!
Thank you for the raid, Timmy.
Thank you for the raid.
Oh my... Hello, everybody.
I did not expect to see that.
Can we ban Hulk and then Hawkeye?
Or Hela if they don't already ban her?
Alright.
I'm buying Hawkeye.
I don't care what my duo says.
Hello!
My name is DokiBird.
I usually stream on YouTube, but I'm doing my Marvel Rivals grind on Twitch.
Because I have no idea...
I have no idea like when I'll get to like Eternity, but today's the day.
I'm gonna try and get it.
Today's the day.
I've been...
I've been stuck in GM for like a week now.
But today's the day.
It's gonna be that day.
If not, then I guess I guess I install.
Oh my god.
But we're gonna make it.
I'm feeling lucky.
I gotta say I'm feeling lucky.
I banned curses in my chat, so no one can curse me this time.
I'm gonna take 6 hours.
6 hours?
You think 6 hours is baby hours?
I've been playing for like 9 plus hours already.
You think I care about 6 hours?
Yesterday I grinded like 15 plus hours.
You think I care?
Alright.
Guys, I swear to god.
The moment I get to the top 500 leaderboards, it's over.
I'll be back to normal.
I'm not normal right now.
Like, I'm very addicted.
I'm so fucking addicted right now.
Oh yeah, I play... I flex all supports but Rocky Raccoon cause why the fuck?
Oh my god.
Wait, we didn't ban Mantis!
Okay.
Alright.
It'll be fine.
Mantis is not banned, but it's fine.
Oh, is this an Eternity game?
Alright.
That's fine.
It's fine.
He says that and he's on Rocky Raccoon.
Please fucking...
Oh, thank god they're also on Rocky Raccoon.
Thank god we have both teams that wanna fucking lose.
Like...
Thank god.
Jesus Christ.
That makes me happy.
Both teams...
Oh, sorry.
I broke my Punisher's walls.
I'm already throwing.
That's okay.
They don't know that.
I didn't even watch the bot.
Alright.
Oh, he got pulled too.
Oh, they have... Oh!
Just more damage.
Can I pull that penny in?
No, do not pull the penny in!
Do not... Oh!
Fuck it!
They should not have pulled the penny in.
Oh my god, I couldn't freeze that.
I got fucking hit.
Support for Ragnarok.
If we had a Mantis, things would be so much easier.
Wait...
There's no reason to not play Mantis.
Except this is like 3.45am so people...
He doesn't really wanna win that badly.
He's literally on Rocky Raccoon.
Oh, I'm not ulting for that.
Fucking my ult doesn't...
My ult doesn't even save you from that.
Like...
The reason why I didn't ult that is because it doesn't matter.
My ult literally doesn't save you.
Wait, this is winnable!
This is so winnable!
Okay, let's...
Now we dance.
This is so winnable.
Oh my... Oh fuck, okay.
Where is he?
Wait...
This is so winnable.
Rocket, why did you run away from the ult that would save you?
The one ult that would save you.
Oh my god, why does everybody run away?
I don't understand.
Is it?
Is it though?
Can't break that now.
I need to reload my hands.
Nope, this is where I died.
This is...
They're trolling, dude.
The score wheel is not 100%.
It bugs out.
I've had it happen since...
They hotfixed it somehow.
In a way that...
Oh hey, Raccoon got TKs.
They made it so that...
If someone can do exclamation point Luna...
Sometimes, it'll get stuck on damage.
Because I've done it today in the morning.
In my first couple of games today.
And I had two games where it got stuck on damage and I lost a game because of it.
Because we got Groot ulted and I was doing a scroll wheel.
We got Groot ulted, we lived but then nobody was getting healed.
So the scroll wheel does not fucking work.
And it like... yeah.
Yeah, that's why I don't do scroll wheel anymore.
Yeah, I got flamed because I got stuck on damage.
Like, why the fuck are you in damage?
And on my screen, it was clearly on heal.
Like, it was on heal.
And they're like, the fuck you doing?
And I'm like, I'm sorry.
Please don't yell at me.
I'll cry.
I've been playing for way too long.
I play Wolverine.
You play Wolverine?!
Yeah, I agree.
Mantis is not even hard!
Like, how do you struggle on fucking Mantis of all fucking characters?!
Okay.
Alright.
I swear- oh!
He was not near me.
Oh!
You're fine.
You're so healthy.
Oh my god, I think he has ult.
He has ult.
100%.
Oh, they have strange ult.
Oh my god!
My mic works!
We have no defensive ult for it.
Oh my god.
Why not strange?
I feel like- I feel like strange is- Strange!
Oh my god.
We live for one strange ult.
Oh, that's huge, that's huge.
Penny, penny, penny, one.
Oh yeah, that's five.
Wait, strange has- oh, careful.
Yeah, I am only 68%.
I'm 80%.
Okay.
That's five.
Left side Bucky, left side Bucky.
I have ult, I have ult.
Left side Bucky still.
I need heals, I need heals.
I'm so low.
I'm really low.
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh, I'm alive!
I'm so alive!
Oh my god.
I'm so scared.
I'm just gonna play here.
What's the worst that could happen?
I'll be too far away from my team.
That's behind you guys.
Okay, you don't live through that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fine.
They don't live through that.
They don't live through the ult.
I know they don't live through it.
I just did it for- to see if I could bait more ults out.
They still have strange ult, yeah.
Oh yeah.
I just did that just because I wanted to see if I could bait more ults out.
Alright, that's fine.
I need to put this on somebody.
Everything is so healthy.
Not really.
Oh!
There's the eye!
Don't use anything.
They used three ults.
That's good for us.
Good job.
I should have ult soon.
No, he does not have his turret set up.
Okay, come on.
We're gonna TP.
They have defensible too.
Alright.
Let's go!
Alright, like right on them.
Right on them?
Okay.
Fuck yeah.
This is beautiful.
I love this.
Alright, I'm going in!
I'm gonna kite it.
Oh my god!
What?
I didn't...
Oh my god!
This is the last fight.
I'm gonna get psyched here.
Can someone touch?
Nah, I can't.
Is someone able to touch him?
Wolverine maybe?
Oh my god!
I didn't...
I didn't hear the...
the punish ult.
I froze somebody.
Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
I didn't hear the punish ult!
I would have Q'd!
If I heard... Okay, to be fair, we'd still die.
Yeah!
I didn't hear it!
The sound Q didn't go off!
I would have Q'd the moment...
We would have died still.
The punish ult with Raccoon ult fucking strikes everything.
Like...
Oh my god, that fucking sucked.
If I heard it, I would instantly Q'd.
But also, we would not have lived.
We would definitely...
It was...
Was it the turret?
I think it was the ult.
Everybody got shredded so fast.
Oh my god, that was fucking crazy.
See, Raccoon wouldn't...
If we had a Mantis, their Raccoon was better.
If we had a Mantis, we would have two defensive ults.
Two defensive ults that could have countered each other.
That could have countered everything.
Oh hey, Mendo got back to...
GM.
Good for him.
Yeah, it was way too fast.
Turret kills don't kill that fast.
Oh my god.
By the way, Jimin didn't hear the sound Q.
Mendo.
That's not some...
That's not something to brag about, Mendo.
I don't know why you would...
I don't know why you would brag about that.
And one game off.
Eternal.
Oh.
Damn.
That's rough.
That's actually rough.
That's so rough, man.
Alright, Hawkeye.
Okay.
Do we get Mantis?
Do we have a Mantis player?
Do we...
Cause I can play Mantis.
Some... Okay.
No, okay, we don't.
That's fine.
That's okay.
I didn't... Yeah, I think they...
I think they thought I said Rocket.
That's okay.
That's okay if they think I said Rocket.
Cause like, for those of you who don't know...
The support meta is Luna and Mantis.
And Luna is banned.
Mantis, Adam.
If Mantis and Luna are banned, then it's...
Adam, Cloak, I believe.
And then it's like, whatever.
No, then it's a free-for-all combination.
You can play anything.
Adam's really, really fucking good.
People just don't know how to play him.
If you get a really shitty man, they just don't know how to play him.
Cause he's actually like, hardcore meta now.
No Mantis team throwing.
But that's okay.
Let's hope the other team is also throwing.
No, Rocket is fucking garbage.
Nobody bans Rocket.
Cause no one...
If you have a Rocket, then it's just GG's.
DoQ loves Rocket Punisher?
The thing is, a lot of fucking...
A lot of team...
A lot of duos are fucking terrible at Rocket though.
Oh, I'm fucking going back then.
We already lost somebody.
Alright, guess I'm going back in.
I dropped down.
Accidentally.
I didn't know there was a hole!
I didn't know there was a fucking hole down there!
Dude, I didn't know like, where I was.
I don't like this spot.
At all.
I really...
Why are we still here?
Like, why are we...
Honestly, why are we still here?!
Let us go!
I didn't know where we TP'd!
I'm like, why are we still here?
In the backline!
I should've stopped healing, but I wanted my ult.
There's no reason to play down there.
Play back there.
Unless our team got picks while we were behind them, but I don't think our team did.
I don't think our team did get picks while we were behind.
Alright.
Infinite?
There you go.
Alright.
You don't live these.
You don't live these, so just hope that you kill them.
We don't live these either.
Oh, thank god!
The enemy team also doesn't wanna win.
Oh, thank god.
Could we play Mantis?
Luna?
Now I'm on my knees.
Literally, we can win this if we have Mantis.
Oh, yeah.
We would have two defensible.
Oh, both teams are...
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Let's swap it up, buddy.
Let's swap it up.
I don't know why you can't play Mantis.
It's literally...
Right click and E.
That's all you gotta do.
Now we have two defensible.
Let's go.
Right click and E.
It's that simple.
It's actually that simple.
Right click and E.
Right click.
E.
There we go.
Sleep!
Okay, I don't know why the sleep didn't get it.
Okay.
I don't know why the sleep didn't go in there.
Sorry.
We just died, I guess, buddy.
We're just gonna have to die here.
Let's go.
E is I.
That's fine.
What are they looking at?
Are we portaling?
Or did we just look at each other like that?
Guys, how am I throwing?
I am just doing what I can in this scenario.
I am in a world where...
Alright.
Like, I wanna ult, but like, I don't know.
I have to.
He's gonna die.
Oh my god, okay!
He threw because you always mantis ult first.
It's always mantis ult first.
It doesn't matter.
Oh my god, that sucks.
Literally...
Literally, you mantis ult first, and then you Luna.
It's always like that.
I didn't think, like...
I didn't think he would do it.
I have to write mantis ult first, then Luna.
No, I still have one more.
I still have one more.
I don't feel so good.
Yeah.
I asked in the beginning, and then they ignored.
I would've played mantis if they wanted to.
It's fine.
I feel like rocket players are always around at this time.
This is the only clown hours where they survive.
I don't know.
I feel like these hours are the only times they actually...
What?
I don't know why you...
I didn't know you...
I didn't know...
What?
There was no reason to...
What do you mean, waited so long?
They had every ult.
I had to use mantis ult.
Our team was okay.
Our team didn't need mantis ult yet.
What?
I wasn't gonna fucking pop it whenever.
What the fuck did he mean?
I didn't know you were gonna use it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, our team is fucked.
Oh, there he goes.
What?
Where's our tank?
Where did our tank go?
Oh my god.
I feel like I got gaslighted there.
I feel like I got GGs, I guess.
GGs?
What was I supposed to do in that situation?
I mean, I don't know.
Our team was a little special there.
It really was.
We could four stack.
No, but I would lose so...
I don't know if he's winning.
I don't know.
My Luna said why I didn't ult faster.
Why I didn't ult faster when our team was full HP.
And I knew you guys had all the aggression.
So they double
Your Luna was a rocket player and he should ask for permission to speak first of all.
Jesus Christ.
Do you want a four stack?
Chat is asking.
Okay.
I don't know how good this... I don't know who he's playing with.
Honestly.
Oh wait, he's five stack.
Oh, chat is asking.
Never mind, you're a three...
He's a three stack!
What the fuck?
Okay, wait.
You're a four stack already?
I was with someone.
I can't ditch him.
I can't ditch Ruben.
Oh my god.
I just invited Mace to boost me.
Wait.
Oh, I'm still Ruben.
I got kidnapped.
Oh my god.
I don't know why he did that.
I...
I got kidnapped by Mende.
Squad.
But I thought he was duo'd.
And I asked if he wanted a four stack.
But he was already three.
Oh my god, I'm in a fucking dilemma.
Guys.
I'm in a fucking...
Guys, now I have too many choices.
Guys.
I have...
Oh my god.
Guys.
We can't five stack too.
Oh.
What a...
Back to dive.
Bro.
That's fucked.
I don't need...
That's messed up, bro.
I'm not stealing your stack.
Your stack.
I'm not stealing his stack, man.
Guys, please.
We can figure this out.
But...
We need a six.
But six stacking is hard, though.
Okay.
Alright.
We're back.
Okay.
Alright.
We just gotta dodge.
I don't trust...
I don't trust Mende's team.
I don't know who the other two players are.
But I'm pretty sure those two players...
I have you know.
I ditched gamers for this.
And we lose another.
I'm sorry.
Alright.
Are they...
Oh, they're in game.
Oh, their Q was faster.
Okay.
Nice.
I said gamers.
Guys, that's plural.
That's literally...
Guys, Ruben's good.
But that was three other gamers, guys.
That's three players I know that are very competent.
And I have to trust on four randoms.
I have to trust four randoms.
That's the thing.
But all... But the other one, I know three of them have like roles that I know they can play.
Now, I have four people who I don't know.
No, um...
Marble Rivals only let you do every stack except for five because they feel bad for the random.
They feel really bad.
Um...
They like... They feel bad for the one guy that has to like deal with...
Yeah, the sixth random might troll.
The sixth random will feel left out.
And be like, you know what?
Fuck you guys.
Yeah, guys.
I went with singular gamer instead of gamers.
Guys, I need you guys to know that.
Oh my god, are you fucking... Oh my god.
I can't not die.
Where are my Mantis gamers?
Like...
Oh my god.
Where are my fucking Mantis players?
Like, I know this Loki does not play anything else because he has the fucking hero thing.
Loki is pretty goaded.
Yeah, but you know what's better than Loki?
Mantis if she's not banned.
Literally, that's it.
And I have a Black Panther, which is like a roulette of if he's good or not.
It's a roulette if the enemy team can counter him or not.
If the fucking Luna is like...
the most... the goddest of all Lunas.
And Mantis too.
If the enemy team has a Mantis Luna, this Panther is not gonna be able to play.
Okay.
Guys, where the fuck are my Mantis players?
Honestly.
If anything, where are my Luna players so I can play Mantis?
At least.
You know what's better than two Luna ults?
A Luna and a Mantis.
A Mantis for the speed boost aggression.
That's better.
Okay.
Oh my god, the first freeze of the day.
Oh my...
Oh my god!
Okay, that's fine.
I would love to retreat, but these guys wanna fucking play.
Poor Captain America died for our sins.
Like...
Alright, that's fine.
Oh!
Let's hope our...
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
You know what?
I don't wanna live.
I...
Oh yeah!
They had Luna!
Of course they did.
Of course they had Luna and Mantis.
Of course.
Alright.
I didn't wanna live anyway.
After getting ran at by those people.
We got this, guys.
I feel so confident.
Okay, I feel...
Jesus Christ, they are taking so much damage.
I need a clap.
They're all in a singular line, so I'm gonna clap.
Oh, I wasted the clap, actually.
I thought they'd be closer.
Oh, nice!
Why are they not taking enough damage for me to...
Jesus!
Oh my god.
Nice.
Oh, please.
Please get in here.
Please.
Where's my team?
Where...
Oh my god.
Oh!
Alright.
Help.
Okay.
Hey, guys.
Thank you.
Loki.
Oh, thank god Loki got to.
Oh, thank god.
You're useful.
But Liv, please.
Liv, you're our only healer.
Loki, please.
Loki, be alive.
Is he dead?
He's dead, guys.
Alright.
I'm not building ult fast enough because my tanks are dying so fucking fast.
They literally get like one shot.
It's actually crazy.
They get kidnapped and then I guess they fall?
Oh my god.
He's so low.
Please.
Don't get kidnapped.
I'm big of you.
That's all I ask for.
Just live.
Don't get kidnapped.
Guys.
I'm a little worried because nobody... Oh, there you go.
Can we like, you know, not let him fucking look at me like that?
I don't need to use it yet.
Okay, maybe I do.
No, I don't.
Liv.
This is so winnable.
Oh my god, maybe it's not.
Oh, it's so winnable.
Didn't have to use my ult.
Look at that.
That's called restraint.
That's called fucking restraint.
I didn't even pop my ult there.
I was like, no, this is totally winnable.
I can keep my ult.
Oh my god.
I'm not gonna jinx it.
I'm not gonna jinx it, guys.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
Everything will be fine.
I believe.
It'll be okay.
Let me heal.
What?
What is that even?
What does that even mean?
It's okay.
Oh,
I thought I got that freeze.
That's unlucky.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my god, please!
What's going on?
Please, heal me!
Wait, okay, I need to watch.
I need to watch where the Loki Luna went.
Where is she?
Are any of you alive?
It's okay.
It's alright.
I'm coming in.
Oh, I don't need to use it yet.
Okay, I need to use it now.
Oh my god!
This might be where I die.
Nope, it's fine.
Okay!
Like, I'm sorry.
I can't...
Like, that's a lot of ults.
Like, I don't know what you want me to do.
No, they used it.
They used it.
I'm not sure about Mantis, but they used Luna.
I'm in a fucking building.
Oh my god.
We won that somehow.
Like, that's crazy.
We won that fucking fight.
Oh, shit.
Oh, good for you.
My bad.
Oh, she's low, she's low too.
She's one, she's one.
Cap your wallet off for a minute.
Oh my god, fuck it, I'll just walk around.
I don't care, I'm doing this shit for America.
Alright, that's Captain America right there.
That's Captain America.
He's gonna do this for America, guys.
Oh my god.
Oh!
magic's frozen.
Alright, yes, I ulted on point.
Magic's low, magic's low.
Alright.
Let's go, let's fucking, I'm leaving.
Oh, Grizzlow.
That's fine.
Everything is, oh my god, we're winning against Luna Mantis!
There is a god in this world.
Miracles do exist.
Miracles actually exist in this world, that's crazy.
That's actually, that's when you know god exists.
That's when you fucking know if you can win against a Mantis Luna, a low-key Luna, god is real.
Cause we just saw a miracle.
To be fair, we did have a Black Panther that harassed the shit out of them.
Hey, it's you.
Hey, it's him.
Oh my god.
It's him.
Our Black Panther is really good.
I was very surprised, usually Luna Mantis can shut him down.
And they're god low-key true.
Luna Mantis lost twice, why are they meta?
You see, there are shitty players that play Luna Mantis.
So...
So like, it's just RNG.
You get a person that actually knows how to play Luna Mantis the most optimal way you can, or you just get people without hands.
How close are we?
We're not close.
We're not fucking close at all.
Oh hey, what's your...
GM1.
Oh hey, who's the fuck is Gloomy?
Who's this guy?
I didn't even get you in a game, you're watching my stream.
You weren't even in my game, you just added me because you were watching my stream.
I'm just like, wait a minute, I don't recognize your name.
Alright, big fan.
True.
Oh hey, we got the...
Do we get second miracle?
You think that's possible?
What if I just... I need to ban Mantis then.
I wish...
I wish I could just ban Mantis.
I really don't want to play this against Hulk and...
Hulk and Iron Man.
So I usually...
Oh.
JK.
I forgot.
Confirming characters first.
That's awkward.
I'll ban Hulk first.
Yeah, I have the same...
I have the same Loki player.
So I'm just hoping to god the enemy team will ban Mantis.
We got...
Hawkeye.
No.
I just like, let's just gamble.
Oh, they ban Luna.
Oh, I can play Mantis then.
Mantis Luna works.
Mantis Loki works.
That's fine.
We got...
Okay, cool.
Cool.
Alright.
Mantis Loki works.
Maybe it will be okay.
Nice.
I'm surprised Luna Mantis hasn't been banned yet.
Because I like...
Adam's fun to play.
Imagine they ban Mantis Luna.
I don't mind.
I've been playing so many games where they ban Mantis Luna that it made me flex to other characters.
I thought Cloak was good.
At first people thought Cloak was good, but I think she's actually a dog shit.
Unless you have every fucking support ban possible.
Cloak is okay.
But Adam's just better.
It's like when Mantis Luna is banned and you play Cloak.
Cloak.
Adam.
But you should play the Adam part.
I have a nigger win rate on Cloak.
I don't even think I play her badly.
I just...
I just never have a positive...
I don't have a positive win rate on Cloak at all.
I don't think I play Cloak badly.
I'm just unlucky when...
I'm unlucky when Mantis Luna is banned and I have to play Cloak.
I have a positive win rate on all my other supports.
Like all you have to do...
People don't know that you can like...
There's so much mobility on Cloak.
People just don't use it.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, that's not you.
There we go.
It's this way.
I was getting lost.
Oh, okay.
Oh, he's so low.
He's so low.
Oh my God!
I will make him go to sleep!
Just let... Oh!
He did not live.
He did not live, but that's okay.
Because he didn't either.
Oh my God.
That was scary.
That was very scary.
Live.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah, but...
Oh, it's that guy, bro.
He's actually so good at Scarlet, though.
That guy is actually really good.
That guy was on...
Um...
Hey, headshot.
Oh my God.
Please.
I need to...
Oh my God.
She already got ult.
So do I.
In 20 seconds.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's hope we get kills out of this, then.
I don't... I'm scared.
Oh my God.
We can kill him, right?
Nice.
We did.
Come on.
Damage.
You can kill him.
I believe.
Oh, shit.
Alright.
Did I get something right?
Nope.
That's five.
I don't know about that, but that's...
Okay.
The rock was very scary and intimidating.
Help me.
No!
It's fine.
Just stall the point.
Alright, I almost have ult.
It's fine.
Alright.
Can you kill her?
Alright, can you kill her?
Doesn't look like it.
Alright, can you kill her now?
Alright.
Nice.
That's a big one right there.
Oh, no.
The goddamn pillar.
Oh my God.
I hate aiming here.
This is...
Oh my God.
Okay, let's go.
Just, please.
Push forward.
Please.
I'm dropping down.
Oh, fuck this.
I don't want to play up there anymore.
Alright.
That's okay, Groot.
Thank God.
Get that Scarlet Witch.
There we go.
Thank God.
No, that's just...
That was a hate crime right there.
I witnessed a natural hate crime.
Oh, thank God.
I denied his again, though.
I really appreciate it.
I denied it.
Alright.
Thank God, I did not want to go again.
I really, really did not want to go again.
What time is it?
Oh, it's 430.
Oh, guys.
It's 430 AM, but I'm committed.
We're not ending stream until eternity.
I don't care.
I don't fucking care.
It'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
This is it.
And then I'll never... No, I'll still go crazy.
Because I want the top 500.
I want top 500.
But the quality of the games will get better in eternity, right?
People are so much better.
The quality of the games should get better.
Okay.
That's how it usually goes, right?
Woah.
Oh my God!
Okay.
I have...
Oh my God.
They have BP.
This is scary.
I'm gonna back out then.
Don't worry, Loki.
I got you.
And I got you too, Magneto.
You're fine already, but that's okay.
I still got you.
As long as Remedy is not...
Remedy is not on an aim hero, I'm like, okay.
Because Remedy...
Remedy is so scary on Hela.
I played Remedy on my team and she was on Hela.
She literally diffed people so hard.
The only reason they're like...
The only reason they're not on...
Goodbye.
Sorry, buddy.
It's because of their ping, apparently.
Their ping is really bad right now.
Where the fuck...
Oh, there he is.
I like ran away.
There was no way I was gonna live through that.
Yeah, I don't wanna deal with...
Oh, I need to save my... That means I have to save my...
I'll just save my sleep for Black Panther.
Here.
Jesus Christ, he's so fucking fast.
Someone lower his DPI.
Right now.
You know what?
I believe in your DPS, Loki.
I'm gonna damage boost you.
Nice.
Oh, stand down!
Hit me again!
Come on!
Oh, he's dead.
He's dead.
That's okay.
We don't need it.
That's fine.
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh my god, I just wanna know what his DPI is.
What is that?
I feel like playing Black Panther...
You have to like...
Your sensitivity must be so fucking high.
What are you aiming?
Your only aim is your spear.
Goodbye.
Are they okay?
Oh, they're okay.
They're so safe.
Someone up top?
I heard them.
I swear.
I'm not crazy.
I knew it!
I fucking knew it!
Oh my god.
That's okay.
Oh shit!
I'm alive?!
I don't know about him though.
Where is he?
I can't...
I was like, where is the fucking Mantis?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
We did it.
That's why when people say, I don't know how to play the Mantis, Mantis and Luna has to be the easiest fucking character you can play as support.
It's when you play like Adam and Adam is when things get complicated.
Cause like, you have to like think about like, oh they're low, but do they really need this heal?
Like...
I'd be like, oh man.
Do they really need this?
Or can my other support do the job for me?
It's all about, Adam is all about restraint.
And that's how I had to learn how to play.
Like, Adam is literally just restraint cause you're just like, I could heal you.
But like, you don't really need it.
No, Jeff is fucking terrible.
I mean, there's like a couple of Jeff one tricks that are really good.
But like, why play Jeff when other support combos are just better?
And there's like, Jeff is map dependent too.
Cause there's no outside there's no like outside borders for Jeff.
So it's like, the ult is practically useless.
Cause you can't kill them.
You can't really kill them.
Usually, I still have, I've learned this, but you use Jeff to like, get if you die, if it's last fight and you died, and you died early on, you use Jeff to like get back on time.
To like, heal the team.
But Jeff is so...
Like, if you're a one trick, obviously, one tricks are just really good in general.
But, it's just, you also have to be a fucking masochist to be a one trick.
Cause everybody fucking hates you.
Like, if you lose, you get shit talked.
And like, but they'll specifically blame you, cause you're not playing meta.
Just like what I did.
I'll be like, you fucked this Reku one trick.
Like,
yeah, I'd be a fucking masochist if you were in a one trick.
In general.
The rank 1 Wolverine?
The thing is, Wolverine is meta.
Wolverine's not bad.
He's literally meta.
Cause people actually realize, Wolverine's really fucking good in general.
So it's like, yeah, if you're a one trick on a...
The only issue is like, if you're a one trick, and you can't play any other character.
That's fucking terrifying.
That's the terrifying part.
Cause like, the moment you ban a one trick, they're fucking useless.
That's why people target ban.
I target ban.
I 100% target ban.
I'm fucking taking any advantage I can get.
If I know what you play, and I know you're useless in everything else, I would fucking...
Ah shit, okay.
I almost went Raccoon.
That's fine.
I can do Mantis.
I am a professional hater.
Oh my god.
No, I'm gonna hate right now.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking hate right now.
Yeah, but apparently if you... Yeah, but the thing about being infamous is... Oh my god, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna spread hate right now.
If you wanna play Loki, just play Adam.
If you want to play Mantis, we can trip sup with Adam.
Mantis.
Luna.
Loki works too.
It's fine.
Loki works.
I can get back Luna.
And I'll play her.
Alright, Loki works but Adam's better.
It's better.
Any triple support combo works.
It's just the most optimal is you have to have Adam in the third slot.
Because of the Soulbond.
The Soulbond makes it work.
It's literally like just the Soulbond.
What the fuck am I watching?
Like, I wanted to fucking set up high ground and then I see this?
Where?
Oh my!
Okay.
How the?
Okay, what's my team doing?
Everybody is so spread out.
Like, actually, what are they doing?
Like, what happened?
What the fuck happened, guys?
Like, what's going?
Oh my gosh.
It tucked Jeff and then my team got fucking distracted by a Jeff.
Actually.
But this is a Jeff map, though, if you guys want to know.
This is a Jeff map.
Like, what happened?
I literally turned around.
Like, why did I just watch my tanks build fucking Fortnite?
Yeah, this is one of the very rare Jeff maps where it can work.
But I've also beaten Jeff one tricks before.
Like, if we have a team, that's just better.
Is the Psylocke to your left?
Alright.
Psylocke on the left.
I just said that!
Fuck me, I guess.
You're right.
You're fucking right.
Fuck my opinions.
Goodbye.
I got hit by the pillar.
See, this is why it's a...
This is exactly why.
No, it's...
I saw myself pop up on the top left.
Okay.
Can we get this?
Yeah, we can get this.
Get the shark!
I'm the only one that shot!
I was the only one that shot.
That's actually crazy.
I was the only one that shot the shark.
That's... Oh my god.
Oh my...
They have rez.
That's chill.
Why did no one else touch the shark?
That's fine.
That's so fine.
Alright.
Where's my other DPS?
There he is.
Oh, where's my only DPS?
Alright, I'm just gonna back up.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, nice.
They're born again.
There's Psylocke here.
Psylocke on me.
I knew it!
I knew my mic worked!
He acknowledged me!
I fucking knew it!
He just...
I knew my mic worked.
I fucking knew it.
Oh.
He's asleep though.
Oh, he woke him up.
That's okay.
I'm all dial-up though.
I'll touch here.
I'm just gonna ult this.
Alright, I can die here.
So I can go Luna.
That's fine.
I can go Luna.
I'm fine with that.
That's a death I'm willing to take to be on Luna.
Alright.
Stop cheering the Jeff on!
I wanna win!
Dead.
No Judge Jury for you.
Oh, please just heal me a little bit.
Please, I just... Okay, there you go.
Oh my god!
Oh.
Sucks to be him, I guess.
I need to reload my hands and I don't wanna be too close.
Oh, he's lit.
He actually... Strange has ult.
Jesus Christ.
Strange, there's a Jeff behind us.
That was mine.
Strange is low.
Starlord one.
And there's a Jeff behind us.
No, Strange.
The Jeff is still behind us, by the way.
He's looking for ult.
He's behind.
He's on the cliff.
He's low.
Please!
Somebody kill this Jeff!
Oh my god!
It'll be there forever!
Jeff's just looking for an ult.
Jeff is low.
Goodbye, Thor.
Jeff is half.
Oh.
Morning.
Good morning.
Uh...
We might die low-key.
Alright, we have Luna ult going in.
On point.
Strange is half.
Strange is low.
He can't heal.
Oh my god.
Oh!
This is his last fight.
Alright.
Top left!
Who's banging that drums?
I froze him!
Oh.
I'm dead here, though.
No, no Luna heals.
Oh, Strange is low!
Strange is one!
Wait, Starlord's half.
Oh no.
Nice, Starlord.
I got...
Yeah, nice.
Jeff, Jeff, Jeff, Jeff!
Jeff and Starlord!
I might be dead, though.
Oh, I got it!
Nice.
Their entire team's here.
I'm contesting.
Oh my god!
Fuck, he's half!
Where's our portal?
No!
We just got Loki on and he died with it!
No, he copied Strange!
I thought you would copy Luna.
There's Strange at portal.
There's Strange at...
That's what I'm saying!
If you're a fucking Jeff one-trick, you're crazy good at your fucking one-trick.
I have to remember names.
There's too many one-tricks in the... There's too many one-tricks.
So like, I need to remember their one-tricks and stuff.
I like... Oh my god, why did we not fucking...
Just shoot him.
Just fucking shoot him.
Literally, at one point I was the only one that shot the Jeff.
Literally, I was the only one.
I don't know why.
Why was I the only one that shot that fucking shark that was in the back line?
We just needed to, you know, pew pew.
Fucking punt the shark.
Fuck Jeffs.
Honestly, Jaws was right.
I wish I could punch a shark right now.
I could've said something really fucked up and it had something to do with SeaWorld.
I hope SeaWorld keeps bringing sharks in.
This game made me a hater.
I'm a fuck... Yes, I'm a hater.
Oh my god, the worst part is like I can't freeze him when he's in that form.
Cause that hit.
That absolutely hit.
A Sightlock top left.
Guys, I can't heal all of you.
Guys, you're all...
You're all critical.
Oh my god.
Why would you go Cloak but not Mantis?
Mantis is a fucking choice.
Alright.
It's fine.
Jeff is half.
Jeff is low.
Okay, I had to use my ult.
Oh, I didn't have to use my ult.
I gotta keep my KDA, guys.
Guys, I had to because I had to keep my KDA.
You guys don't understand.
The KDA was so important.
Guys.
No, they have Jeff ult.
Up quick.
Oh, and they had that ult too.
Where the fuck did he come from?
Oh shit, that's where he came from.
It's alright, we didn't need it.
I literally am 50% away from another ult.
We don't need it, guys.
We wanted to secure the cap.
Ooh, that's a nice headshot.
There's a Jeff behind us.
Gotta heal our tank.
Yeah, you're not living.
You're not living.
You're absolutely not living.
I don't know what...
Did he?
Okay, yeah.
You're not living that.
I think...
Oh, there's Jeff on me.
Alright.
Jeff is so low too.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I just watched him fucking walk into that and died.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
I can't believe I watched that happen in front of me.
I don't think we win this.
I... Is that even a good ult?
Okay.
I don't...
It's gonna be fine, right?
You're so healthy.
I don't...
Guys, I have a feeling...
Alright.
Can we?
I'll just stand here.
Hey guys, do your thing.
I'm not even gonna move.
They can't even one-shot me.
Oh no.
Guys, this doesn't seem winnable.
Alright, I'm not looking.
I'm not looking.
I'm not... Don't look at this.
You will die instantly, guys.
Just walk backwards.
Hiding is an option.
Or not.
Fucking idiot.
Oh shit!
Woah!
Jeff!
Hey there, Jeff!
Oh shit!
I got baited!
I was gonna fuck around with Jeff!
I actually fucked me around!
He was just going around, and I was just like, eh.
I don't...
Guys, this is not looking so good.
This is absolutely...
Like, what is this game?
Anyway.
Like, what am I...
What am I looking at?
What the fuck am I looking at?
Like...
Guys...
I think...
Like, is everybody okay?
I don't think everybody is okay.
Oh my god, we got a pick.
That's crazy.
That's absolutely crazy.
Oh my god.
I'm just gonna...
chill up here.
Is he gonna do Eye of...
Eye?
I know you have it.
I know you have the Eye.
You're so healthy, everybody.
Oh my god, we moved the panel just a little bit more!
That's crazy.
I'm still playing my game.
I just...
I just don't think that...
I don't know.
It's...
It's looking a little...
It's looking...
If you wake him up, I swear to god...
If you... Oh, at least he didn't wake him up though.
It's just...
Nobody wants to help me.
Nobody!
That's okay.
Nobody wants to help me.
What is this queue?
You suck?
Bro was not on the winning team!
Alright.
I don't know who to avoid.
Everybody was pretty bad.
Just don't play DPS when you fed on tank when I was on support.
Who?
What?
Who are we yelling at?
Like...
Who's... Who were we yelling at there?
Like, everybody seems to be the problem.
I don't know who we're yelling at.
Yes.
I mean...
Lowest damage output...
It's not...
50% win rate.
That's fine.
I mean, he has a good win rate on Punisher.
He has a...
I mean, he's a good support player.
I don't really need to avoid him.
Unless he's a...
He was the one that plays low-key, right?
64?
That's more than 50%.
Oh, when he is on cloak, he doesn't care.
He just doesn't care.
You guys want to see my cloak win rate?
That's when I care, but I still lose.
Or is it...
Okay.
I don't know who to avoid.
I'll avoid the low-key player.
I don't know.
They all... I don't know.
Pretty...
We're all bad.
We're...
We're all pretty bad as a team.
I think Ruben must have...
Oh.
We cancelled.
I don't want to queue against... We're going to go against them.
I don't want to queue against them.
I really don't want to queue against them.
Honestly.
Wait, was it...
Mace was...
M...
M4C?
Yeah, this is Mace, right?
No.
That's not the Mace.
I know Mendo has his profile hidden.
Was it just Mace?
Oh, it's just Mace.
Okay.
Yeah.
He's one above all?
Oh wait, no.
That's not the right Mace.
Wait, is this the same Mace?
Did he got Mace on an alt account?
Did he got... Oh my god!
Oh my god!
Oh my fucking god!
Ruben, I hope you know I...
I hope you know I fucking...
You're not hearing him!
I gave away a free ticket.
What?!
You told me this now!
Ruben, I...
I haven't slept yet!
I've been...
I've been up since 11am.
No way!
Mace is rank one!
No fucking way!
No, I'm fucking... I had gamer subs before.
Is he in-game?
They're in-game.
Alright.
We're up two.
No, I'm not!
I'm not!
I'm literally...
I started at this elo when I got up.
What the fuck do you mean?
This is a rank one...
I didn't realize.
I was like...
Oh yeah, I got so many...
Oh my god.
I'm not doing 24 hours, Ruben.
Ruben, I'm not doing 24 hours.
I'm fucking...
If we lose the next game, I'm sorry Ruben.
I need it.
A four stack is like the most guaranteed shit ever.
I wanna be like Shroud.
Shroud had...
Now you say that.
I didn't think I'd be up for 24 hours, chat.
I didn't think I'd be up for 24 hours.
Guys,
I don't know everybody.
I literally just ganked.
I know pro players, but there's no pros yet.
There's literally no fucking pros yet in Marvel Rivals.
There's tournaments, but they're not...
It's like they're like getting Overwatch pros.
It's like getting Overwatch pros into Marvel Rivals, but it's not actual like pros in the scene, so I don't know who's good.
I don't pay attention to that.
I only know like a couple of Overwatch players and a couple of Apex players and then nothing in between.
And Shroud.
Because everybody knows Shroud.
Oh wait, Mace is in chat?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they won.
I can't believe they won every game.
Hey, Mace!
Wait, it's Mason!
Wait, what game is Mace from?
Yo, can we be on the same page, man?
Sorry, my bad!
No!
Can you play Hello or not?
Do we have a Hello player?
It's all good, it's all good.
Alright.
Do we have...
Do we have a...
Do we have a Hello player?
Dude!
That was pretty good.
Oh my god.
I've been...
He won't stop until the turn.
I will fucking...
I will commit.
I don't have a YouTube stream today.
To be fair, I don't make my own skit.
I don't have any commitments today.
I just want to be the big guy, but you just want to play DPS.
Fuck, I would mute your countdown, though.
We would.
Wow!
Gotta tell my thumbnail maker to mute your countdown.
Alright.
We banned Hulk?
We did.
It's fine.
Hulk is bad.
We also banned Hulk, so like, what the fuck is he gonna do to us?
Like, kill us?
With what damage?
Oh, shit!
Got some squids.
Please.
Okay.
I got healed.
Oh,
goodbye.
Don't worry, our Hella's gonna get that one kill that's gonna rez him.
I believe.
Any day now.
Any fucking day now.
You're gonna get that one kill that's gonna rez him.
Oh, never mind, he's back.
Okay.
Never mind.
He's alive.
Guys, please.
Alright, she's gonna get that one kill that's gonna rez our Thor again.
Any day now.
He's gonna do it.
Right here.
Our Thor is back.
She did it.
She fucking did it.
I knew he could.
See, our Thor is back.
He got the pick, right?
Got the kill.
I think I go.
Oh, that's when he died.
Oh, wait.
We're all five.
There we go.
Don't worry, our Hella's gonna get killed where she's gonna resurrect herself.
I'm still alive because I'm not eternity yet.
I'm back where I started.
Any day now.
Good guy.
Are we okay here?
We're okay here.
We're fine.
Thank you for the gift itself.
Thank you.
Five and ten.
Really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Wait.
Where are you?
That's fine.
Let's just...
You know what?
I believe.
Let's commit to this.
That's five.
Namor behind us.
Yeah, he's half.
He's low.
I can deal with him.
Alright.
Did you deal with it?
Oh my god.
That's five.
Strange one.
Okay, Strange.
Stop.
I think I...
My mic doesn't work again.
Are you serious?
My mic doesn't work.
I looked up in the sky.
With nobody else shooting him.
It's fine.
I don't want people to listen to me anyway.
I don't give good comms.
Who cares about my opinion?
It's fine.
Who cares?
Alright.
Yeah, I'm on my push to talk.
I'm just blowing up this Strange field.
We're so healthy.
We're so fucking healthy.
We're so...
That's what I'm saying.
This Ironman can't do...
That's awkward.
Until now.
Until...
Okay, but like...
Who would've thought...
The only kills he got was like...
With his ult.
Who would've thought?
None of us would've known that.
How was I supposed to know that?
I feel like...
We don't need ult here yet.
I can save.
I have restraint.
Okay.
Do I live through this?
Where's my...
Oh!
Where's Reuben?
I need to see this.
He was up ahead of me.
I thought I could live through that.
I really did.
Alright, let's see.
I wasn't keeping track because I was like...
Where the fuck was my Mantis up?
Oh, let's go!
Let's commit to this!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Let's commit to this!
I'm dancing!
Oh my god!
I'm fucking killing you too.
There we go.
Nice.
That's nice.
We're 3-4?
Okay, I thought you meant that was my record.
I was like, I'm pretty sure it's worse than that.
I was like, there's no way.
There's no way.
Thank you!
Alright.
No, I have a problem.
I 100% have a problem.
I don't.
I can't quit anytime.
And I'm not doing anything about it.
I keep going.
I can play this for long hours.
Not gonna lie.
I'm just that severely addicted to Marble Rivals.
And I don't plan to.
I don't plan to.
My problem exactly.
The problem is I'm not Eternity yet.
That's my problem.
It's not me, it's my teammates.
I think...
I don't know.
I feel like I can be Eternity.
I think my Luna is Eternity level.
My other supports maybe not Eternity level.
I don't know.
This is easy.
I woke him up though.
Look at that.
I'm a real homie.
I woke him up when no one else would.
I guess I'll heal myself.
I guess...
Wow!
Okay.
Sure, I would love to.
I would love to if I'm not fucking blocked in right now.
It's just things that are alive.
It's just you.
Good luck.
Why did you push him?
I should've froze him.
Oh my god.
He pushed him forward.
I could've froze him and then he could've lived.
Are they back on Ironman?
Why?
You have no Hulk player.
Like, what's the point?
Your ace?
Who did you kill?
Who the fuck did you kill to get that ace?
I legitimately feel like...
Oh my god.
I thought he did like zero things.
I didn't even realize he existed in my game.
Oh, he's dead.
I'm dead as fuck.
Oh, oh, oh.
I didn't want to ult.
This is why I'm eternity level.
This is why I personally think I'm eternity.
Oh my god, I lived.
Oh my god.
I deserve that ring.
I fucking deserve that ring.
That's why I'm not ulting.
Oh, I need to reload my hands.
Oh...
You're so...
He still has strange ult.
I should've ulted that.
I didn't think they would...
Jarvis clipped that.
I didn't think they would die there.
I should've ulted that.
Maybe that's strange though, so I don't know if it's...
Oh my god, I froze somebody?
Bro, that is the furthest freeze I've ever hit.
I feel like strange is gonna fly up and be like...
I can feel the strange ult coming.
Until Magneto first, I guess.
He's like, saving it.
It's weird.
Did he open a portal?
Who the fuck?
Oh.
Jarvis, give me Eternity, please.
Please, Jarvis.
I mean,
we have...
Oh my god, this fucker's scary.
Please!
I have to reload hands!
You're taking so much damage!
Oh my god.
My hands can't reload fast enough for all this.
Okay, that's fine.
Maybe I froze somebody.
That was a hell-may-freeze.
He wants it so bad.
Are we killing anything?
Don't worry.
There we go!
I fucking did it!
Oh!
Alright, they're gonna combo that I'm not ulting.
Alright.
Well, now I know that's their combo.
I didn't think that was their combo.
Now I know they'll die.
I'm not gonna ult for a strange ult.
You can't live through that.
You're so bad.
Your movement's so predictable.
Your movement is so predictable, buddy.
Just stay on point.
Goodbye.
It was great seeing you.
Oh, I fucked up a little bit?
Oh yeah, a lot of it.
Dude, they're all on you.
Holy fuck.
Yeah, oops.
Oh my god!
No!
Alright.
This is looking a little bad here.
We are chilling.
This is our group here.
Nice.
Baited.
Alright, nice.
Wait, is our Thor okay?
He is so healthy.
He is so fucking healthy.
He is.
He is actually so healthy.
This is fine.
We're so healthy right here.
Okay, no, it's fine.
You're just poking us!
Do we have?
We do.
Please.
Please!
Oh my god.
We should have ulted this earlier.
Change one!
Change one in the air.
I need to fix my frames.
I'll be five seconds.
Fix your frames?
Guys, it's okay.
My opinion doesn't matter.
No!
Oh, he's back.
Oh, thank god.
I'm okay.
Did they R-man ulted?
Yeah, they wasted it.
Alright.
No!
Come to me!
They can't listen!
They just don't!
They don't!
Strange was one!
They heard me say...
Oh my god, please cover.
They heard me say Strange was one.
They heard...
He just didn't care.
I'm going to name one.
I had to reload hands.
I'm sorry.
I guess I touch point next.
I'm dead instantly.
Send Toki to rehab.
Can we play up top?
Because they're just going to get a portal.
Oh my god.
They should've listened.
They let me look at a one HP Strange.
And nobody shot him.
I...
I don't know what to do.
I'm still GM1.
I'm still stuck in the trenches.
Jesus Christ, 12 deaths?
What the fuck were you doing?
Oh, you're still a warrior.
He gets rez'ed by heli kills.
We should win up here.
The Ironman is going to be melee range.
How does the fuck does Ironman have three...
I'm fucking...
I don't die to him.
I am on...
I lost two... the last game.
I lost the last game.
I'm like win-loss-win-loss at the moment.
It's fucking hell.
They're portaling.
I'm going to freeze the first portal.
Alright.
Watch this.
Okay, they're right here.
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, that's not where I wanted...
That's fine.
This is actually good.
That was definitely bad.
Look at my orb on.
Nice.
Wait.
Okay, I'm putting on the Thor.
The Thor is actually taking so much damage.
I can't heal from here.
People from the front are coming in now.
Ironman is back.
Oh my god, why?
Why did you...
Why did they stuff...
Why did they stuff the door?
Oh my god.
I didn't think they were all going to stuff themselves in the door.
Oh no.
I didn't think they would stuff the door there.
I thought they were going to...
They were going to come out.
Where's the Thor?
I don't...
I don't know where the Thor...
Okay, there's the Thor.
You get the orb.
Oh my god, please.
I'm so close to him.
Reload my hands.
Please take more damage.
Alright.
Oh fuck, I don't know where that is.
Oh, we're all okay though.
Ironman is right here.
No, I wanted to kill Ironman.
Oh my god.
My fucking ult was too long.
I was going to freeze him.
Yeah, I got greedy there.
I think I would have died anyway.
To be fair, unless I positioned myself way back.
That was a misplay by my part.
I was so fucking greedy for the kill.
I just wanted to freeze him.
Oh, Liv.
Liv.
Alright.
Don't have anything for that.
Goodbye.
I have to leave.
Alright, I'm locked in now.
There.
That's when you know.
Punch.
Oh my god.
I couldn't get the freeze off.
No, I hit him.
Guys.
They might get off the point.
Maybe they'll get off the point.
Who knows.
It's literally one tick.
Maybe they'll just get off the point.
Guys, I don't know.
I'm not too hopeful anymore.
I'm not too hopeful anymore, guys.
This is looking mighty.
Mighty dreadful.
Oh, please, please.
Any heals?
Okay, yep.
That's fine.
There's a Neymar behind us.
Oh my god.
Please kill the Neymar behind us.
Alright, we can...
Guys.
I don't know we could push that far.
Oh my god.
That's gonna be super rough.
This is gonna be super fucking rough.
Oh my god.
Definitely very rough.
Guys, I'm not too hopeful anymore.
I'm not too hopeful.
We have to always have ult advantage over them.
You just always have to have ult advantage.
I threw the first... I threw the point there.
I didn't know we were gonna stuff them.
I was so confused.
I thought like...
I was so confused because like I didn't realize they were all gonna stuff them up there and then me... I think... I don't know if Mantis was with them.
But I didn't know if I should have went down... I should have went down there with them.
That was my fault there.
Oh my god.
Now your Iron Man is fucking doing work.
Now I can see why they're doing work now.
Alright.
Oh man.
I had my coolest clip too from this game.
That was such a cool freeze.
That's why I didn't blow up the building.
Because we're gonna blow it up ourselves.
Oh my god!
How do I heal something that dies that fast?
I don't even think I had an angle or two for it.
There we go.
I'll kill her myself.
It's fine.
We killed Mantis so we should move up, right?
If we kill Mantis then like we can move up, right?
If I just stay here, everything will be fine.
I'm just playing point.
Okay, Namor.
Okay.
That was like full confidence in the fact that I will heal him.
That was insane confidence right there.
No, I am.
Careful with the pulse.
That was insane fucking confidence.
Okay.
I'm a little bit worried though.
I feel it.
Yeah, I can win ult this.
I can win ult this.
Alright, let's see you all live that.
I didn't want to take the full impact.
Wait, did they?
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
Wait, I'm not alive.
Oh, I think he's dead.
Oh my god, he's dead.
Okay.
This is last fight.
They don't have any support ults.
Touch it!
Touch the point!
Oh, nice.
Is this gonna kill me?
Where do I go?
There's nowhere to go.
I thought he blocked it.
I thought I had full confidence in my Magneto.
But, clearly...
Clearly, I need to stop.
There's an Ironman behind us.
I froze him.
Can we kill?
Never believing again.
Never.
Never believing in my teammates again.
Oh my god.
That's different.
I got it.
I just got it.
Oh my god.
Jesus Christ.
It's over.
It ended.
I tried to kill Ironman, but he's just so popular.
He has Ice Cube and everything.
Jesus Christ.
Point.
We can't leave point.
Oh my god.
It's just...
There's just no way.
They pushed so far.
That fucking portal.
Ironman ult was fucking crazy.
That actually was crazy.
That was a close game, though.
Oh my god.
They give a Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
55k healing?
I mean, when you have tanks that are fucking in...
They're like in, in.
I think most of my deaths were the stupid Ironman ult.
That was actually so dumb.
Wait, where did he come from?
How did he get into my game?
How did you get in?
You're not even in my friends list.
I didn't even accept anything.
How did you get in?
How did he get in?
He's not even on my friends list.
I don't understand.
Alright, that was crazy.
I don't even know how he got in.
Alright, let's see how Mende's doing.
Oh, they lost.
I'm sorry.
Oh, thank god.
There was... He could lose.
Oh, wait, that means he could lose on my team.
Oh, he's ready.
He's bringing the loss streak over.
True.
He is.
That means...
Losing is possible.
I like how he lost...
And then he swapped over here.
And like...
What is this?
Is this a 3 DPS?
Wait, is Mace the tank player?
Oh, Mace is the tank player!
Okay, I was gonna say.
This is a 2 DPS with tank trio.
Very ambitious.
Because you're expecting your random to go support.
Your randoms to go support.
Which they will, because at these hours, these fucking demon hours, are like the support players that are in here.
Oh my gosh.
I need to like, stretch my hands.
Shooter, thank you for the Twitch Prime!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, one of us has to play support here.
We don't need tanks.
No, tanks are the rarest breed of all in any game.
Because who the fuck wants to go through being a masochist and playing tank?
Tank is like...
There's no soul left in my eyes.
There's none.
Ever since I started playing Marvel Rivals, there's like, no more hope in them.
There's no hope.
As a tank main?
Yes, because like, I'm banning Psylocke.
What if I do it?
What if I fucking do it?
You're gonna have to put in a difficult vote to get a chance of playing Hulk, man.
Dopey!
I saw that, Dopey.
What the fuck is that?
You're the strongest fucking dude in the world.
If I can't play Luna, he can't play Psylocke.
Hell of a friend, bro.
Actually, just work it against me over here.
Fucking hell, man.
If I can't play Luna, he can't play Psylocke.
That's how it goes.
I only play Hulk, so why did you hovel?
Why did you hover straight?
Listen, man.
If you hovered Hulk, we would've we would've known.
I was banning 10 seconds before?
It's all good.
We have no main Saurdash on our team.
So fucking true, man.
Wait, don't ban Hulk.
Dopey, come here.
Do it.
Do a flip.
Nice.
This guy gets on my team and starts throwing.
GG.
It's over.
Why the fuck?
Oh, so that's how people die.
On the map.
That makes sense.
Oh, we're portaling.
No one said anything.
I was so confused.
Don't take the portal.
Just don't take it.
But we gotta pick.
Alright.
This guy wants to run my ones.
My team okay?
I can't tell.
Yeah, we can't walk here.
We need to walk main.
Alright, I'm walking main.
But I'll make sure he's okay first.
I'll make sure he's okay too.
And I'm gonna give...
Oh my god!
I don't think he's gonna be okay.
Is he okay?
He's okay.
Jesus Christ.
Please.
This is very stressful to keep up.
Oh my god, I got my headshots in.
Dope.
I don't know if I can get another one in.
Dude, holy shit.
Everybody is okay.
That is like very scary to walk up to.
Not gonna lie.
That's...
Okay, I slept him.
Can't be that difficult to kill these guys, right?
It was.
Whoa!
I'm fine.
I have ult here.
We didn't do anything?
I'll just stay here.
I don't know if my team is okay, but like...
Okay.
Isn't it great that...
Oh my god, this is not good.
This is not great.
I'm trying, buddy.
I am trying my best.
Alright.
Oh my god.
I'm ulting.
Break it, break it, break it, break it.
No!
Alright, I thought he would break it before.
I had so much confidence that he would.
I heard, break it.
And I was like, he's gonna break it.
There's no way.
He's gonna definitely break it.
He wouldn't fuck that up.
What?
Ruben!
Ruben, I need to sleep!
Guys.
I'm gonna freak out.
I'm gonna...
Ruben, this is...
I'm at the edge right here.
I will take the jump, Ruben.
I will take the jump.
Nice.
What?
Oh my god.
Bro, what the fuck is going on?
What?
Bro.
Wait, is Mason Overwatch there?
I love these.
Damn.
That's Ashley fucked.
You're so healthy.
There we go.
What?
That doesn't hit?
Are you serious?
Guys, type shit, type shit.
That's fine.
We're so healthy right here.
You're so healthy, let's go.
They're portaling, they're portaling, I think.
That's so healthy.
Where's the portal?
Oh, it's up top.
Okay, I was gonna say.
That's actually crazy.
How he's like, damn, you missed those?
What a crazy thing this ADC makes.
Jesus Christ.
I'm alive.
I can't get hit.
I cannot peek for this.
I would love to peek right now.
Who woke him?
I literally saw him.
Oh my god, I saw him sleep for like one second.
I saw him sleep for one second.
What happened?
What?
What did I hear?
Oh shit!
There you go.
Everything is fine.
I don't even...
Where's my DPS to damage boost?
Where are they?
Oh, that's where they are.
Alright.
That's where I die.
Welp.
Welp, are we touching?
Alright, I spawn in here then.
Alright.
Oh!
I saw him space, so I got scared.
That's fine.
We got born again.
I can't see anybody.
Alright, that's fine.
I'm a little bit scared though.
I'm very scared actually.
I'm a little scared.
I'm very scared.
Oh!
Oh, I'm alive somehow!
Nevermind.
Oh my god.
I don't...
We were not very much alive.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I was alive though.
For like one second.
For like...
One second there.
That was nice.
That was a nice feeling.
I had a great time.
It truly was.
A great time.
Being alive there for a bit.
Things will be okay, right guys?
Things will be okay, right?
Right?
I'm not stopping till eternity.
We're in for the long haul today.
Okay, I'll lock in.
I'll lock in.
Portal?
Portal, portal, portal.
Where's portal?
I'm waiting.
We're all waiting?
We're fine.
Okay, I'm fucking dropping down.
We're not fine anymore.
I'm not staying up.
Oh my god.
Like, I'm support.
What do you want me to do?
I don't want to get pushed there.
Oh my god.
I was gonna stand there.
I needed other people there with me.
What the fuck was I supposed to do?
Like, I don't mind if other people went up.
But not me.
I'm just a little guy.
Goodbye.
I used all the leaves I could.
In that scenario.
I actually tried my best.
Jesus, I don't have enough leaves.
I don't have...
I don't have enough leaves.
It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
Jesus, you all take so much damage.
All right, we got...
We gotta use this.
All right.
Go do your thing.
Guys.
We have Punisher.
We don't have tanks.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
No, he fucking bumbled it.
Oh my god.
I was ready to sleep it.
It got fucking bumbled.
Oh my god, is it actually?
Let's go.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm over here.
All right.
All right, it's fine.
Oh my god, it's not fine.
It's not fine.
This is scary as fuck right now.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
I hope it's damaged right now.
All right.
Oh.
I hear somebody.
All right.
Oh, Neymar, let's go.
All right, let's all be together.
I'm scared of that.
Is everybody okay?
I don't think everybody...
No.
I don't know about this, guys.
I don't know about this.
Well...
I'm back in GM2.
Oh my god.
I can do this.
Just a little setback.
This is just a little setback.
Fucking hell, this is just...
Just a little setback.
All right.
All right, here we go.
I'm like up, down, up, down, up, down.
I'm on an unlucky streak right now.
All right.
Up, down, up, down, up, down.
Oh my god.
All right.
The ride never ends.
Sorry, I had work messages because like...
I had to respond to some messages here.
I think the fucking craziest shit was...
Was whoever that guy...
That was like...
Whoever that guy was like, wow, Mace, you missed those?
That shit was crazy.
That was a fucking crazy comment.
In my game.
Nice way to death.
No, don't say that.
Please, don't say that.
Don't say that.
I don't do subathons.
I just stream.
I don't need to do subathons.
I make it enough to be okay without having to do a subathon.
I don't know how I still...
Oh, hey, Zac guy.
I don't know how I still have the energy.
I don't know.
Playing competitive games always makes me so hyper.
I just get like...
Adrenaline from competitive in general.
It's a rankathon.
No, 100%.
Oh, hey.
We have a Hulk there?
All right.
You guys got...
We're not banning Hulk.
What a time, boys.
Do we have a Hawkeye player?
We don't need a...
Our Iron Fist can deal with a Hawkeye player.
I mean, I assume you two just dive him so hard that...
Yeah, exactly.
We have two divers.
How many games I do rank to GM2?
So...
I literally just do rank to GM2.
You can just do rank to GM2.
Like, what are we playing, man?
Dude, we'll figure it out.
I mean, I can go...
I can go Penny.
Oh my god.
This is it.
It's gonna be a-okay, everybody.
Oh yeah, by the way, I asked this.
Who is Mace?
Is he an Overwatch player?
I know he has a partner.
I just know he's rank 1 and he was rank...
He is or was rank 1 in Marvel Rivals?
What game did he come from?
Okay.
Oh, TP.
Goodbye, my flankers.
No, not MaceTheFace.
He's not MaceTheFace.
I know MaceTheFace, boys.
Oh, hey, they have it.
Oh, he's a top 10?
Oh, that's why he's a team player.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
That's fucking right.
I can aim.
Let's go.
Yeah, beat her up.
Beat her up.
Oh, I don't...
Oh my god, he beat her up.
He actually...
Oh.
Oh, he's coming over.
Wait, we can kill Strange.
Never mind.
We cannot kill Strange.
Oh my god.
You're so healthy.
You're not healthy.
He's not.
Bro, how?
Oh my god, punch him!
Oh, he's dead.
That Hawkeye is hitting all his shots.
That's for sure.
I'm so scared.
It's so fun.
It's so okay.
Guys, it's so okay.
I just...
As long as I never let go of left click, everybody will be okay.
Am I... Is it okay?
Oh, okay.
You know what?
I believe in my Luna.
There's a Frozen Psylocke here.
That's right!
Now I'll dance!
Oh my god.
I'm fucking...
Storm's one.
Oh, I died.
I did.
Jesus Christ.
It's fine.
My existence don't matter.
The team wins anyway.
I got my...
I got my Storm kill.
I got...
Alright.
Is everything fine?
Is everything okay?
Everything will be okay, right?
I believe in our Iron Fist.
Storm's one.
Who the fuck is healing Storm?
Not anymore.
Oh my god, please.
That's fine.
This guy's low too.
I can only dance so much.
I know, right?
Who's on the point?
Oh, sorry.
Okay, our Iron Fist.
I had a double take.
I was like, who the fuck is that?
Who is he?
I was like, wait.
He's on the point?
I don't know who I froze, but like, good luck.
That's fine.
Everybody is so healthy.
Hey!
Let's go!
They're dancing!
I'm dancing too!
Let's go!
Come on, everybody!
Slay.
Oh my god, oh my god!
I forgot Hawkeye can kill through this.
I...
Oh!
They Star Vaulted!
I haven't played against a Hawkeye in so long.
And then I almost died.
I was like, I gotta get out of here.
Got it.
I forgot about that.
I had to run away.
It's been so long since I played against a Hawkeye.
He can...
For those who don't know, he can actually...
He can kill through...
Oh my god!
He can kill through any support ult.
Doesn't matter.
He can even kill you through a support ult.
Yeah, but some people don't know.
Some people think they're so super.
They think like...
They think that...
Luna and Mantis ult is invincibility.
But it's not.
So like...
I learned that the hard way.
You know, when I danced in front of a fucking Hawkeye and got headshotted.
No, he can literally headshot you through a Luna ult.
He can headshot the Luna specifically.
So I danced in front of a Hawkeye and I was like, oh!
Wow.
He did not like that.
I was like...
Because I was trying to be cocky and bodyblock his ult.
Bro, Garf beat the shit out of people.
It was crazy watching that happen.
Yeah, they ban the same people.
At least we don't have Hella.
That's great.
Do I have MVP?
Oh shit, I do.
I didn't even notice.
Alright, you know what?
Garf deserves this.
Oh shit guys, I'm Ace.
I'm not even focused at a...
Okay, I should focus up.
I should focus up.
I froze somebody and I wasn't paying attention.
I literally looked away.
Like the whole cool guys don't look at explosions.
Oh, they're dooming now.
They're running.
Oh!
Poke me like one time.
Oh my god.
Skip tech, skip tech.
It's fine.
I'll keep Mace up.
He's rigged one for a reason.
Who cares?
He's rigged one.
At least she's literally one.
Oh my god, I almost killed her.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, was I not healed?
You have no healers?
Oh my god, okay.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
Is everybody okay?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
That's fine.
She's flying away.
No.
Justice.
That's fine.
Everything is A-okay.
I froze somebody.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so healthy.
Just keep the rank one guy alive.
Surely he can 1v6 everybody.
Surely, right?
Oh my god!
That was my bad.
I looked at my chat.
I thought I was safe.
I literally looked away.
I'm locked in for real.
This is why I normally don't stream.
I stream if I rank right.
I'm never locked in.
I have a Psylocke on me.
I might be dead.
I'm gonna die in the chat.
Guys.
Okay, I can't.
I can't freaking die here.
Everything is fine.
See, everything is fine.
I'm locked in.
For real.
I literally thought I was in the safest part possible.
I was like, there's nothing that can kill me in this corner.
What could kill me?
Who knew?
It was a fucking scroll I was like, I don't have to look.
Now, how did this that went 14-4 get MVP over me?
I'm gonna shit my pants.
Oh my god.
We did it, guys.
I'm still GM too, but we did it.
We did it.
God.
As long as we keep the- Is he actually rank 1 right now?
Oh.
I mean...
Wait.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to check.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god, he is rank 1.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Sorry, I was like...
We're trying to convict- We're trying to see if we can join up, but we can't.
Sorry, guys.
Alright.
Okay, let me just keep going.
We keep going.
Alright.
Yeah, mace is second mace.
I didn't realize he was rank 1!
Oh my god, that's crazy.
I was like, whoa.
Whoa.
We keep going.
I still don't know how he got in the party.
I still don't know.
I literally didn't accept anything.
I didn't accept anything.
He doesn't have- I don't have a lot of friends list.
I don't know how he did it.
I'm gonna do it.
Please, I beg of you to vote for Hulk.
Please don't ban Sleeves.
The lack of Sleeves is hitting me.
No, I should know.
Can he join through?
Wait, I thought he can join through.
Oh, shit!
Alright, I'll ban Hulk now.
That's right.
Learn other characters.
Stop being a one-trick.
This guy's a Psylocke one-trick.
No, I'm fucking not, bro.
I listened to the rank one guy.
What do you mean?
I flexed so hard.
I flexed.
Let's get off the store.
Ruben.
Ruben, bust out the Black Panther.
Bust out the Black Panther.
Hell no.
Yeah, I'm trying Twitch for Marvel Rivals.
How long am I streaming for?
How long?
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's okay, I have gamer subs.
Guys, you guys know I have a gamer sub code?
Oh my god.
Seamless transition, by the way.
Seamless transition.
But like, if you use my code, DokiBird, you can get 10% off on your order and I get money for it.
I mean, obviously.
But only if you use my code.
Only if you use my code.
Yeah.
That's my rank now.
I'll talk about it if we win this game.
I'll tell you my rank if we win this game, guys.
That's fine.
Not the reload hands!
Oh, he is so...
Who cares about the fucking...
Who cares, Bronzy?
Oh, you're not mace.
If mace is alive, he can carry it all.
He can carry us all to the promised land.
Mace, please.
You can't die.
As long as you're alive.
Oh, and me too.
Because I need to be...
Because I need to be alive to make sure he's alive.
Oh god.
Clap.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, mace!
I will ult to save your life!
But you're okay.
You're okay.
He's so okay.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Um...
He has strange ult, so I'm backing off.
He has strange ult.
This is worth.
I believe in our magneto.
Oh.
Mace is alive though.
Oh, mace is so healthy.
Okay, I gotta heal.
I'm gonna heal other people now.
I'm actually gonna focus up here.
I'm saving Mace's ult accounts KDA.
That's all that matters.
His ult accounts KDA is doing great.
Oh my
god.
There we go.
Mace, your KDA is fine.
Your KDA will be so healthy.
Okay.
I'm not gonna use my ult.
There we go.
Look at that.
Zero deaths, as it should be.
Zero...
Oh my...
Okay.
Alright, everybody.
This is last fight, guys.
Oh shit!
This is a great one.
This is actually really good.
Oh, Magni on point.
Yay!
Don't let the rank 1 die!
Don't let him die.
Please, I swear to god, I'm doing everything I can to keep him alive.
Oh my god, he's alive.
As it should be.
Goodbye.
Jesus Christ.
I was gonna say, how did our Mantis live through all that?
But he didn't.
He actually didn't.
Okay.
He's got this.
I believe.
Yippee!
I should let the Magneto die.
Oh nice.
Okay, I thought that was...
Only one person can have zero deaths.
And it has to be the rank 1 guy.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
Yes.
Oh my god.
Poor guy.
If I could let the Magneto die right now.
Okay!
It was not it.
I swear to god.
It was not intentional.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
As it should be.
Only one person can have zero deaths.
Die!
No, you're not dying.
You're not dying.
You're not dying!
Oh shit.
Oh!
I didn't want to die!
I didn't want to ult!
I wasn't gonna ult from EDA.
I didn't care.
I cared.
But also I...
I fucking cared so much.
I cared.
I cared so much.
No!
There we go.
That's what we wanna hear.
Did she dodge that?
Oh, when I try to dodge it, I fucking die.
Like, when that happens to me, I just fucking collapse.
Don't worry, rank one!
That's looking right.
A rank one should never die.
You... Okay, I guess that's it.
No, thanks.
I can't believe this Mantis wouldn't like, keep me alive with his ult.
Like, I should be important enough to have a Mantis ult.
Honestly.
I'm a street... Oh.
I don't... My god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I will ult this.
I will...
Like,
there's no reason for me to ult yet.
Oh, no.
I wanted to keep him up.
That's fine.
That's...
Oh, hey.
Nice.
She got the ult.
It took me 20 years to get...
It took me 20 years to decide to ult.
Oh, that would've hit.
That would've 100% hit.
Okay, whoops.
I'll just shit my pants, I guess.
Oh my god, please.
It's the final 10 seconds.
I don't know if I can...
Oh, please bug out right now.
Please bug out right now and have it all be damaged.
Please.
Oh my god, wrong person.
I wanted to freeze him.
No.
Miss, no.
Just don't touch the cart.
Keep your KDA up.
Miss.
No, miss.
No, I worked so hard.
I ran and you just not even touched the cart.
I can TP back.
I worked so hard to give him 0 deaths.
After he touched the cart and gave his life away.
How could you let me die?
My one death.
The blood is on your hands.
Why did you touch the cart?
If he didn't touch the cart, he could have lived.
He could have fucking lived.
I can't believe it.
One death washed.
Can't believe it, Miss.
One death already washed.
Feels bad.
Okay, why?
Why did he touch the cart?
He could have lived.
He could have just watched it from afar and kept it clean.
How could he do this to me?
I worked so hard to keep it spotless 0.
I even sacrificed my own KDA for it.
Oh no, 100% addicted.
No.
That's why I'm still here.
It's like 6 in the morning.
I'm about to fucking walk my dog and feed.
I'll still be streaming.
Alright, where is he?
This horde will never leave you.
My team?
We don't have a team.
We just have Mace.
Mace took 0 damage.
Okay, he's taking damage.
But I clap.
I clap now.
It's okay.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I'm just...
I'm never letting go.
Left click, I guess.
Oh my god, there's 3 people to our right.
That's a lot of people.
Look at that.
He's so healthy.
My teammates, my mantis can deal with my teammates.
No!
That wasn't my fault.
Guys, that was definitely not my fault.
Oh my god, they have a...
No, I have to put on a goddamn...
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, what?
What?
Okay, I need to see this.
I couldn't even Q.
They must have 3, 2, 1.
There's no way they did...
Yay!
I'm here now.
This is gonna be...
Yay!
Oh my god, where's me?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I got...
How did I...
Oh my god!
That was the sickest freeze of... Okay, that was...
I've been having a lot of sick freezes, not gonna lie.
My freezes have been pretty fucking sick.
I tell you, Luna freezes are so easy.
Really, like...
I literally just look at them and they're frozen.
It's easier than Ana sleep dart.
I used to do Ana sleep darts a lot for practice when I used to scrim.
Oh my god!
No, there's a fucking Magneto on the right!
Fuck!
I was like, what hit me?
Holy shit!
Oh my god, I got like fucking punched in the right.
Like, that was crazy.
I was like, what punched me?
Not the moon.
The moon.
I would not have saved these people.
Honestly.
It's just us two.
Unless we do like the sickest...
Okay.
I think we're doing the sickest play of our lives right now.
Oh my god.
Mace, please.
I'm so fucking scared for you, Mace.
Mace, no!
No!
Magneto, Magneto!
Oh my god.
We did it!
Yeah!
Oh shit, Mantis!
I was like, where did he come from?
Jump scare.
She just walked up.
Wow.
I don't know, maybe somebody's washed right now.
It's like that office meet where like, Angela...
That's it.
Hey guys, I'm GM1.
For those who are wondering what rank I am.
Oh my god.
Confirm not one trick.
Oh my god, we did it.
We fucking got back to GM1.
Back to GM1, we're so back.
I can't believe it, how could a rank 1 die three times?
We're so back.
Not gonna lie, 40k of that definitely went to Mace.
I did not care about anybody else.
I used other people so I could heal Mace because he was too far away.
Oh my god.
It would've been two deaths if he didn't fucking touch the cart.
He didn't need to touch the fucking cart.
It was over.
We all knew it was fucking over.
Oh no, I was gonna be like, I'll start stream when I'm back to GM1 because I lost GM1 in the morning.
Yesterday night morning.
And then like...
And then I started stream when we were back in GM1 and now we're back in GM1 again.
We've been very unlucky.
Unlucky?
Okay, let me show you guys.
We've been a little unlucky.
We would have like solid wins and then like, you know.
Yes.
Ruben, if you deserve eternity, then you can flex.
It's real.
If you're an eternity player and you can't fucking flex, we're gonna ban your one trick until you learn.
Until you learn to flex.
Exactly.
You don't wanna be a one trick that gets the pick ban every time.
Oh shit!
Which hero do you think you wanna be today?
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon, I shine in darkness.
If you get outtanked by a hard stick, I'm going to laugh.
It looks like our guy wants to play.
Okay.
That's awkward.
That's actually awkward.
Alright, then we ban Hawkeye.
Alright.
Oh wait, yeah.
If I don't ban Luna, I'll be Mantis Loki, that's fine.
Oh!
That works out.
For all of us.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll see if Mace is gonna get attacked by hard stick.
How the fuck do you play a hero Hawkeye in this elo?
How?
How were you able to play Hawkeye at all?
That's actually crazy.
I still don't have a hero on my other supports.
I only have it on Luna.
I'm so happy.
Guys, this is my GM game.
Can we please lock in?
Can we please go goats?
Oh my god.
Wait, did he say this is his GM game?
Alright,
here we go.
For all the people who are new here, my name is DokiBear and I stream on the YouTubes.
I'm doing my rank right here.
Cause I'm fucking crazy.
I've been on for a while.
I love my Roavers.
I will play this game for the rest of my life.
Until a new hero shooter comes out and then I'm gonna dedicate my life to that too.
Alright Mace, I believe in your damage boost.
I'm scared cause I know Mendo's a crazy Hawkeye.
Oh goodbye.
That's funny though.
That's pretty funny.
I know he's a crazy Hanzo player.
That's a Hanzo player.
That's what I was like.
Oh my god.
I'm almost back.
I'm gonna grab this so I can grab this.
Oh my god.
He lost to it.
The Hawkeye can still kill me though.
So that's... I'm scared about that.
I'm scared about the...
I'm scared about that though.
No way.
That's fine.
We're so... wait there's a...
Is that our portal?
Oh that's our portal.
Nice.
That's our portal.
Thank god.
Imagine having a death.
Mendo cut.
You know what?
I'm glad that we didn't ban the Hawkeye.
Oh shit.
I thought I walked off.
Catch.
I did.
Like, is this cover or is this death?
Thank god.
All me good players have 0 deaths.
Whoa.
You're trying to make football references to an Overwatch pro.
Damn.
He has a life outside of Overwatch?
That's crazy.
And Marvel Rivals now?
Oh my god, I am Stroud now.
I fucking did it.
Guys, I told you.
I told you I ended up adopting players just like Stroud.
I did it.
I don't need millions of dollars.
I just need a stream Marvel Rivals and they'll come.
We fucking did it.
And we adopted a rank 1 player.
We did the impossible.
Oh my god, I'm fucking too calm.
I'm not locked in anymore.
I'm not locked in.
Don't never peek that.
Oh, he never misses.
Nah, he misses.
Is my ult on?
My ult is on.
That's good.
Jesus Christ.
Stop.
Oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's cool.
Sleep!
It didn't hit.
It's the thought that counts, you know?
Damage.
Jeez.
Alright.
Nice.
What's over there?
Oh.
Thank you.
We just cap point?!
I already have another.
I have another ult.
Alright.
Damage boost.
Everything's fine.
Portal?
Where could it go?
Oh.
Where is it?
Goodbye.
Oh,
Strange is solo.
I'm solo.
No, you're not.
Thank you, Doki.
Oh.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
I sacrificed myself.
Oh, that was insane!
I got shielded.
I got slept.
How did they see me?
Okay, I have ult.
I have ult now.
It's fine.
It's okay.
Oh my god, my cover.
He'll be fine.
I can get one shot though.
Oh my god, I'm on my cover again.
I shot my own cover.
Third person is so fucking wonky sometimes when it comes to like...
Because when you're too close to something, it like...
Oh my god, he never missed, guys.
If you shoot it too close, it doesn't like count.
Did I get it off?
Yes, we're all so close to each other.
We're all so close, but we're dead.
Oh my god, I didn't have my sleep because I was too busy trying to keep other people alive.
Oh no, he's one!
We can do it.
I believe they just had a...
We have another... Oh.
Oh no.
I'm just gonna stay here until it's too late, which is now.
Don't worry, he's sleeping.
I'm worried a little bit.
What is that sound?
I can't... It's like...
Nice.
We're so fine.
I can stay up here.
Come on!
Yes!
Nobody knew I was here.
I got to chill down up here.
Yippee!
I got to get back up there.
That was so nice.
I actually just chilled.
Portal, portal, portal, portal.
Oh no, not again.
Not again.
Back, back, back.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my god, not again.
Oh!
That's fine.
Nice.
Oh my god, you bitch.
You bitch.
Magneto, nice.
There's a Magneto.
Yay!
I...
Fuck that Mantis, actually.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we're getting closer.
We're actually...
Getting closer.
Actually, no.
I've been like...
Just to slowly kill what I'm next to.
What?
That's rough.
That's the punisher you made me in front of.
It's karma.
That's rough.
That's pretty rough.
Oh wait, it's the remedy yet.
Oh my gosh, my fucking knuckles popped there.
Guys, please.
I can't.
We're so close.
We're not, but I like to be hopeful for a little bit.
Oh, it's him.
Please don't ban Psylocke.
I'm the really good Psylocke player.
Ban Hulk.
Please don't do it.
Hulk ban.
I'm the Psylocke player.
We're banning you.
Psylocke, please.
Please, I beg of you.
Make it not a 50-50.
Thank you.
I got you.
It didn't matter.
At least it wasn't my team.
It didn't matter anyway.
It didn't fucking matter.
It didn't matter.
Punisher.
Winter Soldier.
Ban Punisher.
Come on, 25%.
Come on, 20%.
Punisher.
Hulk.
Yo, there's no fucking way.
My strongest fucking mace to the face.
This is fine.
I can play other characters, man.
Do we even have...
Is this even a Hawkeye map?
You depend on...
When you depend on randoms for heals.
It's gg's.
I can play Strange.
I'm the Strange God.
Dude, that hero is actually so fucking easy.
It's gg's.
The raid boss?
Oh shit, yeah.
You'll never die.
Heroes never die.
Is Mace that well known?
I mean, he is rank 1.
I guess that's why he's so well known.
The glaze goes crazy.
I'm just like...
I was so oblivious.
To all of this.
I just was like...
Another person to play with me.
I'm so happy.
That's really it.
I just like simple things.
And then the other person was literally the rank 1.
You'll never die.
Okay, you'll maybe die like once or twice.
I'm not here to give you...
Oh my god.
Already...
Wait, what is being thrown at us?
Right now.
Oh, it's the fucking Iron Man.
I was like so confused.
Okay, the...
The strange can die.
Oh damn.
Oh shit.
Oh, he's playing deep.
Wow.
Please.
Any picks.
Any at all.
It'll be so cool.
Any...
Yes, a pick.
Oh my god.
He's like deep in there.
How did he get there?
How did you get there?
I don't even know how he got there.
Alright, this is where I...
No max for you.
No, no, no!
No!
Where do I go?
I should've...
I'm frozen!
Oh my god.
That's fine.
Every time...
Don't worry, Mace.
You're not dying on me this time.
But if you die, I guess you're just bad, I guess.
I don't know.
We all get one, though.
I could let him die right here, right now.
I could throw right now.
It's so tempting.
Literally, I could literally do it right here.
Did she kill anybody?
Oh, she did.
I don't know who I froze, but like...
He's frozen.
Oh, Mace.
I'm jumping.
I'm jumping as far as I can.
That's fine.
I can't see anything, but that's okay.
I...
Where am I?
Okay, I'm gonna break the windows.
There we go.
See?
Everything's fine.
Okay, I just need to not heal Scarlet Witch.
And then he'll be the only one with zero deaths.
Oh, that didn't hit?
Goddammit.
I thought that would hit.
This is...
Is this what it's like to have a good tank?
Oh my god.
Am I doing this wrong?
Do I just play with tank players?
Like, is DPS out and tank is in?
Is that it?
I think that's it.
The key is to just play with a tank player.
Okay.
I can't save that.
It looks like it.
Oh!
Please!
I'm jumping!
Jumping actually makes me go slower, but I'm desperate.
I'm so scared.
We did it.
She's dead.
Now Miss is the only zero deaths as it should be.
Oh!
It was a Namor.
No!
Oh my god.
He got killed by a Hawkeye, of course.
Of course.
It's always a Hawkeye.
Okay, Scarlet, you can go whenever.
What?
Oh shit!
Holy shogun!
That's overboard.
That's actually overboard.
Okay.
That's a hate crime there.
It is not.
The worst part is it only got one person.
Like, it was actually useless.
It looked cool.
It looked really cool.
But they literally only got one guy.
No, please.
I'm so not healthy.
Bro, guys.
All that for one guy.
That's so sad.
That poor guy.
That poor fucking guy.
Oh!
Yay!
Wait, did he say Wavy's gonna get eternity?
The Wavy guy just said...
Did he just say it's his eternity game?
Oh no.
That means I'm gonna avoid that guy.
Maybe he'll lose the next game.
He's my competition.
Oh my god.
That's right.
You'll never die.
This is it.
Guys, I can't believe it actually happened.
Maybe I'll bump into somebody who will get the snowflake and then he'll never die.
This is it.
I get to live the dream.
I get to be shrouded for a day.
I just need one more.
One more for the dream four stack and then I'll never fall.
And then maybe I'll even get eternity like 100 RP.
I just need one more.
I need to dock one more guy into this.
One more player.
Just gotta dock one more player.
Then it will be the dream.
No, Mendo got a third stack.
A three stack already.
He already replaced Mace but Mace is irreplaceable.
That's okay.
I've been losing it since six hours ago.
Before I even started the stream I've been playing.
Mack gave up.
Albert Lele.
I was doing with Albert Lele and he like he like gave up.
He was like I can't.
I'm tired.
He isn't in it for the actual.
I'm a fucking grinder.
See?
He gave up the grind.
He's not dedicated like me.
You never give up.
I think also support is like less taxing on you mentally.
Oh no, actually no.
It's less like mentally draining versus like the other roles.
Because all I do is like he he left click and then maybe occasionally right click like this.
Oh god.
Mace.
Mace, you're so healthy.
You're so healthy.
Oh my god.
What?
Yeah, we don't care about that guy.
Oh my god.
I'm merry-go-round that.
I'm merry.
I did a little merry-go-round.
How did I live?
I don't know.
Jesus.
What?
Okay, how?
Okay.
God damn.
Oh my god.
I didn't live.
Oh no.
Wait, is he dead?
Where's Mace?
That's fine.
Oh, if I heal you don't know exactly where you are.
Guys.
Okay, two deaths.
This is gonna be the only two deaths he gets.
Oh my god.
He is testing me right now.
He is.
He is absolutely testing me.
Please.
I don't know if I can keep that promise anymore.
Nice.
Like, I just see him fucking, he's still peeking and I'm like, I don't know.
Oh my god, look back.
If I look back and he died, I swear to god.
I'm gonna die to that Iron Man.
Oh, I can feel it.
I can feel it already.
He's gonna be like, max.
Oh my god.
No, he blocks me out.
I got locked out.
This is fucked up.
Oh no.
My life for his.
Was it even worth it?
I gave up my life for him.
He gave up his life for me.
I chose me.
Oh my god.
He exploded.
I can heal her.
She's like, in that little ghost form.
Wait, I can kill him.
Nevermind, he's getting healed.
That's fine.
Build that fucking circle.
Oh.
I dance, I dance.
Alright.
Yay!
Let's go.
Let's get even closer.
You know what?
Oh wait, they have a Hoth.
Wait, they don't.
Let's get up close and personal and then I leave.
And then I leave.
Oh no, that's not Mace, that's fine.
He can die if he wants to.
Oh, he lives.
He almost just made me to death.
I can't believe I looked away.
I looked away.
I was like, that's fine, he can die.
I don't care.
And I was like, wait, I'm a healer.
Oh my god, he might be goat.
Can I run around this?
No, I can't.
That's just me.
That was worrisome.
Right there.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
That's gonna not hit anybody.
This is okay.
This is so fine.
He can just do that.
Like, with no consequences at all.
Just walk up to them and be okay.
That was my bad.
That was actually...
I think I caused that.
That was my bad.
I shouldn't have said anything.
Whoops.
Oh my god.
He can do that with no consequences.
Consequences happens.
There was...
There was consequences.
We saved.
Saved.
That's fine.
We did it.
Guys, no.
I don't know if I can believe yet.
I don't know, man.
I don't know.
10 death Ruben?
Damn.
Damn Ruben.
10 deaths?
Damn.
That's rough.
I'm making hella space.
I don't know, guys.
Kinda rough.
Kinda rough for him.
Anything can happen for me.
I've been, like, in this hellhole of a rank.
Anything can happen.
I've gotten stream sniped so many times.
That's why I mostly play off stream.
But today I feel brave.
Like, who wants to stream snipe me?
Unless they want to fire me, I guess.
I got stream sniped because people wanted to fire me.
I'm like, please.
No, like...
My friend was like, you should put a delay.
But I'm like...
I don't want to put a delay because I like talking to chat.
Yeah, we will just win.
It's like...
Oh my god, no, it's crazy.
And now I play with so many guitar bands.
Yeah, who would stream snipe Mace?
Exactly.
Mace would just, like...
Mace would, like, take your ELO in his actual main account.
He would make a hit list.
Well, now I didn't rank.
That's why I haven't stream ranked in so long.
Oh, there is a hit list?
Oh shit, am I on the hit list?
Oh my god, am I on a hit list?
Please don't ban Psylocke.
That's my character.
This guy is just being stupid.
You're not going to listen to me.
Where do I ban Strange?
Don't.
I didn't think it would happen.
That was 20%!
I don't fucking know.
I didn't learn.
I'm not a two trick.
I'm not a two trick, okay?
I can learn.
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
I didn't know.
How was I supposed to know it was 20%?
I just wanted to go gambling.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry, babe.
Okay, what is this comp?
Let's go gambling.
There's enough things to run ghosts?
We have three in support.
Oh my god.
As long as you're alive, that's all that matters.
Help our guy.
Our Mantis guy.
We kept America solo.
Yeah, I just got to do everything apparently.
Oh yeah, who's keeping you alive right now?
Who's keeping you alive?
Hey,
you got Groot, right?
I am Groot.
Groot, Groot, Groot.
Okay, how am I supposed to kill anyone with this fucking old man?
I am Groot.
Ah, yeah.
This is so strange, I'm so confused.
I am Groot.
Why would anybody do that?
I just want to get a Pokemon.
I am Groot, I am Groot, I am Groot.
You got America to her right on her lowkey.
Ah, yeah.
Is Groot fun to play?
Uh, I am Groot.
There we go.
You've done something as crazy as that.
That's like crazy.
We're literally at their spot.
We're at their fucking spot.
This guy is just a goat.
I am Groot.
Why is it me not in the right map?
Anybody that's playing Marvel Rivals at 7 in the morning, nobody is okay right now.
Good boy.
Are you okay?
Yay!
I am Groot.
Look at these off meta picks, they're so brave.
No.
No, I am so okay.
Wait, is this your eternity game?
No, next game is.
Okay, Mace, can you avoid him?
I am Groot.
Blowing the cover.
Please stop.
I would never.
I would never do something that fucked up, guys.
Like batting stream.
That's something I would never do.
Jesus Christ.
My God.
What was that?
What the fuck was that?
Careful, he has the list.
True.
Oh no, I'm gonna get on the list.
I'm gonna get on the fucking list.
Yes.
There's no way he would never do such a thing.
Oh my God.
Please, no.
Wait, I died?
Okay, no, I don't want to be on the list.
Don't put me on the list.
I swear I won't do that again.
I swear.
Okay, him not dying should exempt me from getting on the list.
Guys, I'm gonna say that.
I'm gonna say him not dying.
Him not dying.
He's still not dead.
Go, go.
Jump off, jump off.
Oh my God.
What?
Do it.
Jump.
Do a flip.
Guys, please.
I don't want to be on the list, guys.
Please, I worked so hard to be here.
I adopted so many players, guys.
I figured it out.
Alright.
That's fine.
We're so okay.
I don't know why I tried to beat up our own tree.
Wait, where did he go?
There he is.
If he never dies, we win.
We don't care.
Oh wait, he lives too.
Don't worry!
You live!
Who cares about everybody else?
Okay, nice.
Yay!
We did it.
0-0-9 is crazy.
He's Groot.
He is Groot.
Oh my God, look.
See?
Look, zero deaths.
Look at that.
I'm so not forgiving.
Oh my God, what's 0-0-9?
Is it this?
Oh, 0-9.
That's crazy.
I've been marked.
No, guys, don't say that.
I don't want to be on the list, guys.
Don't say that.
No, please.
Please.
Just a humble support player.
What did I do to deserve it?
What did I even do?
I don't understand.
What could I have done to deserve it?
Oh yeah, should I do it?
What if I just avoided the wavy guy?
Right now.
Oh, he's not even...
Oh, I didn't even have to avoid him.
Oh my God.
I didn't even...
I swear, I didn't even avoid him.
It was just RNG.
I swear to God.
It's over.
What do you mean, how could I do that?
I didn't do anything.
It happened.
Also, pasta.
Thank you for the tier one.
Thank you for the prime.
Thank you.
Wait, ban Doctor Strange?
Oh, now you want to ban...
Oh, now you want to ban Doctor Strange.
Do we ban Hela?
Don't watch them ban Hela.
They can ban Hela, watch.
Alright.
Then I'm banning Bruce Batty.
Let's flip.
Oh!
That's good.
That's good RNG.
Guys, I didn't...
I didn't do it.
Someone else in my team did it.
And I think it's definitely not me.
I definitely... I did not.
I let him try...
I thought he was going to be on my team.
He could have Q dodged.
He...
He tried to 50-50 it.
That's his own fault.
If he really...
He tried going gambling and it failed for him.
Guys, you've only met this guy for two games.
He didn't talk until the second game.
And he said three words.
His first word was, I'm playing Pokemon TCG.
His second was like, Guys, it's my eternity.
My turn game is next game.
I feel like I've known him...
I've been here for seven hours!
And you've known him for the rest of your life?
I would die for Wavy.
That's all I need to know.
That he's...
That this is his eternity game.
And that you...
He plays Pokemon TCG.
He's like a brother for you.
He's just a little guy.
Really.
Psylocke...
The standard Psylocke and strange.
Okay.
Who else?
That's four already.
That's what standard means.
Wait, you're not mace.
Here we go.
Okay.
I don't got enough walls for that.
I don't have enough walls for you.
I love this fucking shotgun, bro.
It's so dumb.
I love how he's like, I don't have enough walls, what the fuck you want me to do?
I'm breaking the walls.
Is Psylocke meta?
Yes.
Psylocke is so strong.
Psylocke is basically Genji in Overwatch.
It's a Star Lord too, right?
I'm so happy Luna's not banned.
Fucking easiest support of my life.
Never...
No, Mercy existed, nevermind.
I see.
There's no easier character.
And now it's like, oh wait, Mercy's a character.
There's a Star Lord behind us still.
He's low, he's low.
He's one.
Yeah,
Mercy is so easy.
Oh no, I might anger a lot of people for saying that.
Compared to other support characters, Mercy is pretty easy.
I don't want to anger people for saying that.
Legend.
Oh, time to keep dancing.
Okay, they're in the straight line, so I can do this.
This is the only time I use that.
Oh my god.
I froze somebody.
Oh, that's fine.
I am Groot.
That one hurts.
I'm doing this my way.
Just chillin' there.
Oh, okay.
Oh, shit!
Oh, nice!
That's the rank one!
I know that guy!
I met him today!
There's a Star Lord above us.
Yeah, it's called AppHP behind us.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's so nice not getting pushed by anything.
I literally just exist.
So that's why I'm not climbing.
I just haven't played with a tank player before.
And also, he's rank one.
Yeah.
Yeah, I adopted him today.
I don't know.
I don't know if it's because he's a tank player or he's rank.
It's one or the other.
Yeah, that's a big part.
That's also a big part to it.
It's totally a tank thing, right?
Yeah, it's a tank thing.
Guys, it works with any other tank player.
Adopt a tank player today.
I'm dead.
I'm so- That shit went backwards.
I thought I could get out of the edge there.
Please, please.
Don't push up.
You only have Adam heals.
Yeah, he's rank one because he's a tank.
True.
Guys, this is my PSA to adopt a tank player today.
I know that it's a one-hit kill.
Alright, I can stand still.
I'm getting lazy now.
Oh, nice.
Yo, fuck that one person in particular.
Yeah.
Every tank guy is one.
If you're a healer, always find a good tank.
Guys, don't adopt a DPS player.
Adopt a tank player.
Get ready.
You're not being lazy.
You're being efficient.
Rest in peace, ladies.
This is my PSA that like, throw your DPS players to the pound.
Adopt a tank player right now.
Tribal, Bean, thank you for the tier one sub and the prime sub.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the prime sub.
Thank you.
No, don't send it back!
No comment.
There were just way too many.
The Black Panther pick was the last straw.
I wanna be up here.
I wanna play up here.
It was just one too many Black Panthers.
It only takes one bad day.
It really only takes one bad day.
He was weak.
I was willing to go.
I was willing to go all the way till eternity.
He gave up when we were...
He could've been part of this.
He really could've been.
This could've been.
This could've been his time.
Bro, I hear Namor's fucking wet feet.
Oh, Wavy's low.
Oh, Punisher's low?
What the fuck?
Dude, I was so confused as to who the fuck Wavy was this entire time, man.
That's fine.
Oh, thank god that Groot was taking damage.
Bottom left.
Thank god.
Guys, I intentionally dropped down.
Guys.
I intentionally dropped down, guys.
Because I wanted to heal them.
It was all in.
What?
Already?
There's a Namor up.
There's Namor top right.
No.
Don't make me ult.
I will ult.
Jesus Christ, he's still alive.
I am Groot.
Everybody's okay.
He's Groot.
I won't be up here.
I won't feel tall.
You're fine.
I'm gonna find out how much damage the map does.
I don't need help.
You know what?
Look at him.
Look at him go.
He's so healthy.
I'm gonna drop down.
I saw four people went up top.
I did not feel okay with that.
There's like two.
There's like people over at the bot.
Hey, if you guys wanna fight on point, I'm right here.
Doki, I need healing up here.
Not you.
Luna's one.
I hope we lose the point because of that.
Dude, I'm just sitting here.
I've shot like three people this round.
Go to front line.
Front line and don't be a pussy.
Why are you playing positioning?
The tanks are doing all the hard work and you're just standing on high ground?
Yep, I'm standing on high ground.
What?
There's a widow on main.
Do I just not deserve healing because I'm standing on the high ground?
Yeah, get off the high ground and then you get healed.
Okay.
I hope he gets rocked.
That's really tragic, WayV.
Why, WayV?
Why?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Wait, is that my Eternity game?
Oh my god, I took his Eternity game and gave it to me.
Is that...
No, it was not.
It was not.
He lied.
Oh my god.
I was like, no way.
I got baited so hard.
I was like, there's no way this is my Eternity.
There's no way I played this and it's my Eternity.
Oh my god.
After everything we've been through, that's the game we get it from.
Holy fuck.
I wouldn't be sad, but like, what a game for it to be my Eternity game.
Will she get 24 points?
Do I need 24 points?
No, I need...
No, I need 20 points.
I'm pretty sure.
Alright, let's see.
Until...
We'll figure it out from there.
I need 16?
Okay, I just need one win.
That's all it takes.
Just one win.
Oh, my sense is 1.89, but that's my Apex sense.
And I just converted it from that.
So that's really it.
Thank you for the tier 1 sub.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
Just one more.
Here we go.
Here we fucking go.
Oh yeah, I'm fucking looking at my phone.
I don't know if anybody's learning from me.
I'm literally like, so chill right now.
To be fair.
I think like, in competitive, the more you play, the more you just climb in general.
Like, if you just keep playing.
I literally like, I literally just kept playing and playing and playing until like, I got here.
I got here.
Wait, you learned how to play Luna from me?
I don't know.
I don't know if what I'm doing is correct.
I literally just aim.
To be fair.
It's literally just like, as long as you hit your freeze on dive characters, you should be fine.
You should be like, you should be a good Luna.
As long as you hit your freeze.
And that's really it.
You just gotta make sure you hit your freezes on ults.
And like, have good have good like, game sense.
And like, I just try to make sure I communicate with my Mantis player and be like, you ult first and stuff.
I understand the Rocket 1 tricks now.
The movement is so fun.
But as long as you're not in GM, you're not throwing anyone's games.
So, I think like, GM and like, under GM is just a wild wild west.
Like, you can literally play anything.
And it'll work because as long as you're good, you can play anything.
And then when you're in GM and up, I think GM is actually so easy to get into.
Like, a lot of people are GM now.
Cause I think GM in general is really easy to get to as a rank.
It's only It's hard to get past GM 3 where it's hard.
Cause I was hardstuck GM 3 for like, I think like 3 to 4 days and I was playing every day and I was going fucking insane.
But I'm still going insane because now I'm like hardstuck GM 1 for the longest fucking time.
And And...
Yeah, GM3 is like easy to get to and that's when Elo Hell actually starts, I think.
Loki's the best support.
I feel like opinions change a lot because like everyone was like, oh Adam's terrible, but now people know how to play Adam and like people are like, oh, he's not that bad.
He's actually a really meta pick.
And at first everyone was like, oh, Rocket is so good.
Like people would just pick Rocket with Luna or Mantis and now everyone was like, what the fuck are you doing on Rocket?
Everyone's like, the team up!
The team up, guys!
The team up!
But then like everyone learned that like, oh wait, Adam's better for the soulbond and you play really well.
Yeah, and everybody hated Wolverine and Hulk, but now everyone bans Hulk and Hulk now.
So people thought Adam was terrible at first because of his lack of heals and his mercy.
His mercy res wasn't like super ideal.
Because it's like super, what's the word?
Like it's not, people didn't really know how to play.
People didn't know that like the, you just have to walk to the range of death.
You can put your res anywhere.
You can put your Adam res anywhere.
Adam res is not determined by the distance of whoever dies.
It's where you are.
So you put your res down and you literally walk closer to the dead bodies and they'll be taken to the res.
So like a lot of people didn't know that.
So there's like a lot of little things that people are just figuring out every day.
Yeah, the Adam's radius.
Yes, people like put the res in the front of the fucking, they'll be like, the res has to be close!
To be fair, the descriptions are freaking terrible.
The res has to be close to everybody.
But you can literally put the res in your own spawn if you want.
Like if you really want to troll your team, you can put your res next to your spawner and just walk over.
Yeah, it's based on Adam's current position.
Yeah, people just don't know how to play anymore.
I learned about his soul bond like yesterday.
Because I don't play Adam.
And like I was forced to try learn Adam because like Luna and Mantis kept being banned.
And then like so though Luna was getting banned a lot.
So then but then we would I would have another player that would play Mantis.
So obviously I had to play Adam because Mantis Adam was like really really good.
And then so like...
So like Um, I was in like an eternity game too.
I think I was like the only GM player.
And uh, or like no.
It was like me and Mac that were GM players in this eternity lobby.
And then one of the supports yelled at me because I was they're like stop wasting your soul bond.
And I was like, I'm sorry.
I don't I don't play Adam.
They're like, oh my god, you gotta use your soul bond when...
Um when we're all super low or like we're getting ulted and everything.
And I was just like, but then I learned and now I'm a better Adam player because of it.
It's tough fucking love, but I'm a better Adam player now.
I was like, I'm sorry.
I usually don't have to play Adam.
But now I forced myself to learn Adam, so I'm okay now.
How do you keep a positive attitude when you're on a... oh guys, I don't know.
I was freaking out like five hours ago.
I don't fucking know.
I was fucking freaking out like five hours ago.
I believe they're going to have a Namor.
It's less of a positive attitude and more of like I'm fucking going insane.
Dude, if I laugh the pain away, maybe I'll feel... maybe I'll feel something.
Why are we just bad mantis?
Okay, they got Hella.
What do we get?
Namor?
Oh nice.
That's fucking crazy.
Triple DPS is fine.
Or triple support is fine, sorry.
That's fine.
We can do this.
Who's carrying me?
Mace.
And Ruben's here too.
I'm joking.
I'm doing Ruben and Mace.
We have to admit, we have like a 90% win rate with Mace right now.
So ungrateful.
I said I was joking.
I put slash JK.
This should be fine.
Slash JK.
I freaked out on Ruben a lot today.
I was like, Ruben, I swear to fucking God.
I'm glad that things turned around.
Wait, Doki, is this your eternity game?
Don't, don't, no.
Shh.
Don't say it's my eternity game!
Because people would be like, oh it's time, you're gonna, it's time to pay people off now.
They're gonna pay people off.
I don't trust.
I don't trust people anymore.
People are fucked up.
Wait, I need, I need help.
I'm gonna try to flank the Punisher here.
I'll go for the Punisher.
Don't worry!
You'll never die!
Wait, you're walled, you're walled.
There's like, yeah, there's a hell of a skill.
Or Scarlet.
There's a Groot and a Scarlet up there.
I'll go, actually, I'll go after them.
Yeah, I'm gonna go after them.
Oh my God.
This is scary.
This is very scary.
That's fine, we have their high ground now!
What are they gonna do about it?
Kill our only tank?
That would be great.
Oh my God.
Why did I wake him right after?
Why?
Nobody knew I woke him right after.
Except the Loki knows we need him to die so we can...
Nobody knows except for...
Oh, I almost had my ult.
Give it up for ours.
We should be fine behind this.
Oh, he's not fine.
Oh, that's good!
I told you, no witnesses.
No.
You're not dying on me, Mace.
We might lose this game because I did that.
Yes, yes.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh my God.
Nobody's dying.
It's fine.
Nice.
There's a Scarlet Turret.
Look at that.
It's not a throw.
But he doesn't know.
It's okay.
The witness is dead.
He'll never know what I did.
It was such a good freeze.
I was like, what if he's not frozen though?
Like, what if I just wake him up right after?
Wouldn't that be fucking crazy if I just did that?
It's a crazy-ass freeze.
I need heals.
Thank you.
Oh, he's so sick.
Fuck you, Discord kitten.
Wait, there's a Scarlet Turret.
Top.
Alright, everything's fine.
Point blank.
I was just like, there she is!
I'll ult, but don't peek it.
Oh my God, he's fucking crazy.
Goodbye.
Oh, bye.
I lived.
I died.
I actually lived.
Oh, there's a group behind.
Goodbye.
No!
It's okay, they used so many things, but we also used so many things too.
They should have Scarlet ult.
That should be the only ult they have, right?
There we go.
What?!
There it is.
Oh my God!
You're walled off, but you're fine.
Jesus, there's a Groot behind us?
Bro, he's so locked in.
Mace isn't even fucking talking anymore.
He's so fucking locked in.
He's like, get me out of here.
Get me out of here.
There's a Groot.
I froze him.
Alright.
He's so locked in.
Jesus Christ, you're walled off.
How do you...
Oh, perfect.
We're like, even right now.
We should have Adam ult though.
There's a Groot above us.
They have Groot ult.
I'm just gonna kite that out of the way.
Oh shit.
We're even?
I'm not looking!
We'll get Mantis ult first.
I'll do second.
Okay, Mantis is dead, but we're okay.
Look, there's Magneto.
Oh my god.
Magneto, Groot.
Oh, perfect.
I'll ult after this.
I'm getting away from the point now.
I froze somebody.
Oh, that's behind.
Groot's half.
Groot's low.
Groot's one.
Punisher, low.
Jesus Christ.
Where's the bridge?
Okay.
I'm on point.
I'm pushing cart.
Give me a sec, I need to fix my frames.
Give me like seven seconds.
I don't know.
That does not sound great.
That's it.
I'm pushing cart.
There's a Groot above us.
On the bridge.
Yeah, fuck that Groot in particular.
I don't have anything for it.
There's a Groot behind us.
Groot's one!
This is last, but...
Oh, skip five.
I don't see you, Mace.
I see you.
I have orb on you.
I have 96.
We're so healthy.
I have no idea.
Above us!
Okay,
perfect.
Wait, Gristal!
Grist one!
Nice.
We can kill Luna, maybe?
I'm getting off the cart.
So I can heal you back.
Wait, who's on cart, Diddy?
Bless the heroes.
Oh my god, I can't see anything!
Oh my god.
That's a good push, that's fine.
That was...
That was a pretty good ult from them.
That was a really good ult by them.
We pushed pretty far.
Of course the Eternity game has to be one of the sweatiest games I've played today.
Oh my god.
This has to be the most sweaty one.
Of them all.
Oh my god.
You know what's...
Oh my god, I'm not even tired.
That's the worst part.
That's actually...
The fucking worst part.
I'm not even tired.
I have like Rinka drilling right now.
Alright.
We're as wavy when you need them.
To be on the enemy team.
No, I haven't been tired this entire stream.
Not gonna lie.
I just haven't been tired this entire stream.
Lois death...
Deserves the eloderin.
That's insane.
That's always been me with rank.
That's why I can play super long hours.
I just get adrenaline from playing competitive for some reason.
I just love grinding rank.
I have to add rank in there just in case people put me out of context.
I just really like playing rank.
No, it doesn't hit.
It only hits when I stop playing.
But I can literally play for hours.
Actual long, long hours.
It's literally like...
I need heals real quick.
On Luna.
Oh my god, Yawana, Yawana!
That's chill.
Oh, Grizzlo!
I froze, I froze!
Oh no!
I'm trying to keep you up.
Patch you up.
Hit the wall, please.
Reload.
There's a wall, there's a wall, there's a wall.
There's two walls, too.
I have grit on me.
No!
Holy fuck!
What the fuck was that?
For so long!
He got off from it!
Alright, we just reset here.
He lived for so long!
Why is that hole there?
That shouldn't hit me, right?
Yep, thank god.
Brute's kind of high.
That's safe.
Brute's flanking with ult.
I torched it out.
K.O.!
Oh, we gotta push up soon, though.
Where is he?
I'm ulting.
Alright.
I'm dancing up top now.
Oh, you're walled off, you're walled off.
I'm okay, I got the rap!
My ult's over.
Nice, good job.
We should have Magneto.
I hope my other support players are healing the DPS.
I'm trying to make sure.
I froze Magneto.
You're walled off, you're walled off.
Bring on the chaos!
There's a Scarlet on your left.
So you should have Scarlet ult here.
Yeah.
I'm not close to ult yet for Brute.
Can we break the wall top right?
Can you top me off?
I need top off.
I have ult for Brute.
Top left, top left!
I have to use it.
We're down one.
There's a Luna right behind us.
We're down a lot, nevermind.
I can TP back.
We can Mantis ult.
Our Mantis is getting shot at.
Our Mantis is going in now.
Where's Mace?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Nevermind, I'm not scared anymore.
Let's make sure we don't get C9 here.
Break the wall, break the wall, break the wall.
I need top off.
I need top off, we're fine.
They used Luna ult.
That's really big.
We're good.
I guess not, I guess I leave.
I have ult for Brute.
And they used Bucky ult too.
They have tank ults.
Oh, Mantis, please.
Oh my god, we have double tank?
He's going off of Loki?
Oh my god, what is this?
Oh, I might die to this.
I froze him.
He's so low, he's one.
I'm pushing up with damage.
They have one more fight here.
But we don't have support ults.
What did they use that fight?
Brute.
Magneto.
But they haven't used their support ults here.
We need to just win, we don't have support.
How about a back up?
Back, back, back.
I don't know if our Magneto...
Magneto, you're walled up, you're walled up.
I might die though.
Nah, we have time, we have time.
They only have one on Taric.
Worst case scenario, I touch.
You touch for a second and then get off?
Yes.
I can't get to you all.
No!
We were so close.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was such a close game.
That was actually such a...
Oh my god.
We had two ults too.
That's actually... oh my god.
Oh, I guess we go again.
I guess we go again.
Minus 22, that's not bad.
Oh my god, I guess we go again.
Oh, that was such a...
That was a good game too.
I actually locked in.
I was so locked in too.
40k for solo tank is really good.
For triple support?
Triple support solo tank and I was able to grab 40k off of that?
It was actually insane.
Because then we also have 20k healing from the other two support.
Ruben got paid off.
Oh my god, imagine that.
They whispered to Ruben and was like...
Come on, you know you want her to keep going.
You know it.
Chai, thank you for the 5k subs.
Thank you.
Twitch Prime.
How do you pause the ad view when you're on bad loss streak?
Do you just keep grinding?
It's because I'm streaming.
If I'm toxic on stream, it's going to be over for me.
I think we ban Hulk first.
Oh man, the off stream.
Off stream when no one is streaming?
Oh...
Shit gets crazy.
I don't want to get cancelled.
Oh, they forgot to ban.
Oh man, no.
Off stream...
Off stream when no one is streaming?
Things get crazy.
Off stream me?
I'm not okay.
If you think current stream me is okay, it's not okay.
Off stream me is not okay.
He's a really good Iron Fist if he doesn't get shut down.
We're close.
We were literally one game off and then we got...
We had three support players.
Usually it works, but this time it didn't work.
This time.
The enemy team can finally say I beat a rank 1 player.
I should put that in their title.
I beat a rank 1 player and...
Oh my god, wait.
I can make a clickbait title right now.
Playing with...
Playing with the rank 1 player?
The rank 1 player?
Oh my god, look.
Oh my gosh, thank god I can clickbait.
The rank 1 player?
That's a YouTube upload right there.
I say as I don't do videos.
Wait, what the fuck?
What happened?
Oh my god, did we win?
Did we win the brawl?
I'll try to get another pick here.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was that brawl?
Huge.
That scared the shit out...
Oh my god.
Did you know they were gonna do that?
That's crazy.
Look, it's like, yes.
Oh, I might be dead here.
Oh my god.
He knew.
Only a rank 1 player would know.
Oh my god, he's whipping him.
He is Doctor Strange, of course.
That scared the shit out of me.
I was like, excuse me?
The fuck was that?
Oh my god.
I froze somebody.
Oh my god, he's climbing.
Oh my god, he's following him.
There's a magic here, right?
I got...
Oh, that was sick.
That was a sick ult right there.
You're so healthy.
No!
I cannot...
Where can I go?
Oh no.
Oh, Magnus won.
Magnus won.
Nice.
You look wicked while fucking ulting, bro.
Get dunked on.
Oh my god.
I cannot run it.
He hates K-pop.
My man fucking hates K-pop.
I mean, he's old.
He's like a grandpa.
I don't think he understands K-pop, guys.
He's seeping through a lot.
Yeah, he's old.
He hates new music.
I don't know.
I've never seen a Luna.
I don't know what it is.
I just...
What do I do?
I run.
And it still hits me.
I don't know what...
At least it just hits me, I guess.
Like, where do I go?
Where do I go?
Where the fuck do I go?
I don't know.
Someone please explain.
I want to be a better...
I guess I should position myself better.
I guess that's really it.
If I knew they have a Magneto, I'll just position myself better.
No!
I just witnessed a Titanic sinking.
Oh my god.
I just saw the Titanic sink there.
That was crazy.
Oh my god.
Thank you for the red!
I'm in a game right now.
I'm sorry.
I'll be back soon.
I'll do the usual stuff soon.
I just...
I gotta live.
Oh my god, he's healing in front of them.
Fucking crazy.
That tear doesn't heal!
I'm not gonna get hit.
I'm not...
Oh, the wall.
The map's changing.
They used both support ults.
I'm gonna go for a silent ult.
Win the fight here.
Is that Neymar's low?
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go!
I fear Magneto.
I'm so happy it wasn't me this time.
Live.
Just keep living.
Oh my god.
That's called prediction!
Jesus Christ.
Magics half.
Magics one.
Everything's fine!
See?
Everything's A-okay.
Oh, I have a C now!
Oh my god, I haven't played with an Iron Fist.
I always forget the Iron Fist team up.
But it's like...
I don't feel like I need to use it.
Because nobody's diving me and I just get the freeze.
Not that one though, but like...
You know, the other freeze.
When he's on me.
Jesus Christ.
There's a magic coming to you, Loki.
Don't worry!
You're so healthy!
There's a Magneto on point.
Oh my god!
The freeze almost went off!
That had to be ping.
What the- Adam got the- That had- That was ping right there.
I heard the sound register too.
I heard the fucking sound register.
I got really cocky though, I shouldn't have done that.
I definitely should not have tried that.
That's right.
No,
I couldn't press C!
I'm so not used to pressing C!
My fingers didn't know where to go.
Did they use Mantis ult?
Oh no, they're switching to it.
My fingers don't know where the C button is.
It's not used to pressing- It's been so long since I fucking pressed the C key.
That was like the most hell-mary thing I've done.
There's a Mantis to your left.
Adam's low.
Wait, what?
Where's the Namor thing?
Wait, where's the- Oh my god, it was in the center!
I was like, where was that?
I couldn't see it.
I was so confused.
I'm tipping us down on the left.
I'm tipping us safe, I'm tipping us safe.
Yo, they're Mantis and they're Magneto.
We got pick, we got pick, we got Magneto.
Behind us, behind us, right side, right side.
Mantis one, Mantis low.
I don't have- Namor to your left.
I'm asleep though.
Drop down if you need to.
There's Bucky.
Wait, Magneto, Magneto.
I'm damage boosting.
Nice.
Oh, behind us!
Oh, it was the other side.
Holy shit.
That was a crazy berserker that he did.
Oh my god, back to one more game.
Oh, I need to sit fast, dude.
I'll be right back, guys.
Back, everybody.
I'm back.
I just realized we've been getting this Loki guy, like, consistently.
And like, he's like- Is Loki just farming off of Bucky on our team?
He's like the plus- He's like our unofficial adopted player.
Like, he's just- He's just always there.
I realized.
He's just tagging along.
The unofficial forth.
Oh, wait, Craigie is on the enemy team.
Oh, it's them!
It's the Widow player.
Also, strange.
Thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you, thank you.
And Tobias, thank you for Twitch Prime.
Yeah, also- Well, as I was saying- Thank you so much for the raid, Cleo.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I do the stream on- Sorry, oh my god, I said Twitch.
I do the stream on the YouTube, but-
Oh, they banned Hella anyway.
Well, at least we banned someone else.
I guess we ban Hawkeye.
Please don't ban Psylocke.
Let's ban Hawkeye.
But yeah, I'm doing my rank right now on Twitch.
Because I don't know how long it's going to take me.
But like, surprisingly- It's not as long as I thought it would take me.
I think.
Alright.
Bro, I'm down bad.
Drop to GM one and let's just turn it up a little bit.
Oh my god, Luna Mantis.
This is a game- We almost have the perfect comp.
But then we got the one tricks.
We were so close to the perfect comp.
And then it's- It's our DPS.
It was so close.
We almost got there.
Our DPS is Widow Iron Fist.
Like- We were almost full meta.
The Black Widow- I swear, this is my eternity game.
I swear to fucking god.
This is my eternity game.
Who is he fucking right now?
Alright, who did he pick?
Who is- Oh, it's just the- Oh my god, everybody.
I'm excited.
Alright, the wall.
You'll never die, mace.
I like how we never saw- We never saw Wily.
Oh my god!
We never saw Wily again.
I think he legitimately Q dodged.
What did he kill?
Who did our Widow kill?
I didn't even pay attention.
It happened so fast.
Not gonna lie.
Oh my god, wait, they have no heals.
No sleep either.
There's an Iron Man.
Frozen?
Alright, that- Guys, was that- Oh, Strange is low.
Guys, that was-
Strange is so- Strange is one.
I have ult.
Is it worth it?
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
There we go.
Wow.
Oh my god.
Did you guys see that sick ass freeze?
Fucking reflexes.
Right there.
This is what I mean.
A Luna is so easy.
What makes a good Luna is literally just her- It's like, positioning and freezes.
I feel like.
I honestly feel like a really good Luna- A really good Luna has just insane- I see you, Mace.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Goodbye!
I froze him.
Bro.
I- I-
Oh my god.
This guy's gonna be on the list.
He's gonna be on Mace's list.
I can feel it.
I can feel him being mad.
He's gonna- That Iron Fist is gonna get on the list, guys.
I- I feel it.
I feel it so bad.
I don't think he's happy about the Iron Fist.
I legitimately don't think he's happy about the fact that- Oh.
Oops, I missed.
Whoa.
He's five.
Oh my god, good for him.
Oh.
Oh my god, what?
I- Oh, that's- Okay.
Fuck me.
I guess.
I don't know- Okay.
I literally- Like, okay.
I don't know, man.
I don't fucking know, man.
I don't know.
I- This
is awkward.
It was nice knowing you, Iron Fist.
But- I don't think- I don't think you're gonna have a good rank climb after Mace is done with you.
I- He's so- Yeah, I think- I don't think-
There's a- Iron Manta, right?
He's half.
Oh.
You're five.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
Back up, back up.
We're all alive.
I got a little bit scared when I said that.
But- I was like- I still have Lunala too.
I was like- Oh, thank god.
Technically, we're all still alive.
We're gonna TP back.
They should have Strangeld.
He's looking for it.
There's Peel to our right too.
Iron Man one!
I'm gonna ult this thing.
Back, back, back, back, back, back, back.
Back, back, back, back, back.
Heals, I'm on the point just dancing.
Back, back, Magneto.
Magneto's one.
What a comm.
I'm just on the point dancing.
If you want heals.
Nice.
Who she's playing that's rank one?
Look at the leaderboards.
And look who I have my snowflake on this entire time.
Look who's- Look who has it.
Other people low HP?
Nah.
I like turn- I'm scared of like turning around.
Is he okay?
No!
I- I legitimately blame the widow.
I actually looked up.
No way.
I looked away first.
Oh my god.
I actually looked away.
Never again.
Yeah, you ult first Ruben.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We can make it.
Yeah.
I don't know where he is.
I don't see him.
Oh, he's in the front.
He's looking for it.
He's looking all - Look above.
Oh my god!
We're alive!
I'm on damage.
I'm backing up.
Who's gonna be on cart?
Diddy.
Mantis should stay cart.
Yup, bad.
I'm on Saga.
Oh, nice!
No way!
Oh my god, thank god.
Thank god!
I'm- I just hide here.
I- Every time- Oh my god, if I hear- If I hear any of those fucking Magneto and Iron Man ult, I just run.
I don't look back.
I don't care if my teammates die.
As long as I live.
That's all I care about.
Maximum pulse.
I don't think this guy- I think this guy's gonna be on Mace's list.
He's definitely not happy.
He's- He's not happy.
Try freeze Iron Man?
Oh my god.
Okay, I froze Iron Man.
I did like some insane fucking freezes on that guy in this game alone.
Literally in this game alone I did some sick ass freezes on Iron Man.
But it's like, it's so risky.
Not something I would like to hear from the healer, but if it- Look, as somebody that's taken a fucking meteor and a fucking maximum pulse bomb to the face for the past 8 hours I'm just happy to be alive.
Iron Man's going low.
Oh my god, the Widow talks?
I didn't realize he talks.
He is a person!
No way!
He's a real person.
Who is he?
He added me and I said yes.
Because he's good.
I saw- He's fucking insane.
You know what I'm surprised by?
The lack of Luna bands.
Honestly.
Everybody just- Maybe these hours are just fucked in general.
This is like the least amount of Luna bands I've ever had.
That was a great prediction for me.
Oh my god.
There's a Black Panther!
I'm ulting.
Yeah...
I have 3 seconds left.
Oh my god, I'm fucking focusing so hard.
He has Strange ult.
I'll ult this.
I froze Strange.
He has ult, by the way.
I'm gonna stay here.
I swear to god, if I see this rock in- Okay, nice.
Okay, not nice.
Everybody's dying.
Oh, it's just us two.
Alright.
He's so healthy.
He's not a bad hold.
We should have Black Panther ult and Strange ult.
Actually, majority of the ults.
They don't have Mag ult.
They don't?
Oh.
Black Panther!
I've had one!
I'm ulting this to stabilize.
Oh!
Oh, he didn't get frozen.
I'm dead here.
He's still alive.
Who says I am?
He died.
We all died for our sins.
Okay, okay.
The Luna's to your right.
Magic slow too.
I am ready to put on a show!
Can we kill Magic?
Magic's one!
Oh, he's healed.
They're on me now.
Oh, goodbye.
I res, I res, I res.
Oh, Magnio's one!
Oh, he got healed.
Goodbye.
Bye.
Oh, we have Neymar!
Okay, bet.
Oh, he's still...
Oh
my god.
He got freed of the fucking list.
The Iron Fist one trick actually swapped.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
He is scared.
He is so scared.
He knows who's streaming right now.
There's Strange up top and he's...
Oh, I'm sorry.
My scroll wheel is still up.
I froze Strange.
I forgot.
I forgot about my scroll wheel.
Oh, backline is one!
I'm not the Lunatic!
It's so risky!
It's actually so...
Oh my god.
It's so...
I need to unbind the scroll wheel.
I was trying to ping.
Jesus Christ.
I have ult soon.
I froze somebody.
I have ult.
They're all really low.
Three seconds is gone.
Oh my god.
Oh, that's huge!
Do they have Strange ult?
Yeah, they do have Strange ult.
Alright, they should have Magical too.
We need to hold coast.
We don't have any ult.
Yo, back up, back up, back up.
Oh, no, no, no!
Hold fucking close!
He angry!
Strange point behind me!
He's trying to look.
Lunas one!
I need to reload.
I have a magic on me.
I know Adam too.
I'm dead here, I think.
I'm so low.
I can get support here.
Just live, Adam.
It has to be me.
It has to be somebody.
I have ult, I have ult, I have ult!
Stand on my ult.
We have to pick, we have to pick.
I froze Strange, I froze Strange.
I have to back up now.
Oh my god, Strange on me.
I need to reload.
Strange behind you!
I'm on it, I'm on it, I'm on it!
I'm dead for it though.
Oh my god!
It's just magic!
Take Canyon!
Oh my god!
We're all here!
What a fucking crazy...
That was a crazy fucking game.
That was actually...
That's me!
Oh my god, it's me!
That's actually me!
I fucking did it!
Oh my god!
So what if we just lose it right now?
Look!
There I am!
Oh my god!
Shout out to Mace!
Shout out to Mace and Ruben!
Oh my god!
What a fucking rough day!
Thank you for the 100 babies!
Thank you!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Shout out to Ruben and Mace's channel!
If they're still awake...
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
I'm so fucking happy!
Oh my god!
We were here!
We were fucking here!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me move over a little bit.
Oh my god, thank you!
Hey, there's me right there!
Oh my god, there I am!
There I am!
Oh my god!
Thank you, numbers!
For 50 gifted subs!
Thank you!
Oh!
No, it's not over!
There's still top 500 left!
There's still one above all!
And top 500!
It's not over!
Thank you for the 10 gifted subs!
Thank you!
Oh my god!
It's not over, everybody!
Now it's on the top 500!
The ride never ends!
We did it!
We were all here!
That was a crazy win though!
Holy fuck!
That last match...
My fucking touch for the cart...
My run for the cart...
So that my DPS and tank...
Can do their big ass fucking strange ult...
And just slap the people on cart...
Was fucking crazy!
Oh my god!
The fact that like...
It was 0.0!
I was like screaming!
I was like I'm going in!
I'm gonna touch it!
Thank you for the 5 gifted subs!
Thank you, thank you!
The 0.07 touch to get a huge shout out to Mason Rubin!
Did my mods do their shout out yet?
I don't remember, but like...
Did they do the shout out to their channels if they're still around?
We win this mystery today!
Oh my god!
Are my mods even alive?
I don't think they're alive anymore.
I don't think they're alive!
We've been going at it for a while.
I'm not surprised.
Alright.
Huge shout out to Mendo for letting me poach Mace.
Huge shout out to Mendo for letting me poach him into my own squad.
I think this is Mace.
Is Mace just Mace?
I'm gonna look up Mace.
Mace.
Is it Mace or like M4CE?
M4CE.
Oh, Mace is just Mace.
Wait, you are the Brig 1!
Wait, are you the Brig 1 trick Mace?
Are you?
No, okay, you're tank.
Okay, I just saw...
Wait, you're the Brig 1 trick Mace?
That's you?
Oh my god.
Oh no, you were the former tank player.
Oh, you were Mace in the face!
That was you?
Oh my god.
I can't believe that was you.
I hate it.
No, I'm joking.
I definitely avoided the count once at least.
I...
I definitely avoided Mace to the face at least once.
No, okay.
Oh my god.
I can't believe he is the Brig 1 tank player.
It's okay, he's reformed now.
Now he's back on Strange.
Now he's back on Strange and Magneto.
He's reformed now.
But yes, he would shout out to... No!
I was joking.
I was just a hee-haw banter.
Please Mace, I just got here.
I just got here.
Oh my god.
I was joking.
Come on, I even followed you.
I even followed you.
Come on.
Come on, man.
Oh my god.
Shout out to Mace and Ruben.
The DPS.
Remember to adopt a tank today.
Adopt your fellow tank to climb.
Oh my god.
I knew it.
That was the dream combo.
Just put an orb on the tank player.
Farm your ult off of them.
Just let them fucking go at it.
And then press Q.
Thank you.
God, that's me right now.
Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh my god, we did it.
Someone screenshot real quick.
I'm gonna screenshot my own screenshot.
Let me hide it real quick.
I need to screenshot this and goodbye chat.
I gotta...
That's me.
I gotta do that and then welcome back chat.
Let me tweet that right now.
Oh my god.
Remember to adopt a fellow tank today.
Now on to one above all.
Which is just 24 hours, but still.
Now on to Now we go for one above all.
Slash top 500.
Did I spell Ruben's name wrong?
Ruben.
No, I didn't.
Nice, I did it.
Okay, we're not top 10, guys.
Oh my god, it's...
Thank you Mendo for letting me poach mace.
I really appreciate it.
I wonder if they're climbing.
I wonder.
Give me a sec.
We got it.
Oh, I'm plus 34.
Wow!
I mean, we could actually, technically if you think about it...
Wait, what's top 500?
Oh, that's like 5, 6, 7...
That's like 3 wins.
I don't know about that.
Not at 8.42am.
Technically!
Oh, you see?
Oh shit, Wavy!
Aww, Wavy!
What happened after?
Oh, he limited.
It's only 3 more wins, technically.
Wouldn't it be fucking crazy if I just lose Eternity?
If I just lose Eternity right there?
Oh my god.
Wouldn't that be fucking crazy?
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Alright, let me check out Mendo's progress.
I know he's playing with HotSick.
Not that bad.
Oh!
Wait, is Spu...
Wait, let me check Spu.
Okay, wait, Mace.
Which squad was that?
So what?
Okay, I'll also shout out Mendo for letting me poach Mace.
Because like, legitimately Mace is fucking insane.
What happened?
Oh my god.
I have Mace.
I can't just ask them to keep going.
What if they have to sleep?
What happened?
Oh my... Do we... I can't...
Okay, this is Mace and Ruben's decision.
We read in-game chat.
We're getting Doki.
We found it and we did and now she's out there playing more.
I am a slave and it's over!
I did one damage!
You played with me for like two to three hours and that felt like 850 miles.
Intention serpent dude.
Oh my god.
Okay, but do we really end on a win streak though?
Do we really?
Oh my god.
I could literally lose Top 500.
Like lose Eternity right now.
That would be so silly.
That would be so fucking silly.
Look, okay.
Q, okay!
Look, Mace says Q.
Alright, if we lose, we're out.
Because I have 34 points of like... I can have one loss.
I get one loss.
Exactly, we can't end on a win.
Let's go.
Let's fucking go.
Mace has spoken.
Mace has fucking spoken.
Alright.
If we lose, we stop.
Exactly, gamblers quit early.
Okay, I need to be like...
I need to be like Let me be like Thanks Mendo for letting me poach Mace.
It truly was game changing.
Oh my god.
No, we lose?
If we lose the next game, we literally start to...
What do you mean?
Nice, I love you and I've only had Jeff since he left.
Oh my god.
How does that mean?
I'm thanking him.
Oh my god.
Poor Mendo.
Also, here's Mendo's...
Here's Mendo's...
Here's Mendo's stream too.
Shout out to Mendo too.
It was him.
It was because of him that we were able to accomplish this.
Alright.
Man.
That's rough though.
That's rough, buddy.
I can't.
He's three stacking.
Wait.
We can six stack, but that might be...
It might take 20 years.
It might take 20 years before...
Yeah, if you guys want to know what rank one player...
No, six stack takes a long time in this ELO apparently.
It takes an incredibly long time from what I've heard.
I don't know though.
I'm not in this ELO often.
Like, this is literally my...
I don't know.
I just got here.
I just got Eternity.
I don't know.
Only Mace knows.
He's like the actual person that knows.
Oh my god.
We don't have to ban Hulk.
We actually have a Hulk player.
This is the real Mace to face.
Wow.
Oh my god.
He's famous.
I'm here too.
Inside my chest.
I'm here.
Hi, I'm Doki.
I'm Doki bird.
Doki who?
Oh my god.
Is this...
Oh, you're the brig guy.
I like how everybody knows who he is.
Wait, what do we ban?
What do we ban?
I never got this far.
Doctor Strange?
Let's fucking do it.
Let's go.
Oh.
We need somebody to go Iron Man.
Iron Man now.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Alright, this is it.
Doki.
Doki, that's your Q.
This is my game.
Do you take prize?
Bro, he's like some fucking terrorist or some shit.
Everyone's like, fuck, it's him.
Scatter.
It's fucking him.
Time for the best character.
Guys, 100 gifted guys.
No.
100 said she give you the...
Wait.
Chat.
Chat, can I have an IOU?
Chat?
Chat, can I have...
Can I have an IOU, guys?
Oh, it's Doki Bird.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Guys, can I have an...
You can spot me, right?
Fucking...
You can spot me, right, guys?
I just need like 200.
Just a little bit.
Can't be that much.
Can you guys spot me real quick?
Jesus Christ.
Wait, are we lagging?
Wait.
Oh, my God, wait, I'm fucking...
Everybody's like actually TPing a little bit for me.
Oh, my God, I was lagging a little bit.
That was crazy.
Wait, no!
Oh, my God!
Holy shit, that poor man.
That poor man.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, what's happened?
What happened?
I'm TPing back, I'm TPing back, just live right now.
Holy shit, that was crazy.
Take TP, take TP, take TP, come, come, come.
Where's TP?
Take TP!
I'm here.
I don't think they're taking TP.
It's just me and you.
I'm scared.
Oh, holy fuck!
Holy fuck!
Oh, my God.
That's crazy.
Guys, I don't...
Yeah, that was...
That was pretty rough.
Where's my...
Okay.
Don't worry, Ironman.
We should have banned Hulk.
Who gives a fuck about our one trick?
We should have banned him.
Oh, my God, I'm scared.
Oh, my God, I'm so scared.
Oh, my God, we should fight this now.
We should 100% fight this.
Oh, he's fucking mad.
Oh, my God.
I don't know where that is.
I don't...
Oh, we got it.
Oh, my God, you're fine!
Oh, my God, you're so healthy!
They have over, you know.
Oh, my God!
That's a fucking lie!
Yeah, you think they can afford it?
Oh, my God, it feels like...
They have Wolverine on.
Oh, I need help.
I need help from Hulk.
Oh, Wolverine won.
Oh, my God!
I don't think you'll live.
You live.
Oh, my God, he actually...
Wait, Strangelove, Strangelove!
Oh, my God!
Wait, Wolverine's so low.
Wolverine's really low.
Okay.
Iron Man, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Wait, there's someone behind us.
Man, this man is frozen.
That's fucking right!
I deserve to be in this ego!
That was the sickest freeze!
Okay, he got nothing off of that.
I think they have Hulk ult, right?
I have to reload.
There it is!
Hulk is one, Hulk is one!
I deserve to be here!
I'm fucking insane!
Oh, my God, what did Mendoz say?
I was too busy winning.
I saw what he said.
3, 2, 1, now.
I'm jerky.
I saw what he said.
Bubbling 7, Bubbling 6, Bubbling 5.
Bubble whenever you go in.
You should have Iron Man ult here.
Iron Man 1, Iron Man 1.
Bubbling 8, Bubbling 7, Bubbling 6.
Kite that, kite that, kite, kite, kite.
I'm not using it, I'm not...
Oh, I have to use it then.
I'm here to save you, Ruben.
I'm ulting it on you.
You might die.
No ult, no ult, no ult, no ult.
Hulk dead, Hulk dead, Hulk dead.
Okay, bye yourself.
Oh!
Goodbye.
Wait, it's still winnable.
Nevermind.
Okay, you guys can get out.
We can heal you.
Oh my god, you lived.
They use Gamma, they use Gamma.
Just live, they use Gamma.
Oh my god.
You're so... Oh, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Oh, Iron Man.
Strange low, strange low.
Hulk is half, Hulk is frozen.
Hulk is 1, Hulk is 1.
Baby Hulk, baby Hulk.
Raccoon?
Yay!
Okay, what do you say?
I'm...
Oh my god.
Having fun.
I just...
You're so...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, bro is losing it.
Okay, you know what would tell someone?
Don't keep, please.
Oh my god.
Finally, the curse of Ra is not on me.
Everything is turning around for Doki.
That's fucked.
Everything is turning around.
For Doki.
I'm gonna jinx it, aren't I?
They're gonna fucking push it all the way and snowball us.
I can feel it.
The one time I feel happiness for myself.
The one time I feel good about myself.
It's gonna happen.
I can feel it.
Hulk's alright.
Oh my god, I can't help you there.
Okay, I don't feel good.
Oh, bro.
Yeah, you can't go too deep.
We can kite here.
Yeah, I'm kiting back.
There's a strange on us.
Wrap around, wrap around our main.
Yeah, we're here, we're here.
I'm going all the way back.
Main, main.
This way, this way, this way.
I don't know if I can touch this, bro.
Touch, touch, touch.
Oh, I got grabbed.
I need help behind.
I'm frozen, I'm frozen, I'm frozen.
Someone get the Hulk if you can.
Oh, no, it's behind us.
It was behind us.
Oh my god.
It's just the tings.
Yeah, there's Doki.
Get out of there.
Yeah, I'm going the other way.
It's fine, this point should be more open for our Iron Man to fight.
We can bubble you whenever you get him though.
Bubble, bubble, bubble.
Oh my god, he came out of nowhere.
I was excited.
Do you have bubble?
Yeah, no, I don't have bubble.
But I'm ulting, I'm ulting, you just watch.
Hulk is low, Hulk is low.
Hulk is out.
I can bubble you, Iron Man.
Focus change, focus change.
This is ridiculous high ground for Punisher.
Holy crud.
I have to reload, I can't heal you.
I need heals, I need heals.
Let me know.
Do you have gamma, do you have gamma?
I need heals.
Let him walk a bit.
Back, back, back, kite the Z, kite the Z.
Back, back, back, back.
I'm not ulting this.
Oh my god.
I'm bubbling 8, I'm bubbling 7.
Bubbling 3, bubbling 2.
We should push up.
Left side, left side, there's a rocket.
In the building.
In the heart, uh, strange.
I can't see you guys for heals.
He dies, he dies, he dies, he dies.
Nice.
Make sure I have Iron Man ult here and, uh, strange ult.
And Hulk ult too.
I'll make sure I...
Oh, he got exiled.
Oh my god, noob.
Nice.
Did I get anybody?
Oh, that's bad.
Don't worry, don't worry, it's gone.
I froze Hulk.
Behind you, behind you, behind you!
Ow.
I have to reload.
I can't heal you, Iron Man.
If I can't heal you, you're L.S.
I come back to punish for ult.
Do we need it?
Uh, no, not yet, not yet.
Iron Man, are you okay?
I'm gonna use gamma, I'm gonna use gamma.
Bubble, bubble.
I have to reload, can't heal you.
Bubble in seven, bubble in six.
Bubble in three, for you, Iron Man.
Two, one, walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
I suck.
Oh, he fucking...
I can't heal you anymore.
I'm gonna ult this.
Stun.
Oh, nice.
Can we stagger him?
Yeah.
Yeah, stagger him.
What if he just kills you?
Nice.
Good stagger.
They have Iron Man ult here.
And Strange ult, but I don't have Nuke.
I'm gonna eat it with my ult.
Oh, Iron Man, Iron Man bought it, Iron Man bought it.
He's looking for it.
Iron Man is literally behind us right now.
I got exiled.
Keep me up, keep me up.
I'm gonna reload.
It's fine, we stalled for a long time.
I'm dying.
This play is really good for a bubble.
Oh my god, I messed my...
I messed my freezes there.
Oh my god.
I messed up my freezes.
I need to remember he bubbles...
Hulk bubbles in when he jumps in.
I need reload, I need reload.
Oh my god, he gets exiled.
They're all low, they're actually all low.
When he gets exiled, it's not cool.
This is how he gets rank 1, everybody!
This is how he does it, look at these comms!
Look at these comms!
I'm gonna kill Iron Man.
I can bubble you, I'm going to bubble you.
I don't see you for heals.
I got you.
I need reload.
I gotta make sure he misses.
Bubble in 6, bubble in 5, bubble in 4.
Hulk to our left.
Bubble in 6, bubble in 5.
Bubble in 2, bubble in 1, Iron Man.
I'm ulting this, I'm ulting this.
Oh my god, we're so heavy!
We're still so heavy!
We're so heavy!
Wait, they Hulk ulted, they Hulk ulted.
I'm backing up.
They're trying to portal us off, they're trying to portal us off.
I got exiled.
Get out of spawn, get out of spawn.
I got out.
I had to bubble myself.
Oh, I couldn't do anything.
I'm rezzed, I'm rezzed, I'm rezzed.
I'm trying to keep her.
I had to bubble myself again.
Oh my god, he bubbled it, of course he did.
I need to run very thick.
No!
That Hulk is good.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is an intense game.
This is an intense one.
This is why we ban Hulk.
I don't know.
I see you Hulk one trick, but I fucking hate playing against Hulk.
I didn't remember.
When he jumps in, he bubbles.
So, to dodge my freeze.
Fucking insane.
I think we have Mantis, maybe?
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I'm fucking gaming.
Yeah.
Yeah, now I'm actually...
Oh no, he's on the list.
He's on the list now, guys.
Oh no.
He's ready.
He's ready to put him on the fucking list.
We also have to ban...
Oh, I didn't get a chance.
I can't orb you there.
It's alright.
Yep.
Back, back, back, back.
Drop, drop, drop.
I reload.
Hulk is coming over.
I can bubble Iron Man now.
I reload.
Strange can die.
I reload here.
Oh, he took so much damage.
I have 91.
I can Luna ult this.
I'm Luna ulting.
I'm on it, I'm on it, I'm on it, I'm on it.
I'm keeping back.
Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk, Hulk.
Cap point, cap point, cap point.
They can't touch, they can't touch point.
There's an Iron Man.
Oh my gosh.
I'm dead.
Oh, Strange is half.
Oh no.
Hulk half.
Oh, this is intense.
You're not allowed to play that on your ult.
Oh my god, I have to reload.
Change.
Change your rocket, change your rocket.
Oh my god.
That's actually...
Oh my god, that's crazy.
It is winnable.
Bro, hitting an Iron Man is so fucking stressful.
It's so...
Cause like, they're all high ELO players so their movement is so fucking hard to predict.
Cause they have to be like...
They have to have really fucking insane movement.
But as a support player it's so fucking tilting to heal that.
I literally like...
I was like...
I know you're trying not to die but oh my...
I know you're not trying to die but holy fuck your movement is too good.
And then I'm moving too cause I don't wanna die too.
Like, I don't wanna die so I have to move too.
So like, I have to do mega prediction on two good...
Double good movements.
Like...
Oh my god.
It's actually...
Holy shit.
It's so stressful.
I'm just setting up A.
This is stressful as fuck.
Holy fuck.
Guys, I don't think we...
There's a possibility...
Okay.
I'm gonna go in with my shift.
I can't.
I froze somebody?
Oh my god.
Dude, they used...
Why didn't we use Z?
They used Z and we just lose?
Um, I got respawned so I might die.
Yeah, you just gotta die again.
We gotta make sure we use Z first.
Like, as soon as we...
Z.
Oh, they got staggered.
Oh my god, guys.
That was a great game, guys.
It do be like that.
This is rough.
This is actually rough.
I have to reload.
Maximum pulse!
Nice.
Strange is low!
Strange is so low!
Got him, got him, got him.
I'm gonna save my Reynald.
Well, Ironman, Ironman.
Shoot Ironman, shoot Ironman.
I have to...
back up.
He was on your right.
He was on your right window.
Back to you.
Reload.
Go point, go point.
We have to go point.
I have Luna ult, but they have all their ults.
They saved everything.
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
I'm backing up a little bit.
There's a Hulk behind you guys.
Can we cut this?
Oh yeah, I have the ult.
There's a Hulk beating us behind.
That's huge, that's huge, that's huge, Hulk.
I'm backing up.
Oh, I couldn't get it.
No!
I almost got the freeze too!
That was a really good game though.
Oh my god.
That was a really good game.
Oh.
Guys, if I lose the next one, I'm out of eternity.
I can't.
We'll go again next time.
That was a really good game though.
Exclamation point, Luna.
Why I don't use the tech.
Oh my god.
See, I'm still there.
Let's go.
I just gotta wait.
It's bitch time, it's bitch time.
I like that game though.
That game was insane.
That was an insane game that we had.
Oh my, I had fun.
Okay, 10 more games.
You got like 4 hours.
Tomorrow.
Maybe.
Or later today.
I bitched.
Alright.
Mendo gets his carry back.
Oh my god.
That was good.
That was a good game.
I think I did really well.
I think like, if I did that freeze on the strange, I think we would've clutched it.
But like, that shit was like, I did so many freezes already.
I'm fucking...
Just one less freeze like, you know, really changes the game.
But yeah, for those who are wondering why I don't do the scroll wheel tech it's because it's bugged right now.
The fact that you can do the scroll wheel tech and it can stay on damage.
It'll stay heal, it stays heal on your screen, but it'll stay, it'll be on damage.
Like, in the game it'll be on damage.
And I don't do that because like I did it this morning, I did it yesterday Oh my god, this morning.
Right now it's this morning.
I did it yesterday and um, and I got, I I lost the game because of it.
Because uh, it stayed on damage even though on my screen it says heal.
And it happened twice.
So, uh so like, I don't do it because it's too risky.
I manually press Q.
Um, I don't do scroll wheel.
Uh, but I don't spam it too.
If I spam it, it triggers it.
It's something to do with spamming it, basically.
If you spam the Q too much, basically it'll stay on damage.
So I just press Q.
Um, but yes, thank you everybody!
Huge shout out to Mace, Ruben, Mendo for letting me poach him.
Uh, we did it!
Yeah!
It was great meeting the rank 1 guy.
I can't believe I didn't know who he was.
I was just like, who the fuck is Mace?
And then like, you guys have to tell me he's rank 1.
Um, I still don't know how he sneaked right in.
Uh, yes, nice to meet you Mace!
Go again another time!
I had a great time playing with you.
Um, I didn't know.
I don't keep track of the date.
I can't believe he was Mace to the face.
Like, I avoided... I know I definitely avoided a Brig 1 trick called Mace to the face before.
I...
LOL LOL Mace, you can't lie!
You must have got avoided by so many people as a Brig 1 trick in Overwatch 2.
Who the fuck means...
We had no friends!
Literally, the moment we loaded in, the moment we... Oh my god, did you get paid off?
You must have got paid off didn't you?
Guys, guys, no gifted.
Just like, excuse me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, look at this.
Is this the real?
Wait, wow, Mr. Mace?
No friends.
Sign my chest.
Do you have a marker?
At Mace.
And then, this is my...
Mace got that, that's why.
Woah, woah, woah.
Donkey Bird said she gave me 200 gifted.
Who's Donkey Bird?
LOL If anybody, I'm the one with no friends.
I literally got...
Who's Donkey Bird?
Right here.
LOL It's not like my stream was on the second or third.
It's not like my stream was top 3 of all my rivals, but who the fuck is Donkey Bird?
LOL I got humbled real quick.
I got humbled.
Ego check there.
Hey guys, I'm gonna head to bed.
I don't know if I'm gonna go again today or later today, but thank you everybody for coming.
For those who are new here, my name is Donkey Bird.
Please check me out on YouTube.
I usually stream over there for my schedule streams.
I do guerrilla streams on Twitch, so please follow me on Twitter.
If you wanna like, if you wanna know when I'm streaming on Twitch, which is basically like, you know, like I said, it's basically whenever I...
Who's messaging?
Okay, so we're running out of fuel.
I said I got plenty of fuel in the tank.
We can't iron on the loss.
Goodbye, Ruben.
I'm sorry.
I ran out of fuel.
Mace isn't even here.
I'm sorry.
LOL
I was gonna say, oh yes, if you wanna support me via other means, I have merch!
So I have a couple of different merch.
I have a custom PC.
See, I think the custom PC case has been sold out and keycaps, but we still have the wall scroll, the mouse pad, the desk mat, and the charm that's still being sold.
And then we have the gamer subcode.
And also, for those who are like, who the fuck is JokeyBread?
I have a Nendoroid.
LOL I mean, I have...
I have a Nendoroid that is like up for pre-order.
And that's me.
That's retro version me.
So like, I have different...
What if I just raid Mace's empty... LOL That's so fucked.
I'll raid Reaven.
I'll be like, what if I just raid like Mace's empty... LOL Like no stream.
That's so fucked.
LOL
But anyway, I have a Nendoroid.
If you do !Nendoroid, you can pre-order my own Nendoroid.
And if I get enough pre-orders for this one, there's a potential for a Nendoroid for my new skin suit, which is the one you see right now.
So yeah.
Ruben abuse.
Hey!
I chose a gamer over gamers.
And then Mace was like, these guys look like they're having fun.
I'm tired of the one tricks that Mendo's getting.
These guys look like...
LOL
Oh yeah, Mace, I don't know if you saw this, but Mendo's not having a good time ever since you left.
He's not having a great time.
He was the good luck charm that you needed.
LOL Bro, it's all your fault.
I have another scroll, one chicken, and I have this.
I got him like 8 wins!
How many wins did I got?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 2, 4, 6, 8.
Oh, I got 8 wins too!
Look at that.
We're both equal.
LOL I got 8 wins as well.
Yippee!
Mace, please check out my Nendoroid and pre-order it if you want to.
I mean, it's pretty cute.
It's pretty fucking cute, not gonna lie.
Is that everything I have to show?
That's everything, right?
Anyway, subscribe to my YouTube.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
As always, everyone, stay hydrated, posture checked, and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, guys.
You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye!